AMMAN OR TO BE IN THE CHAIR.
THIS STEAM JOINT COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES
TO BE ABLE TO BE WITH US. IT IS
MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME OUR NEW
VICE CHAIR FROM THE STATE
ASSEMBLY WE HAVE A SIMILAR
NUMBER STONE HERE FROM THE
WONDERFUL CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK. HE WAS ACTIVE AND ENGAGED
LAST YEAR AND JUST WANT TO SAY
HOW EXCITED WE ARE TO WORK WITH
YOU ASSUME NUMBER STONE. WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING FROM THE VICE
CHAIR HERE AND JUST AT THAT AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
IN OCTOBER WE HELD A HEARING IN
EUREKA JUST A FEW BLOCKS FROM
THE DOCKS AND NOW WE ARE
THRILLED TO HAVE OUR FISHERMEN.
COME TO THE CAPITAL ONCE AGAIN
FOR THIS TIME HONORED TRADITION
FOR FRTY FIVE YEARS EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERY SPECIFIC
COMMITTEES AND ORGANIZATIONS.
ASSOCIATIONS COUNCILS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR FISHERMEN
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. ANNUAL
REPORT IN AND REPORT ON THEIR
GOALS. YEARLY ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. IN THIS YEAR'S
FORUM TAKES ON SPECIAL
IMPORTANCE IN THE REASON BEING
IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LOOMING
DANGEROUS PROPOSAL TO OPEN UP
NEARLY THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
COAST TO NEW OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS DRILLING. AND THIS IS A
MASSIVE THREAT TO DO IN
POTENTIAL ASSAULT ON
CALIFORNIA'S SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR COMMERCIAL FISHING
INDUSTRY UNDER TWO BILLION
DOLLAR RECREATIONAL FISHING IN
HISTORY.
CFA PRESIDENCY GREATER THAN MAN
WHOSE NAME IS ON THIS FORM.
SPENT NEARLY A DECADE FIGHTING
SIMILAR OFFSHORE OIL PROPOSALS
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND I
KNOW THAT HE WOULD BE SHOCKED
THAT WE ARE RIGHT BACK AT IT
AGAIN WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION
WE THOUGHT WE WON THAT WAR. AND
WHILE THIS LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR IS WORKING OVERTIME AND
YOU WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU SECRETARY LAYERED FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK TO PROTECT OUR
COAST. WORKING OVERTIME TO TURN
BACK THIS DANGEROUS PLAN. WE
MUST DOUBLE OUR EFFORTS TO WIN
THIS BATTLE ONCE AND FOR ALL
BECAUSE NEW OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING IS THE LAST THING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FISHING FLEET NEEDS
AT THE MOMENT. YOU ALL HAVE
ENOUGH FIRES TO DEAL WITH. FOR
EXAMPLE ARE FISHING PORTS
COMMUNITIES IN TRIBES UP AND
DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST WHOSE
HEALTH AND VITALITY. IN
ECONOMIES RELYING ON ROBUST
FISHERIES ARE THREATENED THEY'RE
THREATENED BY. CHANGING OCEAN
CONDITIONS THAT'S RESULTED IN A
SERIES OF DISASTER CRAP. SALMON
SARDINE AN URCHIN ARE ALL LIKELY
ANDIDATES FOR OFFICIAL DISASTER
DECLARATIONS WITH CRAB ALREADY
DETERMINED. THAT DIGITALLY
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS HAVE
IMPACTED MANY OTHER SPECIES FROM
SALMON AND SARDINES TO CROW IN
WALES. CALIFORNIA IS FACING A
NEW REALITY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NO LONGER A
THEORY. IT'S HERE IT'S HERE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT IS
PAYING THE PRICE. NO MATTER HOW
LOUD SOME IN WASHINGTON DC MAY
SHOUT AND DENY. WE ARE STILL
SUFFERING FROM CALIFORNIA'S
EXTENDED DROUGHT FOR WATER
MANAGEMENT KILLED MORE THAN NINE
WE'RE PAYING THAT PRICE IN FULL.
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT THE RECENT
SALMON IN HOT WATER REPORT BY
CAL TROUT IN UC DAVIS TODAY.
THAT REPORT CONCLUDED THAT
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S REMAINING SALMON
STEELHEAD IN TROUT ARE WORSE OFF
TODAY THAN THEY WERE. ONE DECADE
AGO UNDER PRESENT POPULATION
TRENDS FORTY FIVE PERCENT.
NEARLY HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATIVE SALMON ARE LIKELY TO BE
EXTINCT IN THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS.
DUE TO CHANGE CLIMATIC
CONDITIONS AND WARMER WATER
TEMPERATURES IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING SOON. AND WE ALSO
KNOWN SOME TRIBUTARIES. THIS
EXTINCTION HAS BEEN SPED UP. NOW
THERE IS SOME GOOD NEWS TO BE A
REPORT AS WELL. BY WORKING
TOGETHER OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT
NUMBER ONE. WE TURNED THAT
TURNED BACK THE PROPOSAL TO
RAISE LANDING FEES IN SOME CASES
BY THIRTEEN THOUSAND PERCENT.
AND I WANNA TAKE MOMENT SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FLEET FOR YOUR
MOBILIZATION LAST YEAR FOR
STANDING STRONG AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU. ATTRIBUTE FOR
DIRECTOR BOTTOMS WORK ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS ISSUE. AND OTHER WILL
NOT BE IN HIS CHAIR THRONE THIS
YEAR SO THEY TRULY ADDRESS ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEVER TO
WE'VE SUCCESSFULLY FOUGHT TO
ENSURE EFFICIENT WHILE LIFE WILL
IMPLEMENT FISHERY BY FISHERY
BUDGETING. THIS WILL ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY ON HOW EACH FISHERY
IS THE SAME THING WE ALSO WANT
TO TO GOVERNOR BROWN AND
SECRETARY
LAYERED THAT DAY HAVE BEEN
SHOUTING LOUD AND PROUD ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S. CRAB
FISHING FLEET IN THIS WOULD NOT
HAPPEN WITHOUT THE SECRETARY
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR AS WELL AS GOVERNOR BROWN
FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE WORKING
THIS GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AS WELL PLEASE.
OUR NEXT FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
SALMON SARDINE IN SEA URCHINS.
WE HAVE WRITTEN A GOVERNOR
REQUESTS THE SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE TO CALL FOR A
DECLARATION OF THE SALMON
SARDINE IN SEA URCHIN FISHERY
DISASTER HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
GOVERNOR SUPPORTED THESE
REQUESTS AND WE AWAIT THE
NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE. DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE
RESPONSES. THESE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE CONGRESSIONAL FUNDING.
IN AS WE KNOW THESE DAYS CAN BE
A BIT TOUGH BUT I KNOW THAT WE
WILL NOT STOP WORKING UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO BRING HOME THOSE
DOLLARS TO HELP OUR FISHING
COMMUNITY CAN THRIVE. AND NUMBER
FOUR LAST YEAR WE WERE QUITE
SUCCESSFUL IN PASSING FISHERY
RELATED LEGISLATION SEVEN BILLS
WERE PASSED AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA'S FISH FISHING
INDUSTRY. SUCH AS SJR SEVEN
WHICH PROVIDES A CLEAR
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE TO PROTECT
AND RESTORE SALMON IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE BENEFIT OF COMMERCIAL
AND RECREATIONAL AND TRAVEL
FISHERIES. SP EIGHT OR NINE
WHICH SUPPORTS THE STATE AQUA
CULTURE PROGRAM WITH CONTINUED
FUNDING IN EIGHTY NINE OR FOR
WHICH ALLOWS A LOBSTER FISHERMEN
TO FORM A LOBSTER COMMISSION.
THIS YEAR AS WE LOOK AHEAD WE'VE
INTRODUCED WITH VICE CHAIR STONE
THE FISHING ON THIS BILL WHICH
WILL CONTINUE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMERCIAL SAME INSTANT PROGRAMS
IT CLARIFIES AND SIMPLIFIES. THE
INTRO THE HARVEST IN HUMBLE BAY
ALL THIS AS WE LIKE TO CALL
WILD WEST.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING GOT WELL
AGAIN WE COULD NOT BE MORE
EXCITED THAT ALL OF YOU ARE HERE
TODAY. WE ENCOURAGE SPEAKERS AND
NOT ONLY IDENTIFY PROBLEMS BUT
ALSO ADMINISTRATIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
HELP OUR FISHERMEN STAY AFLOAT.
AND EXPEDITE RECOVERY OF OUR
FISHERIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO I'D LIKE TO
BETTER TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR MISTER STONE. AND ALSO TO
LIKE TO TAKE MOM TO WELCOME THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY MISTER DALI.
THE FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE IS
A BIPARTISAN ISSUE. MISTER DALI
HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE CHAMPION
FOR THE FISHING FLEET AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL HAT HE'S JOINED US
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR PHONE INTERNET OVER THE
REPUBLICAN ¸DER
COMMENTS MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HIGHLY SORT
OF FOR THE. CANDY THAT YOU
ALWAYS BRING TO THESE HEARINGS
AND I'M SORRY THAT I MISSED THE
DINNER LAST NIGHT IS REALLY ONE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR YEAR TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE. WITH THE
FISHING INDUSTRY AND AND HAVE A
GREAT MEAL AND HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION.
REALLY PLEASED TO BE ACTUALLY ON
THE COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN COMING
FOR AWHILE AND NOW I'M
OFFICIALLY HERE AND THEY MADE ME
VICE CHAIR NOT SURE QUITE HOW
THAT HAPPENED BUT I'M VERY HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU AND. AND THIS
COMMITTEE AND AS WE LOOK TO THE
HARD WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
CONTINUE TO BE DONE THIS YEAR.
THIS COMMITTEE THIS.
STRENGTH OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE MORE THAT THAT WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ALL OF THE
STAKE HOLDERS AND THE FISHING
INDUSTRY. HELPS US HAVE A
CONSISTENT APPROACH TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED HERE AS
WE'RE. GOING TO SWITCH
ADMINISTRATIONS THIS NEXT YEAR
AND IN ORDER TO NOT LOSE TRACK
WE NEED TO BE MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WE ARE SETTING UP. POLICY
AND CONVERSATIONS FOR NEXT YEAR
AS WELL. I'M A LEADER THAT WE'RE
HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU LISTEN TO
THE PROGRAM TO THE. PROGRAMS WHO
ARE GOING TO BE TALKING TO US
AND. I LOOK FORWARD TO A GOOD
HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH SURPRISE
SURE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
WELCOME. MR LEADER.
HE WAS CHAIRMAN AND THE MEMBERS
AND STAFF AND.
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
THIS IS THE ONLY COMMITTEE I
HAVE NOW BYE BYE AS TO ASSUME
THE LEADERSHIP ROLE OF THE
REPUBLICANS I. THEY TOOK ALL MY
CRAZY BUT I REQUESTED I STAY ON
THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE THIS IS A
VERY POOR TO MY DISTRICT. AS YOU
WELL KNOW THAT SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE WATER THAT COMES
OUT THIS YEAR'S.
COMES FROM FROM THEN UP IN THE
NORTH OF MY DISTRICT IN.
PERCEPTION OF WATERS AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO.
MAKE SURE HABITAT IS STRONG
INTO. ALSO GETS OUT TO THE OCEAN
AND THAT WE TAKE KNOWS OF A
PLACE THAT'S FIT TO COME BACK SO
I'M I WAS DOWN THIS COMMITTEE AS
LONG AS THEM YOU ALLOWED ME TO
BE HERE AND. OVER TO THE
DIALOGUE I DON'T THINK SO MUCH
STRONGLY WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE TODAY.
MY FINAL THANK YOUS TO ALL OF
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK LAST NIGHT
AT THE DINNER IS THE VICE CHAIR
AND SAID. IT TRULY IS A TREAT TO
BE ABLE TO BE WITH ALL OF YOU.
AND WANT TO SAY AGAIN THINKING
THIS FRENCH AND THE ENTIRE CREW
THAT PUT IT ON LAST NIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK.
AND I ALSO WANT TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK THE GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT.
AS WE'VE ALWAYS SAID WE COLUMN
CRAB TRAP IN THE OFFICE. BY TOM
WAS SLOW REALLY IS THE HEART AND
SOUL.
IN IS THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE. AS WELL AS THE
FLEET AND I WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO HIM I THINK
WE ALSO NEED TO GIVE HIM A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE IS WHAT.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER DO WE LIKE TO
BE A TO BRING UP. THESE
FANTASTIC ALL STARS AND OUR
AGENCY LEADERS WERE GONNA HEAR
FROM JOHN LAYERED TO SECRETARY
OF NATURAL RESOURCES WORKING
HERE FROM MR BONHAM THE DIRECTOR
OF CAFFEINE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE. WE'RE ALSO EXCITED FOR
HIS FIRST TIME TO BE A C.
ANTHONY WILLIAMS HERE TODAY HE'S
VICE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION WE
WELCOME YOU ALL CHAIRMAN TO BE A
COME FORWARD. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S FISHING FLEET.
MY COMING FORWARD. AND AGAIN
JUST CANNOT SAY THANK YOU ENOUGH
TO MISTER LAYARD WHO. HAS BEEN
SUCH A CHAMPION FOR ESPECIALLY
ARE CRAP FLEET. TRYING TO SECURE
THOSE DOLLARS THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AND I HAVE TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
I HAVE TO RACE OUT OF HERE WHEN
I'M DONE TALKING AND SO. ON
APOLOGIZE FOR.
HAVING TO DO THAT AND I WANT TO
ALSO SAY I CANNOT THINK OF A
TIME. THAT I MISSED THE DINNER
HAD A AND.
WHITE'S KNIGHT WAS. THE TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF A MAJOR ENERGY
BILL THAT THE THEN SPEAKER NOT
CO AUTHORED THAT THAT THEY HAD
TIED US DOWN SIX MONTHS IN
ADVANCE HERE IN THE CAPITAL I
WAS HOPING TO GET THERE. AND I
WAS HOPING TO GET THERE NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE GREAT FOOD AND A
GOOD CAMARADERIE.
BUT BECAUSE I CEDED TO DIRECTOR
BONHAM. OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THE
FEATHER RIVER HATCHERY SALMON
PACKAGE WHICH I WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO DOING.
AND JUST FOR THE TWO PEOPLE.
THAT ARE SITTING BEHIND ME THAT
MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN THERE.
LET ME SAY THAT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO KEEP THE DATA STREAMS GOING
AROUND THE SALMON FISHERIES. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES COMMITTED AND IT WAS
ANNOUNCED LAST NIGHT. TO FUNDING
THE SALMON TUGGING AT THE
FEATHER RIVER HATCHERY. AND
THANKS TO THE LEADERSHIP OF. THE
D. W. R. DIRECTOR CARLA NEMESIS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH US
DIRECTOR BONHAM. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MISS A BEAT ON THE SALMON
TAGGING AND WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO COLLECT THE. THE
CRITICAL INFORMATION FOR SALMON
MANAGEMENT AND I KNOW IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO MANY OF OUR.
COMMERCIAL RECREATIONAL TRIBAL
FISHERMAN AND A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW PEOPLE ARE COORDINATING AND
I'M GLAD TO COME TO A ROOM FULL
FISHMAN. WORKS DONE AND THEY ARE
NOT ASKING ME WHEN IT'S GOING TO
BE DONE BUT SO FAR. OUT OF THAT
IS REALLY GOOD NEWS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL YOUR WORK AND THEY
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING TO WORK VERY VERY
GRATEFUL. VERY HAPPY WITH THEIR.
AND THEN ALSO I DID NOT WISH TO
ONCE IN OUR ONE OF THESE
HEARINGS. THAT THE TIME I GOT TO
KNOW SEE GREATER VERY WELL WAS
BOTH OF US FIGHTING OFF SHORE
OIL IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES ME
AS A MATTER OF HIM AND HIS ROLE
OF OF DECADES AND.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT HE IS
NOT AT OUR SIDE.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS FIGHT OF
BECAUSE HE WAS SO INSTRUMENTAL.
IN IT IN THAT TIME BUT I THINK
THAT I WOULD JUST REITERATE.
THAT.
WE ARE. A.
CLEAR.
THAT. THE STATE IS CLEAR AGAINST
THIS PROPOSAL WERE OPPOSED TO IT
WE WILL PRESS THAT POSITION IN
ANY VENUE. OF THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO PRESS IT AND IT
COMES FROM IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE GOVERNORS OF
CALIFORNIA OREGON AND
WASHINGTON.
ALL SENT JOINT LETTERS TO THE
PRESIDENT AND THE CONGRESS IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS IN EARLY
JANUARY OF THE WEST COAST
GOVERNORS ARE ISSUED A
STATEMENT.
AND THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
HAS ADOPTED A RESOLUTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE IS THE NEW
ASSEMBLY REPRESENTATIVE AND A
PARTICIPATED IN THAT. FARM AND I
THINK THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSALS PREMISED
ON A PERSPECTIVE THAT ALL THINGS
ARE EQUAL BUT NOT ALL CLOSE ARE
ALIKE.
AND THEY'RE DIFFERENT DROP OFFS
ON THE HONOR CONTINENTAL SHELF
WEATHER PATTERNS SHIPPING LINES
FISHERIES MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS.
AND.
.
NO WE DID THE FIRST TIME WE
FOUGHT IT WE WERE ONLY FIFTEEN
OR SEVENTEEN YEARS OUT FROM THE
MAJOR SPILL. AND WE HAVE TO
REMIND PEOPLE. OF JUST HOW
DISASTROUS THAT WAS. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT IN ANY SURVEY. THAT
HAS BEEN. TAKEN AND WE HAVE AS A
STATE WITH POLICY REALLY MOVED.
AWAY FROM THE WHOLE NOTION OF
FOSSIL FUELS AND TRYING TO DO
RENEWABLES. IT WHEN I WAS
FIGHTING THIS IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES I ALWAYS SAID THAT. IF
WE JUST IMPROVED BY ONE MILE PER
GALLON THE FUEL EFFICIENCY OF
CARS IN CALIFORNIA IT WOULD
EQUAL THE AMOUNT OF OIL THAT
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT OFF THE
COAST. WHAT WE HAVE DONE THAT
AND AND EXPONENTIALLY AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND SO
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT SHOULD
BE?
?
DISCOUNTED IN ALL THIS AND I
SHOULD ALSO SAY THAT.
WHEN. SECRETARY OF INTERIOR
APPEARED TO GIVE FLORIDA A PASS.
FROM THE DRAWINGS ARE FAR
GOVERNOR GOT ON THE PHONE WITH
HIM WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
AND DEPRESSED THE SAME CASE FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND HE AGREED TO
COME VISIT. AN INTERESTING WAY
THE DAY THE SECRETARY OF
INTERIOR CHOSE TO BE IN THE
CAPITAL. WAS OCEAN'S TODAY
BECAUSE I WENT TO FROM THE
MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
HIM TO OCEANS DAY AND THE
GOVERNOR JUST PRESSED HIM IN
PERSON.
WHY IT WAS DIFFERENT WHY HE HAD
TO DO THIS AND WAS RELENTLESS IN
HIS INTERPERSONAL? A PUSH ON
THIS SO JUST TRUST US. WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT AND I KNOW THAT
I SUBMITTED A LETTER.
ON FEBRUARY SEVENTH THERE'LL BE
OTHER LETTERS COMING BEFORE THE
DEADLINE TOMORROW IF I CAN
SHAMELESSLY SAY IF THERE'S A
PERSON SITTING BEHIND ME THAT
HASN'T WRITTEN OR LETTER YET
TOMORROW IS THE DEADLINE AND GO
HOME TO YOUR HOTEL. LIGHTED
TONIGHT TO ADVENTURE GETS THERE.
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE FULL.
WITH WEIGHT OF WHAT CALIFORNIA
REALLY BELIEVES. A FEW OTHER
THINGS BECAUSE YOU HAVE GREAT
WITNESSES ARE COMING AFTER ME
THAT WILL GO INTO DEPTH AND MANY
THINGS. BUT I WANT TO MENTION
THAT.
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL HAS
ACTIVELY INVESTED OVER TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES. THAT AIM TO ENHANCE
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES. AND. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
DUNGEON THIS CRAB FISHING GEAR
WORKING GROUP. WHICH IS A VERY
DIVERSE GROUP AND IT'S COME
TOGETHER TO CHALLENGE.
REDUCING THE RISK OF WYO
ENTANGLEMENTS AND AND FISHING
GEAR IT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS WE INVESTED TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THAT
GROUP. ALONE. AND.
WE HAVE ALSO APPROVED
ADDITIONAL MONEY SUPPORTING TO
SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES PROJECTS.
TO IMPROVE THE MANAGEMENT OF
STATE FISHERIES AND WHEN THE.
M. M. P. A. AS OPPOSED TO THE M.
L. P. A FORCE IN ACTED. IT
REALLY SET UP A PROCESS FOR
LOOKING AT INDIVIDUAL FISHERIES.
AND THAT COST IN THE FIRST THREE
TO SIX THAT WERE DONE SOMEWHERE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF. NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO A MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT IS THE REASON
THERE ARE THIRTY THAT ARE ON
DON.
AND SO WE IN JANUARY AT OUR
MEETINGS. BUNDLED THOSE
REMAINING THIRTY TO GATHER AND
APPROPRIATED MONEY TO TRY TO DO
THE FIRST STEPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN MOVE THROUGH THOSE
PROCESSES AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE
ACTUALLY. DONE.
AND.
JUST SO YOU KNOW. ARE KEY
FINDINGS FROM OUR SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM. ARE REPORTED ON
EMERGING RESEARCH ON THE
CAPACITY OF SEA GRASS.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
DOCUMENT THE SCIENCE IN RELATION
TO WHAT MIGHT WORK IN A.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAM AND KNOW THAT THERE'S
DOCUMENTED SCIENCE THAT MIGHT
MAKE OCEANS. HAVE A PLACE IN
THAT AT SOME POINT.
ON MARCH TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
THIRD AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM
OTHER PEOPLE. OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL WILL CO HOST
A WORKSHOP WITH THE OCEAN
SCIENCE TRUST. THE INTER AGENCY
HARM FOR A BONE TASKFORCE.
FOCUSED ON HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS.
AND.
THIS WORKSHOP WILL FOCUS ON TO
MORE CASTED IN MONITORING IN THE
OCEAN AS IT RELATES TO SEE FOOD
SAFETY. I JUST SAY IN CLOSING
THAT WE ARE VERY CONSCIOUS OF
THE FAT THAT WE HAVE TEN MONTHS
LEFT. AND WE ARE TRYING TO.
MAKE SURE WE GET MONEY OUT THE
DOOR A DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
INSTITUTIONALIZED DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS FIXED. SO THAT WHEN THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION COMES IN OF
THERE IS A CLEAR DIRECTION ON A
NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS IN A
WAY THAT THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH WHEN THEY WALK IN THE DOOR
SO. THAT'S WHAT I'D SAY FOR
OPENING COMMENTS AND AND BEFORE
I GO I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAD ANY THANK
YOU SO MUCH BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
NEXT. TO THE KEYNOTE SPEAKERS
LET'S OPEN UP FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE FOR THE SECTOR
IS HE HAS. ANOTHER INDICATION
THAT HE HAS TO GET TO TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK HE'S MUCH SECTOR. REALLY
GREAT PLEASURE HERE CHANCE TO BE
HERE. EVERY YEAR SO VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JIM WE'RE NOT GONNA BE TURNED
OVER TO CHECK ON HIM THAT
DIRECTOR CAPPING DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. HE IS GOING
TO BE GIVING US AN UPDATE ON THE
BUDGET THAT HE HAS SOME GOOD
NEWS TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
TODAY.
ALSO ON ALL ISSUES OF WAILING
TALE ENTANGLEMENT. TALKING ABOUT
SP EIGHT TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT THE FLEET ALL SUPPORTED IN
ADVANCE IS WELL. IN THEN WE'LL
BE TOUCHING ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE. WE WELCOME THE
DIRECTOR TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK THEY COULD SHARE VICE CHAIR
MISTER LEADER.
CRAB TRAP.
AND.
MAYBE THE ONLY TIME I GET A
CHANCE TO SAY THAT HEARING.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHUCK BONHAM
AND I STILL THINK THAT THE
GREATEST JOB IN THE WORLD WHICH
IS SOMETHING I ALWAYS SAY AS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
YOU WROTE ME ON THE TWENTY HIRD
OF FEBRUARY YOU ASKED ME TO
COVER THOSE FIVE ITEMS.
IN FIFTEEN MINUTES.
INSTEAD OF STARTING WITH WHICH
YOU LABEL GOOD NEWS THE BUDGET
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WAS LAST
YEAR AND BEGIN WITH. THE MARINE
LIFE MANAGEMENT ACT MASTER PLAN
TOPIC.
SO AS MOST FOLKS KNOW AND
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE STATE
ENACTED THE MARINE LIFE
MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND PRETTY SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE I THINK THE
STATE ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
MASTER PLAN. FOR GOVERNANCE
WITHIN THAT. AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS OUR
DEPARTMENT WITH COMMISSION
LEADERSHIP ARE VARIOUS PARTNERS
IN TRIBES. ARE UNENDING THAT
MASTER PLAN.
AND HERE'S WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT.
SO WE SPENT ABOUT TWO YEARS
THROUGH THAT COLLABORATIVE
DIALOGUE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
COMMISSION'S PUBLIC PROCESS.
AND I THINK THIS WILL BE A FROM
THE COMMISSION IN JUNE.
AND THAT'LL SET US UP FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WE'VE HAD
INVOLVEMENT BY THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITIES FISHING COMMUNITIES.
AND IT WILL LAY OUT A FRAMEWORK
FOR HOW WE'RE GOING TO ASSESS
OUR STATE MANAGED OCEAN
FISHERIES.
AND THEN GET ABOUT THE BUSINESS
OF DESIGNING THE SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS FOR THOSE FISHERIES.
BUT IT DOES SOMETHING NEW.
THE EXISTING LAW REALLY
EMPHASIZES FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
PLANS WHICH CAN BE A LENGTHY
PROCESS THEY'RE IMPORTANT BUT
WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO GET
ABOUT A HALF A DOZEN OR SO
FISHERIES UNDER THAT PLANNING
EFFORT.
THIS AMENDMENT CREATES A NEW I
THINK INNOVATIVE ASPECT WHERE.
THERE MAY BE SOME FISHERIES WE
CAN DO ENHANCE STATUS REPORTS
ABOUT.
DO THE ANALYSIS ANALYSIS FASTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR STATUS FASTER
AND THEN THAT'LL BECOME A PIVOT
POINT DECIDE IF YOU NEED A FULL
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT PLAN OR
SOME MORE ABBREVIATED LIGHTER
VERSION BASED ON STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT IN THE SCIENCE. SO
WITH THE SOME MEN THAT WE EXPECT
THAT BY EARLY TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN BUT A YEAR LATER WE'LL
BE ABLE TO HAVE DONE ABOUT
THIRTY SIX OF THOSE IN HAND
STATUS REPORTS FOR STATE BASS
FISHERIES WHICH CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE ANY ANALYSIS AROUND THEM.
FOR THEIR LONG TERM MANAGEMENT.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST CATEGORY.
THE SECOND TOPIC YES ME TALK
ABOUT. ALL THINGS WHALES.
THIS TAKES A MOMENT TO PAUSE.
AND A KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF ENGAGE.
COMPONENTS OF OUR CITIZENRY ON
THIS TOPIC.
THE FLEET IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED
OUR CONSERVATION COMMUNITY.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY I
THINK THERE'S A SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT SHARED VALUES.
NOBODY WANTS TO UNTANGLE AWAY
ALL.
AND I THINK THAT RUNS ACROSS THE
SIGHT SEEING THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THEN YEAH
INDUSTRY COMMUNITIES.
JUST SO YOU KNOW.
WE ARE UNDER ACTIVE LITIGATION.
THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN SUED IN
FEDERAL COURT.
BY THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. AND MOST RECENTLY.
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
MOVED INTERVENE IN THAT FEDERAL
LITIGATION.
SO THAT'S HAPPENING.
IN ONE'S FEAR. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THERE'S BEEN AN EFFORT
UNDER WAY. TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
PROBLEM FOR A COUPLE EARS.
THROUGH OUR DUNGEON IS CRAP WORK
GROUP. THERE IS A STRUCTURE.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A SET OF
SHARED VALUES AND OBJECTIVES
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING INDUSTRY.
THOSE INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
TRANSPARENCY.
PROCESS.
INFORMATION SHARING.
ELECTRONIC MONITORING.
AROUND THIS ISSUE PERHAPS GEAR
MARKING.
AND THEN. WHAT IS CALLED RAMP A
RISK ASSESSMENT MITIGATION
PROGRAM? WHICH IS A LAY PERSON
IN MY MIND I PACKAGE IT THIS
WAY.
POSSIBLY AS AN ANALOGY SOMETHING
LIKE A GREEN YELLOW RED. RISK
ESCALATION DIAGRAM.
AND IF WE CAN FOSTER AN
ATMOSPHERE WHERE INDUSTRY AND
STAKE HOLDERS ARE ENGAGED IN
THAT TYPE OF PROCESS.
THE SEGUE BETWEEN COLORS IS
DEFINED BY OBJECTIVE SCIENTIFIC
METRICS.
AND AS YOU MOVE UP YOUR SLIDE
YOUR YOUR RISK METER.
KING ABOUT COLLABORATIVE ACTIONS
TO REDUCE THE RISK AND
EVENTUALLY PERHAPS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT RESTRICTIVE
ACTIONS. THAT'S ON TOPIC WELL.
ENGAGED IN THIS WORKING GROUP
IT'S REFLECTED I THINK IN YOUR
OMNIBUS BILL.
AND WHAT'S NEXT I THINK IS FOR
THE PARTIES TO. CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION SEE IF WE CAN'T
PRODUCE AN OUTCOME. THAT WILL
REDUCE THE RISK OF.
ENTANGLEMENTS BY WAILING OR
FIXED GEAR FISHERIES IN STATE
WATERS.
IT'S B. TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
YOUR LEADERSHIP TO THINK ABOUT A
PART OF THIS CHALLENGE AND
THAT'S GEAR LEFT IN WATER
ABANDON OR DERELICT.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN AUTHORING THAT
BILL.
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE IN THE
CURRENT OMNIBUS YOU'VE TRIED TO
FINE TUNE. THINGS TO HELP
IMPLEMENTATION BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL. THE DEPARTMENTS I
THINK ABLE TO COME TO YOU AND
TALK ABOUT A FEW FURTHER
REFINEMENTS.
WE THINK WE'RE CLOSE ON THAT
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. AND WERE ALSO VERY
WILLING TO ADOPT YOUR
INSTRUCTION THAT WITHIN ABOUT A
YEAR FROM NOW WE'VE GONE AHEAD
AND DONE THE IMPLEMENTING RULE
MAKING. TO MAKE IT A REALLY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM.
.
I DO THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION. AND A LOT OF GREAT
CONCERN AROUND WELL
ENTANGLEMENT.
BUT I'M OF THE VIEW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE MIDDLE
FACILITATING THIS CONVERSATION I
THINK WE CAN GET ALL THE MAJOR
STAKE HOLDERS TO A COMMON
OUTCOME. I'M HOPEFUL FOR THAT.
LET ME RUN THROUGH AN UPDATE ON
THE SALMON SARDINE INTERACTION
FISHERIES THE CHEST FOR.
THERE'S GOOD AND BAD NEWS.
ON THE SAME IN FRONT I'D SAY
THERE'S A TOUCH OF GOOD NEWS BUT
THERE'S ALSO BAD NEWS. SO LAST
WEEK OUR SCIENTISTS COMPLETED
THE STOCK FORECASTS FOR THE
SACRAMENTO IN THE KLAMATH FALLS
CHINOOK. AND THESE FORECASTS ARE
WHAT BECOME THE BASIS TO
DETERMINE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FISHING SEASONS. SO THE
FORECAST FOR THE SALMON FALL RUN
IS ALMOST IDENTICAL TO LAST
YEAR.
ABOUT FORECASTS THESE ARE MODELS
THATTAKE A SKATE MEN IN NUMBERS
AND PROJECT WHAT WE THINK WE'LL
SEE. AND THEN THAT GUIDES WHAT
WE ARE ABLE TO ALLOCATE FOR
CATCHING HARVEST.
SO IN THE SACRAMENTO IT'S A
PROJECTION OF TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND ADULTS WHICH IS
ALMOST IDENTICAL TO LAST YEAR.
IN THE KLAMATH FALL RUN STOCK
THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME GOOD NEWS.
NUMBER IT IS RELATIVE BECAUSE
IT WAS SO ABYSMAL THE PRIOR
SEASON.
BUT IT IS MUCH IMPROVED WITH A
FORECAST OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND CHINOOK IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WIN LAST
YEAR WAS ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND. ADULTS SO THAT'S A
MARKET INCREASE I DO THINK THAT
SOME GOOD NEWS.
HERE'S THE LESS GOOD NEWS. IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT BASED ON
THOSE CRITERIA AS THEY ARE
EXPRESSED IN THE FEDERAL
MANAGEMENT PLANS. IT MAY BE THE
CASE THAT BOTH OF THESE TARGETS
STOCKS.
YOU MAY QUALIFY FOR THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION OF OVER FISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING THIS WEEK AT THE
PACIFIC FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL RUNNER PARK IS THE
BEGINNING OF A DISCUSSION WHICH
WILL END IN.
IT WAS A JUNE IN PORTLAND.
AND WILL DETERMINE WHAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE FINISHED OR
NOT IN BOTH THOSE FISHERIES.
SARDINE I WOULD SAY IS
CONTINUED BADNESS.
SO IT'S MORE LIKELY THAN NOT FOR
FOURTH YEAR IN A ROW YOU'LL SEE
NO FISHING FOR OUR STARTING
FISHER.
AND THE REASON IS THE PROJECTED
SARDINE STOCK BIOMASS IS WELL
BELOW THE SET LIMITS. FOR THIS
FISHERY.
SO WE'RE PROJECTING THE BIO MASS
AT FIFTY ABOUT FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND METRIC TONS. AND THE
LIMIT IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND METRIC TONS THAT'S HOW
FAR BELOW THE LIMIT WE ARE. AND
I THINK JUST TODAY THE FEDERAL
COUNCIL AND THE NATIONALLY
FISHERIES SERVICE. HAVE PUT OUT
ADDITIONAL DATA SUGGESTING THAT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX THIS
STARTING FISHERY IS DECLINED BY
NINETY. SEVEN PERCENT.
SO SOME OF THE BIOLOGICAL WORLD
IS COMPARING IT TO THE COLLAPSE
OF THE CANNERY ROW FISHERY.
THEIR VARIETY OF FACTORS AND I
THINK THAT'S MUCH OF THE
DISCUSSION NEXT YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE THE PRIME FACTORS AND WHAT
WE CAN DO ABOUT IT.
VIRGIN ABALONE NORTH COAST HELP
I WOULD PUT AS ONE.
IN DECEMBER AS MANY KNOW OUR
COMMISSION CLOSE TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN READ ABALONE SEASON
BASED ON A COLLAPSE.
THE COLLAPSE IS REALLY TRIGGERED
BY I THINK THAN FAVORABLE OCEAN
CONDITIONS LARGE SCALE REGIME
SHIFT. AND BASICALLY A LOSS OF
ARE KILLED FARCE.
WHICH SHOWS THE LOUD LESS
PREFERABLE VIRGINS TO TAKE OVER
THE LANDSCAPE BIRBAL NOTABLY.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO THE COMMISSION IS FORCING THE
DEPARTMENT APPROPRIATELY TO DO.
IS UPDATE THE ABALONE READ EYE
BELOW THE FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
PLAN. IT'S OUTDATED WE NEED TO
GET IT UPDATED WITH NEW SCIENCE
AND WE'RE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT.
BUT IT'S VERY LIKELY IF NOT
CERTAIN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
LIMITED URCHIN FISHERY
OPPORTUNITIES STILL.
I THINK ON THE UPSIDE I WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE GOT CRAB
OPEN.
WE GOT IT OPEN IN THE HOLIDAYS.
AND WE SEEM TO HAVE AVOIDED A
SIMILAR DIM DRAMATIC ACID
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAD A COUPLE
YEARS PRIOR. EVEN THOUGH IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT OUR OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL KEEP POSTING
THE SCIENTIFIC WORKSHOPS ONE
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE NEXT
MONTH.
HE. FORCING US TO LOOK AT THIS
QUESTION OF DEMO GAS IT AND HOW
WE MANAGE IT IN FUTURE CYCLES.
AQUA CULTURE PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT.
A MOUTHFUL. NOT MANY OF THE ROOM
PROBABLY UNDERSTAND OR TALKING
ABOUT I THINK YOU DO.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT SHOULD TAKE
TEN PLUS YEARS FOR AN AGENCY TO
COMPLETE AN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT WHICH IS WHY THIS YEAR
WE'RE GOING TO GET IT DONE
FINALLY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO COMMIT THE
FINANCIAL STAFF RESOURCES TO
COMPLETE THE DRAFT GET OUT OUT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT BY THE END OF
THIS CALENDAR YEAR. THAT'LL BE A
HUGE SHIFT. NEEDS TO GET DONE IT
SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE A LONG TIME
AGO.
SO WE'LL BE POSTING A REFRESH
REFRESH NOTICE OF PREPARATION
LATE THIS MONTH WE'RE GONNA GO
OUT TO PUBLIC SCOPING MEETINGS
BOTH IN THE NORTH AND SOUTH AND
WE GONNA LAY OUT THIS TIME LINE.
TO GET THAT DRAFT UP TO THE
PUBLIC BEFORE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND I'M POTENTIALLY DON.
UNDERSCORE POTENTIALLY AS
DIRECTOR THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
OKAY SO.
YOU SAID THE. GOOD NEWS IN YOUR
LETTER TO ME. LET ME TRY TO END
ON A GOOD NEWS NOW.
FIRST BY TELLING YOU SOMETHING I
DON'T THINK YOU KNOW YET.
THIS WEEK WE ARE GOING TO
ANNOUNCE THE DEPARTMENT'S FOURTH
SOLICITATIONS UNDER PROPOSITION
ONE. FOR GRANTS WHICH WAS THE
WATER BOND THAT SIXTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS VOTED
YES FOR.
OVERALL IN THE PRIOR THREE GRAND
CYCLES WE'VE GRANTED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE PROJECTS.
FORTY ONE PERCENT OF THAT
RESTORATION GRANTING HAS BEEN
FOR THE BENEFIT OF SAM AND STILL
AT.
WE'VE RECEIVED FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX APPLICATIONS.
FOR FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF WORK.
BUT HERE'S WHAT'S NEW RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO ONE
SOLICITATION GONNA BREAK IN
HALF.
WE'RE GONNA SPRING SOLICITATION
WHICH WILL RELEASE THIS WEEK
WHY.
WE HINK WE CAN FOCUS ON A
COUPLE OF LITTLE THINGS.
ASK ONLY FOR IMPLEMENTATIONS
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS AND TURN
DIRT FASTER.
AND IN THE FALL WILL DO A
SUBSEQUENT SOLICITATION MORE OF
THE ACQUISITION THE PLANNING.
TYPE WORK.
HERE'S WHY SPRINGS IMPORTANT.
ONE OF THE EMPHASIS WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS WILDLIFE. AND WILD FIRES
RECOVERY.
SO WE WILL ASK PEOPLE TO COME TO
US WITH APPLICATIONS FOR
PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT FISH.
ALSO DEAL WITH THE RHODESIAN.
IN OUR.
WILDFIRE.
IMPACTED LANDSCAPES. RIPARIAN
HABITAT WORK.
WATER QUALITY WORK AND POSE FAR
SUSSMAN'S WHICH CAN BE PLANNING
FOR SUBSEQUENT WORK.
AT THESAME TIME WE'LL ASK
PEOPLE TO COME TO US FOR CENTRAL
VALLEY SALMON RESILIENCY
PROJECTS.
IF YOU GOT A FISH SCREENED THE
SUNSCREEN IN NEED SCREENING IF
YOU GOT A BURIED A MIGRATION. IF
YOU WANT TO DO REARING HABITAT
BY FLOODING UP YOUR LAND SURFACE
CAN GET ON AND GET FATTER. IF
YOU GOT PASSAGE PROBLEMS IN YOUR
FRONT CONTROL PROJECTS COME TO
US WE'RE GONNA HAVE A SPECIAL
SOLICITATION FOR THOSE TWO
TOPICS IN THE SPRING.
SINCE AT LEAST THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES.
IT'S BEEN UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED
THE DEPARTMENT SINGLE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES SUSTAINABLE FUNDING.
ACTUALLY HAVE A REAL POOR
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT. THE JOINT
COMMITTEE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS
LEGISLATURE ASKED BOOZE ALLEN
HAMILTON A NATIONAL CONSULTING
FIRM. TO LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THEIR ANSWER WAS SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
I'VE GOT THROUGH A COUPLE.
BRUTAL BUDGET CYCLES ISN'T THE
QUITTING LAST YEAR.
AND I AM THRILLED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
GOVERNOR BROWN'S LEADERSHIP IN
HIS JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHERE HE PROPOSES FIFTY POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
PERMANENT. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TO THIS HEARING.
THAT'S.
ALLOCATED.
AMONG OTHER ITEMS THIS WAY
ALMOST FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SALMON WORK.
AT ABOUT NINETEEN NEW POSITIONS.
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE MILLION
FOUR HATCHERY WORKED TO BUILD
BETTER TECHNOLOGIES INTO OUR
HATCHERIES.
ABOUT EIGHT AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUR MARINE OCEAN
WORK. HAS THIRTY EIGHT
POSITIONS.
WE AS AN EXAMPLE. DEAL WITH
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND COMMERCIAL
LANDING RECEIPTS AND LOG BOOKS
ANNUALLY WE PRINT THEM WE MAIL
THEM IN WE MANUALLY ENTER THEM
INTO A DATA SYSTEM.
WHEN IT FLIPPED OUT OVER TO
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY.
THERE'S ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
MILLION SET ASIDE IN THIS
PROPOSAL FOR THAT MASTER PLAN
WORK I DESCRIBED EARLIER.
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SET ASIDE INTO PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO CREATE WHAT I
BELIEVE WILL BE THE NATION'S
MOST PROGRESSIVE WAY UNTANGLE
MEANT RISK REDUCTION MITIGATION
PROGRAM.
SO THE BENEFITS ARE REAL TO
THOSE IN THIS ROOM TODAY.
IN MY VIEW IS THERE'S VERY
LITTLE DISPUTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT STRUGGLES WITH
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING.
IT'S CREDIBLE PROPOSAL OTHER
FORD NEXT WEEK STARTING THE
HEARING PROCESS ON THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL NOT STOP
THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A DIRECTOR
GRATEFUL AT THE TURN IT OVER TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I'D SAY A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO
UNDERSTAND JUMP BACK TO YOUR
FIRST PART ABOUT AT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND.
IN WITHIN THE ON THIS BILL SO
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS WILL BE PROVIDING.
LANGUAGE OF POTENTIAL TWEAKS. TO
BE ABLE TO TO GET THAT MOVED YES
THAT'S GREAT WANNA CONFIRM THE
STATISTIC THAT YOU GAVE ABOUT
THE NINETY SEVEN PERCENT
DECREASE. IN THIRTEEN THIRTEEN.
ASIAN IS THAT JUST IN CALIFORNIA
IS THAT WEST COAST ITS MEXICO
TO.
ITS RIGHTFUL RANGE WIDE AS I
UNDERSTAND IN MEXICO TO BRITISH
COLUMBIA EXCLUDED AND I THINK
IT'S BENCHMARKED AGAINST TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIX MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THE HIGHEST.
LAST YEAR LIKE IT WAS THROUGH
THE ROOF RECORD BOSS. SO YOU
NEED TO THINK THROUGH THOSE.
PARAMETERS OF THE ANALYSIS.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
TALK ABOUT THAT SO THE WILDFIRE
RECOVERY WHICH IS FANTASTIC AND
JUST. DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU AND
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU THE
TRACTOR ONE. RIGHT IN THE THICK
OF ALL ISSUES THE NORTH A
FIRESTORM CALLED UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT. KITTEN THE RESOURCES
WE NEEDED AT ON HIS SIDE.
.
DO YOU SEE THIS AS A ONE TIME
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU SEE THIS
GOING OUT BECAUSE THE.
ESSENTIALLY NOT APPARENT REASON
HERE PLANNING GRANTS.
I DO HAVE TO GET THAT PROJECTS
PREPARED.
IN IN DOLLARS SHE ACTUALLY DO
HABITAT RESTORATION WITHIN.
STREAM BANKS WATERSHEDS EXEDRA.
IS IS TO INTERPRET DISCO SECOND
YEAR IF YOU'RE DOING A PLANNING
GRANT TO BETTER SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT.
I DON'T HAVE AN OPINION TO
EXPRESS ON THE OUT YEARS YEAH
YEAH WE'VE NOT TRIED.
EARLIER TARGETED SOLICITATION
LIKE THIS EXCEPT FOR DROUGHT
YEAH.
I'D LIKE TO GAUGE RESPONSE.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT IF WE'RE
GONNA FUN PLANNING WORK THIS
YEAR WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND GOOD
PLANNING MAY COME BACK PROJECTS
LATER EXACTLY. BUT ALSO SAY
WHETHER WE DO IT TARGETED
SOLICITATION AGAIN IN YEAR TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE.
MAY NOT MATTER. THIS WAY BECAUSE
THIS WORKS ALL QUALIFYING UNDER
PROP ONE GENERALLY SPEAKING.
RIGHT A RHODESIAN WORK.
IN BANK SETTLEMENT CONTROL WERE
PREPARED AND HABITAT PLANTING.
ALL ARE PRETTY ELIGIBLE UNDER
PROP ONE AS WE HAVE IT SET UP AS
OF TODAY ANYWAY.
SO LET ME THINK ABOUT.
HOW THIS GOES AND I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR? PERMANENCE WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO DO PROJECTS
ON THE LANDSCAPE SCALE LIKE ANY
OTHER WAYS THAT RING THAT UP TO
EIGHTY EIGHT IN PARTICULAR THIS
IS. FOR SOME OF THE SMALLER
COUNTIES RIGHT.
.
WOW THERE IS SIGNIFICANT NEED.
TO USE MEDICINAL KENNY'S EXAMPLE
RIGHT ALONG THE RUSSIAN RIVER
THERE.
BEING ABLE TO SECURE THESE
DOLLARS SO LET'S AS YOU DO THE
SOLICITATION SPRING THEY
PROBABLY WANNA MEANS BE ABLE TO
SEE THE DOLLARS IN THEIR
ACCOUNT.
MAKING THIS UP MAYBE TO FALL.
I SAID THEN YOU'RE INTO THAT
NEXT CYCLE THE NEXT YEAR AS TO
THE REASON I BRING THAT UP AND
BY THE WAY I DON'T DIMINISH.
WHAT FANTASTIC NEWS THAT IS
BECAUSE IT IS? WONDERFUL AND
DESPERATELY NEEDED. DISTINCTION
PRACTICALLY ON BANDWIDTH OF SOME
OF THESE COUNTIES.
AND THEY CAN ALSO WORK WITH CST
SIX SAID ROB RIGHT UNDERSTOOD
YEAH I ALSO THINK A POTENTIAL
ADVANTAGE OF MOVING SOMETHING
EARLIER IN SPRING MIGHT BE
UNDERSCORE MY. WE GET PEOPLE
AND.
FIELD CONSTRUCTION SEASON IN A
FOLDER.
IT IS SAID TO BE A BACK TO OVER
FIFTEEN YES SO. IT'S FANTASTIC.
HATES WHEN AS A THANK YOU FOR
HAT. TARGETED APPROACH BECAUSE
IT IS. DESPERATELY NEEDED END
LIVING THROUGH THE VALLEY FIRE
CLEAN FIRE NOW THIS IS I'M NOT
SURE MMHM WHO MANY PEOPLE
APPRECIATE. THE OVERLAP BUT AS
AN EXAMPLE IN CINEMA COUNTY. MY
DEPARTMENT THAT COUNTY SNOW
COUNTY WATER AGENCY ROUNDTABLE.
MARK WEST CREEK IS AN
IDENTIFIED.
CORE RECOVERY AREA FOR SALMON
IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER. AND IT
WAS.
RIGHT IN THE FIRE SO THAT'S
THAT'S A NEXUS IF YOU WILL OUR
THINKING THIS IS A GOOD
APPROACH.
THANK YOU THAT'S SORT OF BEEN
ASKED ABOUT TIMING. BUYERS TO
GET ON THE GROUND ACTUALLY.
BILL TO GET THERE BEFORE IT.
NEXT YEAR'S.
RIGHT.
YEAH THAT'S GREAT. MUCH TO MANY
OTHER ITEMS.
RIGHT DIRECTOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND HAVE AFFECTED ME HANGING A
BIT AND I THINK HIS MOTHER BEING
SICK BUT AGAIN WE'RE JUST VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK.
LIZ YEAH WE'RE WELCOMING NINE
ANTHONY WILLIAMS VICE PRESIDENT
COMPETITION GAME COMMISSION AND
NOT A STRANGER TO INTO THIS
BUILDING IS A HE WORKED WITH THE
GOVERNOR FOR. QUITE SOME TIME
HE'S GOING TO DISCUSS THE
COMMISSION'S PRIORITIES. FOR A
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YOU CAN BE
FOCUSING THE PRAYERS BOTH ON THE
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE SIDE.
OF THE ANIMAL IN ME
IMPLEMENTATION. AS WELL AS
UPCOMING WORKSHOPS SO MISTER
VICE PRESIDENT WE WELCOME YOU
THINK YOU SO MUCH. FOR COMING
BACK AND WE CAN BE MORE EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THE
pYOU FOR HAVING ME OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT. MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND AND.
MISTER LEADER IN THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND.
MISTER ROYSTER YOU ASKS THE
QUESTION HOW YOU GOT YOU'RE NOT
SURE HOW YOU GOT ELECTED. WAS
SELECTED AS VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE I I I ACTUALLY KNOW
HOW I GOT ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT
AFFECT CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION I I MISSED THE
MEETING PLANNER.
BUT THE TIMING WAS GOOD BECAUSE.
IT DOES GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY
AS MUCH AS I MEAN I'M. VERY
THANKFUL TO YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE.
AND APPRECIATE THAT I I I
REALLY ENJOY THE FACT THAT I GOT
TO GO TO LAST NIGHT'S DINNER SO
THAT WAS A THAT WAS A GREAT
EVENT AND I THINK THANKS
EVERYONE FOR. FOR PUTTING THAT
ON AND WALKING WITH WELCOME
WELCOMING ALL OF US UP SO I MEAN
I KNOW YOU HAVE A.
VERY AMBITIOUS AGENDA TODAY SO
I'M IN A.
IN THE INTEREST OF GETTING TO
SOME OF THAT I WANNA I WANNA TRY
TO BE A LITTLE BIT DISCIPLINE
WITH MY REMARKS AND. SO FORGIVE
ME FOR GLANCING DOWN HERE A
LITTLE BIT I KNOW HOW THAT IS
AND IN THE HEARINGS LIKE THIS TO
JUST SIT THERE AND WATCH
SOMEBODY RE BUT ALL OF THEM.
I'LL TRY TO BE AS A AS A
EFFICIENT AS I CAN AND THAT SO.
HE YOU KNOW IT IT'S IT'S REALLY
A PLEASURE.
TO TO SERVE AS VICE PRESIDENT
AND TO BE HERE TO REPRESENT MART
PRESIDENT ERIC SKLAR WHO I AM I
KNOW YOU KNOW VERY WELL. BUT
ALSO TO BE HERE TO REPRESENT OUR
FINE STAFF AT THE COMMISSION UM
VALOR TO MANY YEARS ARTS ACTOR
DIRECTOR. I'M SUSAN ASHCRAFT TO
INTERACTS WITH A LOT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
ON MARINE RELATED ISSUES I
THINK THEY'RE BOTH HERE IN THE
ROOM SO I JUST WONDERED
KNOWLEDGE THEM IN THE STAFF OF
THE COMMISSION AT THAT. WITH
VERY FEW RESOURCES TO QUITE A
LOT OF A WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. MANAGE OUR
RESOURCES AND AND I THINK YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE REMARKS OF.
BOTH SECRETARY IN THE DIRECTOR
THAT WERE PART OF A. PRETTY COOL
TEAM VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE VERY
COMMITTED AND PASSIONATE ABOUT
MANAGING OUR NATURAL RESOURCES.
YOU KNOW WE ARE AT THE
COMMISSION OBVIOUSLY VERY DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT. OUR FISHERMEN
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
COMMUNITIES AND A THRIVING OF
FISHERIES HERE IN THE FUTURE.
BEGIN I PLEDGE YOU FOR HAVING
THIS THIS FORM AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN ADVANCING ISSUES.
MANY OF YOU MAY. BE AWARE THAT
THAT HE THE CALIFORNIA FISH
COMMISSION AT THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION IS ACTUALLY THE
OLDEST SUCH COMMISSION IN THE
UNITED STATES. IN TWENTY TWENTY
WE WILL CELEBRATE A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS OF AN EXISTENCE.
SO WE ARE YOU KNOW IN ADVANCE OF
THAT SORT OF HISTORIC. LANDMARK.
WE'RE GONNA BE EMBARKING ON.
STRATEGIC PLANNING INITIATIVES
THAT YOU KNOW WILL ALIGN OUR
GOALS TO MORE EFFICIENTLY DRESS
ADDRESS THE COMING CHALLENGES
INCLUDING CLIMATE CHANGE IN ME
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY.
COM. THE GOAL IS TO REALLY HAVE
THE COMMISSION BE MORE
PROACTIVE.
RATHER THAN REACTIVE. REGARDING
THAT MANY MEN MANDATES THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS AGAIN WITH A VERY
SMALL STAFF SO PRIORITIZATION IS
THE KEYS SO YOU ASK THAT WE TALK
ABOUT SOME WHATEVER WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES. COMING UP IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT IT NO NEED FOR ME TO
REPEAT IT AND THAT IS THE
ADMINISTERED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
OFFSHORE ORAL DEVELOPMENT YOU
YOUR. SECRETARY LAYERED LAID OUT
THE CASE VERY WELL I DON'T NEED
TO REPEAT IT. WHAT I WILL SAY IS
YOU KNOW AGAIN AS PART OF BEING
THIS THIS TEAM OF NATURAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT STATE WE
ALSO ACTED WE SENT A LETTER? TO
SECRETARY ZEKI OPPOSING THE
DRILLING PLAN. AND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY JOINING THE GOVERNOR
THE SECRETARY AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER STATE AGENCIES ND. AND
UNANIMOUSLY OPPOSING THIS
EXPANSION. I COULD SAY SIMPLY
PUT THE PROPOSAL HAS NO PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT PUTS AT RISK
OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES OUR
FISHERIES. AS WELL AS THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR BRAIN
ECOSYSTEMS.
ANOTHER PRIORITY OF THE
COMMISSION IS.
YOU KNOW THE FUTURE OF FISHING
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS A HUGE HUGE
ISSUE THAT WE. HEAR ABOUT HERE
AT THE CAMP AT THE COMMISSION.
AND AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
COMMISSION STAFF DEVELOPED A
SERIES OF YOU MENTIONED A
COASTAL FISHING COMMUNITIES
MEETINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
REGARDING THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY AND PROSPERITY OF
OUR FISHING COMMUNITIES. THE
GOALS OF THESE MEETINGS IS TO
FIND COMMON THINGS THEMES AND
PRIORITIES THAT ARE WITHIN THE
COMMISSION'S REAL HOUSE TO
ADDRESS EITHER THROUGH BROAD
POLICY DEVELOPMENT. REGULATION
CHANGE.
OR SUPPORT FOR OTHER APPROACHES.
THAT FIVE MEETINGS NOW.
FROM SMITH RIVER ATASCADERO OF
INTER.
MONTEREY SAN DIEGO UP AND DOWN
THE COAST. ON THEY'LL BE MORE
PLANNED.
AND WE'VE GOT A SECRET WHO'S
STARTING CIGARETTE FELLOW
STARTING IN IN LATE MARCH WE'RE
PLANNING SOME MORE THOSE
MEETINGS. AND ONE OF THE COMMON
THEMES THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
IS AT THE CHALLENGE.
YOU KNOW OF THE RESTRICTED
ACCESS FISHERIES ARE HAVING ON
COMMUNITIES IS TOUGH.
PRESENTS CHALLENGES FOR
FISHERMEN TO A DOT ADAPT TO THE
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS. FOR.
INJURY BY NEW A NEW GENERATION
OF POTENTIAL FISHERMEN.
THE COMMISSION PLANS HER BREATH
EMBRACE A POLICY THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THE VALUE OF CALIFORNIA FEATURES
AS WELL AS AQUA CULTURE. OUT TO
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE SENT A LETTER TO
THE COASTAL COMMISSION
EMPHASIZING THE NEED TO PRESERVE
AND BALANCE ARMORY MARINE
HERITAGE. ECONOMY AND.
ITS COASTAL AND OCEAN USES. AN
IDEAL IS THE POSSIBILITY
REFINING THE EXISTING COMMISSION
POLICY RESTRICTED ACCESS AND
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES TO THINK
THROUGH. HOW WE CAN HELP
COMMUNITIES BE MORE RESILIENT AS
FISHERIES HAVE THE CYCLES YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE ALLAWARE OF? IT
WITH THE GOAL TO TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES THRIVING WITH A
PORTFOLIO OF ASSETS AND
STRATEGIES TO ADAPT.
LET ME MOVE TO THE NEXT TOPIC
BECAUSE AGAIN I WANNA I WANNA
HEAR FROM.
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE ASSEMBLED SO
HALIBUT PERMIT TRANSFERS THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON. IT'S ANOTHER RECENT
EXAMPLE OF COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTIONS.
IN TERMS OF THE RECENT OMNIBUS
BILL RIGHT.
WE'VE HEARD THAT BOTH BOTH THE
COMMISSION AND THE MARINE
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. ABOUT THE
ONGOING CONCERN FROM FISHERMEN.
REGARDING CONSTRAINTS ON
TRANSFERRING THOSE TOUCH ALL
VESSELS PERMITS.
SOME REAL CHALLENGES FOR FOLKS.
WHO WANT TO MODERNIZE THEIR
BUSINESS?
AND ALSO YOU KNOW WHO SIMPLY
WANT TO GET A A NEW ABOUT.
SO THE FACT THAT THESE PERMITS
TRAVEL WITH THE BOAT AND CAN'T
BE TRANSFERRED FROM ONE BOAT TO
ANOTHER OWNED BY THE SAME
FISHERMEN.
UNLESS THERE'S A SPECIFIC
IRREPARABLE DAMAGE TO THE VESSEL
IS CREATING A LOT OF LET'S SAY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES RIGHT
SO.
YOU KNOW THE NEURAL PROVISIONS
DEFINED IN THE FISHING GAME CODE
GOVERNING CONDITIONS ALLOWING
FOR THE TRANSFER PERMITS THAT.
YEAH THESE ARE IN PLACE UNTIL A
pADOPTED OR THERE'S A
LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE. I'M SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
SEE THE INTRODUCTION OF YOUR
BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE THAT I
THINK WILL ADDRESS A LOT OF
THESE CHALLENGES SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THAT.
AND THEN FINALLY ISSUED IT TO
TOUCH ON IS THE MARINE LIFE
MANAGEMENT.
ACT THE THE MLM MAY IN THE
MASTER PLAN UPDATE IS NEAR
COMPLETION AFTER A LONG PROCESS.
OVER TWO YEARS ON HOW TO UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERIES LAW.
THAT PLAN SERVES AS A ROAD MAP
TO IMPLEMENT THE MLM MAY FIRST
WRITTEN ALMOST FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
AND UP OBVIOUSLY A LOT'S CHANGED
SINCE THEN.
WE'VE GOT NEW TOOLS AND
STRATEGIES TO BETTER ADDRESS
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT AND AND THE
CHALLENGES WE NEED TO BE MORE
ADAPTIVE SO.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE GOALS I
THINK IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT OF
THE MASTER PLAN IS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH A SHARED SET
OF EXPECTATIONS. FOR FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT BETWEEN THE
COMMISSION DEPARTMENT
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC.
WITH BOTH THE COMMISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW WE REALLY
MUST PRIORITIZE WHAT TO TACKLE
FIRST.
IN THE MASTER PLAN HELPS
pTHINK THROUGH WHAT SCALE OF
MANAGEMENT IS APPROPRIATE FOR
ALL FISHERIES AND. I'M SO WE'RE
WE'RE CURRENTLY CONSIDERING
ADOPTING THE DRAFT AND THERE'S
STILL TIME BY THE WAY FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO COMMENT ON A
PRIOR TO THE COMMISSION'S APRIL
MEETING.
AND THEY WILL BE TAKEN THAT UP
FOR ADOPTION IN JUNE.
AND THEN THEN THE REAL WORK
BEGINS TO CARRY IT OUT A SO WITH
THAT I WILL STOP AND SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS AND I
I'M JUST GONNA ANNOUNCE.
UP UP FRONT THAT IF I CAN ANSWER
THEM BUT I'VE GOT A CAPABLE
STAFF BACK HERE WHO.
WHO COME UP AND OUR DIRECTOR
VALERIE TO ME FOR SURE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE YOU KNOW THINK IT'S TOO
MUCH TO VICE PRESIDENT WOULD
TAKE? IF WE'VE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS VICE PRESIDENT AGNEW
STATISTICS LITTLE MORE.
IT DIFFER DIVING CAN LESSEN TWO
MINUTES JUST TO GET AN EXTERNAL
BUT ON THIS COMMUNITY MEETINGS
AND.
ONCE YOU'RE ABLE TO COLLECT IT
THE DATA WOULD YOU HOPE TO DO
WITH IT.
YEAH I THINK YOU KNOW AS WE IN
AND AGAIN I'LL HAVE OUR EN
MINUTES TO WHAT MIGHT COME UP
AND AND AND SUPPLEMENT MY
RESPONSE WHAT BUT CERTAINLY ARE
PLANNED.
AT AS YOU KNOW AS WE DID WITH
THE COMMISSION ON MANY ISSUES IS
TO BRING THAT STAKEHOLDER INPUT
TOGETHER. PALM AND THEN TO
DEVELOP WHAT WE MIGHT THINK OF
AS YOU KNOW SOME REGULATORY OR
pPOLICY SUGGESTIONS THAT WOULD
BE
NEEDED AND AND MOVE SWIFTLY TO
TO TO BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMISSION. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY'RE ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO BRING THOSE AS WELL AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AS I SAID
YOU KNOW. AS WE'VE GONE AROUND
THE STATE IT'S THERE'S A
CRITICAL NEED TO ACT VERY
QUICKLY SO WE DON'T WANT THIS TO
BE A DRAWN OUT PROCESS WHERE
IT'S YOU KNOW YEARS DOWN THE
LINE. OF OF CONTINUED IT KIND OF
GATHER INPUT BUT WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO HAVE THAT INPUT WE WANNA
HAVE A PROCESS THAT'S OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT.
AND AND BUILDS UPON ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
GATHERING.
BUT TO BRING THAT TO SOME
ACTION RELATIVELY QUICKLY NO
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WHEN THE SENATE THAT MIKE
GUY ANY ANY ITEMS THAT YOU LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON TO WITH THE
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MORTGAGE
LENDERS INTRODUCING YOURSELF AND
SORRY I'M IN BALLARD TO ME AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COMMISSION THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TWO MORE
MEETINGS. BETWEEN EIGHT WOULD
SAY. APRIL AND JUNE LOCATED IN
FORT BRAGG AND HALF MOON BAY
AREA. AND THEN HOPEFULLY WILL
CULMINATE ALL OF THOSE MEETINGS
AND HAVE A COUPLE KEY THEMES
THAT WE'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SHE COULD ACCESS IS THE
BIG ONE. I THINK WHAT'S
INTERESTING TOO IS HOW IT WILL
DOVETAIL IN WITH THEM I MAY.
INITIATIVE AND HOW WE CAN FOCUS
ON PRIORITIZING A COUPLE
FISHERIES WHAT'S IMPORTANT THERE
TOO IS TO THINK THROUGH. HOW WE
CAN HELP OUR COMMUNITIES BE MORE
RESILIENT IN THE FUTURE SO IF
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE IF IT'S ICE
IF IT'S A HOIST LIKE HOW CAN WE
THINK THROUGH WHAT FISHERIES
MIGHT BE THERE? IN TWENTY YEARS
OF VERSES IN THE CYCLICAL CYCLES
AT THE OCEAN GOES THROUGH AND SO
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE RESILIENT
THROUGH THOSE CYCLES. CONSISTENT
THAT SOME OF THESORT OF ON THE
GROUND ON THE BOOTS ARE THE
PROJECTS THAT. I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL AS WELL AS THE LARGER
RESTRICTED ACCESS POLICY IN
ADOPTING THAT TO BE A BIT MORE.
ADAPTIVE GIVEN CURRENT
CONDITIONS THAT'S GREAT AT THIS
ADDRESS TO DO AT ALL.
I HAVE OBSERVED A FEW THE
MEETINGS AND TWO WORDS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MENTIONED ICE
AND VOICED.
I WAS NOT READY FOR BUT FOUND
VERY INTERESTING A LOT OF
FEEDBACK.
HEY WHEN I CATCH SOMETHING I'M
TRYING TO MAKE A DECISION AS.
FISHERMEN OR WOMEN WHERE I GO
AND OFTEN THAT'S CONTROLLED BY
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
HARBOR.
THE ICE EQUIPMENT THAT CAN HELP
ME AND THEN THAT'S INFLUENCING
WRAPS GOING TO OREGON RATHER
THAN THE CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT SEEMS LIKE INTERESTING
INFORMATION THE DIMENSIONAL
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ACT ON. THIS
GREAT. WOULD LOVE IT. IF YOU
THINK THAT ATTITUDE TO THIS FALL
YOU WOULD HAVE SOME EARLY
FINDINGS.
WOULD THAT BE ACCURATE SO I'D
ANTICIPATE A PRELIMINARY REPORT
PROBABLY BY OCTOBER COMMISSION
MEETING. WE WOULD LOVE IT IF IT
HAD BECOME A REPORT TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS SIX RIGHT LOOK
I THINK THE THE BOTTOM LINE TO
IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS. A MAN
WITH A DECLINE RIGHT WE SEEM
PARTICULARLY THIS IS HE'S CRAP
ON THE NORTH COAST FOR EXAMPLE
OR SARDINE.
WHAT COMMUNITIES ARE DOING TO
BE ABLE TO ADAPT AS ARE IN AT
THE STATE CAN DO TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST WITH THAT AS WELL? I KNOW
YOU NEED DEEP IN THIS PROCESS.
IN LOOKING AT WHAT WE CAN DO TO
ASSIST IN THE STREET BUT.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THE NORTH
COAST WITH HIM WERE GONE.
.
SALMON AND CRAP ARE YOUR NUMBER
ONE DRIVERS SELL WHEN IT COMES
THE ECONOMY.
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU ARE KNEE
DEEP IN THIS SO WOULD LOVE IT
THAT BE ABLE TO HAPPY I COME IN
THIS FALL. REPORT BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S CRITICAL FOR BY THE
ENTIRE FLEET WOULD BE THRILLED
TO THINK OF THE WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MEDICINE THANK YOU
MUCH. THANK YOU.
SOLICITOR GENERAL ELECTED TO DO
A QUICK FORMAT REVIEW WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING TWO PANELS HERE
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME TO OUR.
SECOND PANEL OF THE DAY WHICH IS
TITLED OFFSHORE OIL THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT ECONOMY
IN FISHERIES FOR TO WELCOME OUR
THREE PANELISTS VEHICLE FOR
LIVING IN A DECENT. HERE IN A
MOMENT FOR THEN GONNA HAVE OUR
SALMON FISHERIES UPDATE HERE
FROM UC DAVIS ON THEIR LATEST
STUDY. THAT IS ALARMING BUILDING
HERE FROM THE MAN THE MYTH THE
LEGEND WHO WAS ON IT LAST NIGHT
DAVIS. IN ALONG WITH JOHN
MCMANUS ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SALMON FISHERY FOR
AND TAKE A QUICK BREAK RIGHT
AFTER THAT. AND THEN GET INTO
THE REMAINDER OF THE HEARING BUT
FIRST WE WELCOMED OUR ESTEEMED
PANEL HERE TO.
.
THE FORTY FIFTH ANNUAL FORM AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK I'M GONNA INTRODUCE EACH OF
THEM AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
MISTER. OPPENHEIM AND WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
THAT WORKING HERE FROM TO DAY
FIRST IS THE FISHING INDUSTRY IN
THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF
EXPANDED OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
OFF THE CALIFORNIA COAST AND
THAT'S WITH NO OPPENHEIM WHO'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION HE'S
GOING TO FOCUS. ON THE PHYSICAL
AND BIOLOGICAL THREATS AT THAT.
FFSHORE OIL DRILLING EXPANDED
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING. POSES AND
ANY POTENTIAL ECONOMIC IMPACTS
WILL HAVE ON THE FISHING
INDUSTRY IF WE SEE THAT
EXPANSION WITHIN CAN HEAR FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE DIRECTOR
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IS
HERE. AS CATHERINE PHILLIPS HE'S
GONNA ADDRESS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF CONTINUED AND EXPANDED
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING. AND.
PROVIDING HER ANALYSIS ON WHAT
AN EXPANDED PLAN WOULD LOOK LIKE
A IS FAR AS THE IMPACT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE THIRD WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON IS OUR ECONOMY TO
CALIFORNIA HAS A FORTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR COASTAL ECONOMY.
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS
ARE DEPENDING ON THE CLEAN COAST
IN ONE OF THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC
DRIVERS WITHIN OUR CULTURAL CON
ME IS OUTDOOR RECREATION. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT KATIE HOPKINS IS
HERE SHE'S A STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERS. GROUP SHE'S
GOING TO DISCUSS POTENTIAL
IMPACTS THAT OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING. HAS HAD IN MAY HAVE ON
OUTDOOR RECREATION AND BY THE
WAY WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
OUTDOOR RECREATION.
COMBINED I SAID IT'S TEN
BILLION FOR OTHER REGRESSIONS
TEN DEALING FOR TOURISM I POP.
ZHAI'S ITS NINETY TWO BILLION
ECONOMIC STIMULUS TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH ALL
INDUSTRIES COMBINED WHEN IT
COMES TO OUTDOOR RECREATION SO
WE HAVE. FISHERIES ENVIRONMENT
AS WELL AS OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN THE STATE SO
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO NO ONE.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN EACH OF
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROBLEM
NO WE WELCOME EASTERN TAKE YOU
FROM YOUR WORK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE CHAIR
LEADER DOLLY.
MY NAME IS NO OFF TIME I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS. AND I
WANNA TAKE A BRIEF MOMENT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND DEDICATION IN DEFENSE OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL
FISHERIES YOU AND I AND EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM. KNOW THAT FISHING
IS A PERMANENT.
PART OF OUR STATE'S CLOSELY
CONNIE.
THAT LEGACY OF PROTECTION THAT
YOU AND IVE INHERITED HIS TO
PRESERVE.
THESE FISHERIES AND PREVENT THE
SCOURGE OF OIL DEVELOPMENT FROM
IMPACTING OUR COASTLINES.
CLOSING OUR FISHERIES AND
DAMAGING ARE CLOSELY KANA ME.
NOT ONLY IS NEW OFFSHORE OIL
DEVELOPMENT IN CONGRESS WITH THE
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL NEED TO CURB
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT
WOULD BE GREAT AND JEOPARDIZE
BOTH OUR COASTAL AND OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS. AND OUR OCEAN
ECONOMY PARTICULARLY COMMERCIAL
FISHERIES.
THE SEVEN MEMBERS ARE RELYING ON
THE HEALTH OF OUR OCEANS AND WE
KNOW FIRST HAND HOW THE
PRODUCTIVITY. OF THESE OCEANS
PROVIDE JOBS HEALTHY FOOD AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR NATION'S
ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA HAS A THIRTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR OCEAN
ECONOMY CONSISTING OF COMMERCIAL
FISHING SHIPPING RECREATION
TOURISM AND MANY OTHER SECTORS
ALL CO EXISTING WITH RELATIVELY
MINIMAL CONFLICT SHARING THE
OCEAN AND ITS RENEWABLE BOUNTY.
THE VALUE OF THESE INDUSTRIES
INCLUDE SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE FROM THE LEGAL AND
SUSTAINABLE HARVEST. OF LIVING
MARINE RESOURCES WITH PROPER
MANAGEMENT OF OUR RENEWABLE
RESOURCES THIS ECONOMY THAT WILL
FLOURISH AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
GOOD JOBS AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY FOR GENERATIONS.
OIL AND GAS AND OTHER MINERAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE AREAS AS
WELL AS IN THE ACTIVITIES
REQUIRED FOR SUCH DEVELOPMENT
WOULD THREATEN OUR MEMBERS
LIVELIHOOD. THEY WERE JAPANESE
JEOPARDIZETHEIR ABILITY TO
OPERATE OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT
PROHIBITIONS AND RESULTED IN
MULTIPLE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN IN CALIFORNIA. BY
ENSURING THAT THE INEVITABLE
HARM CAUSED BY PATROLLING
EXTRACTION DOES NOT DEAL WITH
SERIOUSLY IMPACT THEIR ABILITY
TO FISH. THE COMPANY
DISTRACTIONS PLAN TO DEVELOP
OFFSHORE OIL RESOURCES HERE
PRIORITIZE SHORT TERM GAME FOR
ONE INDUSTRY WHILE RISKING THE
HEALTH AND LONGEVITY. OF ALL
OTHER OCEAN AND COASTAL BASED
INDUSTRIES AND THE STABILITY OF
OUR COASTAL STATES ECONOMY AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AS A RESULT.
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONTENT OF THE BUREAU OF OCEAN
ENERGY MANAGEMENT STRAFFORD POST
PROGRAM. PARTICULARLY AS A
CONTEMPLATES CALIFORNIA'S
FISHERIES AND THE EXTREME
MISINTERPRETATION OF THE YEAR
THEIR ECONOMIC VALUE ALONG OUR
COAST.
MR OFF PROPOSE PROGRAM
SHOCKINGLY CLAIMS THAT
COMMERCIAL FISHING DOESN'T EXIST
THE NORTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA LET ME JUST STATE FOR
THE RECORD THAT. THERE ARE
COMMERCIAL FISHING ACTIVITIES IN
CENTRAL AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE FACT THAT OUR ORGANIZATION
IS ABOUT TO SUBMIT FEDERAL
COMMENTS TO A FEDERAL AGENCY
THAT POINTS OUT THIS BASIC FACT
IS ASTOUNDING. BLOWS MY MIND THE
DRAFT ALSO FAILS TO CONTEMPLATE
THE TRUE VALUE OF OUR FISHERIES
STATEWIDE ESPECIALLY CONCERNING
THAT THE SINGLE YEAR THAT WAS
USED TO REPRESENT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL FISHING
IN STREET. WAS TWO THOUSAND NINE
WHICH AS WE KNOW IS A YEAR THAT
WITH DEVASTATING COMMERCIAL.
SALMON FISHERY CLOSURES THAT
CAUSED AN ESTIMATED LOSS OF A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND A LOSS OF EIGHTEEN.
HUNDRED JOBS THE CHERRY PICKING
IS SO BLATANT IT BORDERS ON THE
CONSPIRATORIAL.
ANYONE A BOWL AND IS OR WILL BE
WATCHING. I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
DISAPPOINTMENT YOUR AGENCY THIS
IS NOT QUALITY WORK IT'S SHODDY
STAFF WORK IT'S SHAMEFUL
REPRESENTS THE GENERAL FAILURE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR TO
CONTEMPLATE THE DEVASTATION IT'S
DEVELOPMENTAL PROGRAMS.
THE OCEAN AND OUR RIVERS ARE TO
OUR INDUSTRY. SHAMEFUL SITTING
BEHIND ME NOW IS A LIVING LEGEND
CAPTAIN MIKE MCCORKLE. WHO TOLD
ME JUST NOW THAT HE WAS LESS
THAN A MILE AWAY? WHEN OUT
FISHING WHEN THE WELL THAT
SPURNED THE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
SANTA BARBARA OIL SPILL
HAPPENED.
MR MCCORKLE SHUT DOWN HIS CROWDS
ARE FULL OF OIL AND YEARS LATER
THE FISHING INDUSTRY WAS NEVER
COMPENSATED.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN AGAIN WE IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
WE NOW KNOW THAT IT DOESN'T EVEN
TAKE THE DRILLING OF A SINGLE
WELL. TO RESULT IN ECONOMIC HARM
AND DEVASTATION THE LIVING
MARINE RESOURCES SEISMIC AIR GUN
SURVEYS WHICH ARE CONDUCTED TO
EXPLORE MINERAL RESOURCES BELOW
THE SEA FLOOR. TOE GIANT ARRAYS
OF. PNEUMATIC EXPLOSIVE DEVICES
WHICH. PINNING DOWN HUNDREDS OF
METERS BELOW THE CREST OF THE OF
THE SEA FLOOR. THESE ACOUSTIC
SIGNALS WHICH ARE I'M TOLD AS
LOUD AS A SPACE SHUTTLE TAKING
OFF. NOT ONLY.
AS WE KNOW DESTROYED THE THE.
ORGANS OF MARINE MAMMALS AND AS
WE'RE LEARNING CAN DISRUPT FISH
POPULATIONS BUT AS WE NOW KNOW
IS BASED ON A TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN STUDY ACTUALLY KILL
LARVAL FISH FOR MILES AROUND. SO
WE DON'T HAVE TO.
DIG A SINGLE OIL WELL IN ORDER
TO DESTROY OUR OCEANS. AND THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW THE STATE IS STEPPING UP.
IN CONCLUSION MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO SAY THAT PCS A STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE AN SP EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WE
HOPE THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WILL ACT TO SUPPORT
THE PREVENTION OF NEW ON SHORE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR NEW OIL AND
GAS LEASES. DESTRUCTIVE POSE
PROGRAM IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
WE DON'T WANT THESE NEW PIECES
KEEP IT IN THE GROUND PC WITH A
STANCE WITH YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THOSE TWO BILLS
WOULD BAN.
THE REFINING OF ANY AND OR
TRANSPORTING IF ANY THE
CRUISER TO BE TAKEN OFF OF THESE
RIGS OR ANY INFRASTRUCTURE ON
LAND IN CALIFORNIA FROM ANY OF
THESE NEW BRAKES SO. AGAIN MR
EXECUTIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ADVOCACY HAD HANG WITH US. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR THIS YEAR CLIPS HERE
MISS PHILLIPS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES MA'AM AIMED AT WE WILL
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPTED THINK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SON.
RADIO. RED LIGHT RED LIGHT OKAY.
SO THERE ARE THREE KEY
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS RESULTING
FROM OIL DRILLING WHILE LIFE
IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS
AND THE FUTURE OF THE PLANET.
AND THEY EACH OF THESE THINGS
WILL SUFFER IF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO ALLOW OIL
EXTRACTION. HERE. BUT ESPECIALLY
IN NEW OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING IS
LOUD AND IF IT IS FORCED ON THE
STATE BY THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION AND BY THE OIL
INDUSTRY. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS AN ACTING
ALONE IN THIS IT'S THE OIL
INDUSTRY THAT'S DEMANDING THAT
OFFSHORE OIL FEE OPENED UP.
THE FIRST ABOUT WILDLIFE I THINK
IT'S INSTRUCTIVE TO LOOK AT THE
REFUGIO BEACH OIL SPILL OF MAY
OF TWENTY FIFTEEN. BAT WAS AS
OIL SPILLS GO A TINY OIL SPILL.
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND GALLONS OF
OIL ENDED UP IN THE OCEAN OF
GRANITE IT CAME FROM A HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLON SPILL. FROM A
PIPELINE ON ON LAND BUT
ULTIMATELY TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
GALLONS ENDED UP IN THE OCEAN.
AND SMALLER SPILLS ARE FAIRLY
COMMON. BUT.
IT COVERED AN AREA OF TWENTY
THREE BY SIX MILES. AND IT
CLOSED WITH THAT WAS CLOSED TO
FISHING AFTER THIS BILL FOR MORE
THAN A MONTH TO BEACHES WERE
CLOSED FOR NEARLY A MONTH DURING
CLEAN UP.
ACCORDING TO THE DATA COLLECTED
BY THE OILED WILDLIFE CARE
NETWORK DURING THE FIRST MONTH
AFTER THIS BILL FIFTY SEVEN
BIRDS WERE CAPTURED WITH OIL.
IN AND CLEANED UP BUT A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE WERE FOUND DEAD.
THE BIGGEST HIT WAS TO BROWN
PELICANS SIXTY TWO MAMMALS WERE
COLLECTED ALIVE AND A HUNDRED
AND SIX WERE FOUND DEAD THE
BIGGEST HIT WAS TO SEE LINES
THERE ABOUT TWELVE DEAD
DOLPHINS.
THESE NUMBERS.
INCREASE SLIGHTLY OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS BUT WHAT THESE
NUMBERS DON'T REFLECT IS THE
WILDLIFE YOU DON'T SEE THE BIRD
TO GET OILED AND MANAGED TO. OF
FLIES SHORT DISTANCE AND THEN
DIE OUT FARTHER OUT AT SEA WHERE
THE THE WORKERS THE RESCUE TEAMS
ARE NOT LOCATED.
WE ALSO DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE FISH WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO THE TWO.
THE.
INSECTS TO THE THE MOLLUSKS TO
ALL SORTS OF CREATURES THAT
DON'T GET RESCUED. AND THEY WHAT
WE WON'T KNOW THE LONG TERM
IMPACTS TO THE FISHERY OF THAT
OIL SPILL FOR A LONG LONG TIME
IT'S GOING TO TAKE AWHILE FOR
SCIENTISTS TO STARTS TO USED AS
DIRECTED AS SOME PEOPLE
HAVE NOTED IS HARMFUL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THE DOMINANT SOURCE OF EVERY
DAY POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA. IS.
FROM TAILPIPE EMISSIONS AS THE
PRODUCT OF BURNING OIL.
IN VARIOUS FORMS EITHER AS
GASOLINE OR DIESEL FUEL OR OR
OTHER FUELS RELATED UGH THAT
COME FROM PETROLEUM OR NATURAL
GAS.
THESE THESE. OF.
THESE EMISSIONS RESULT IN. ABOUT
NINETY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
AT ANY TIME DURING THE YEAR
BEING EXPOSED TO UNHEALTHY AIR.
THERE'S ONLY A REALLY SMALL
PORTION OF CALIFORNIANS THAT CAN
SAY THAT THEY HAVE CLEAN AIR
EVERY DAY. AND IF THEY NEVER
LEAVE THEIR LITTLE CLEAN AIR
SPOT. AND THEY DON'T GO TO SAN
FRANCISCO THEY DON'T GO TO LA
THEY DON'T GO TO FRESNO. THEN
THEY THEY CAN AVOID BEING
EXPOSED TO DIRTY AIR BUT
VIRTUALLY EVERY CALIFORNIAN IS
EXPOSED TO DIRTY AIR AT LEAST.
SOME POINT DURING THE YEAR AND
THOSE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
MOST POLLUTED AIR DISTRICTS LIKE
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE
LOS ANGELES AIR BASE IN. THE
MOST THOSE ARE TWO OF THE TOP
THREE POLLUTED AIR DISTRICTS IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY TO THIS TOP
THREE POLLUTED AIR BASINS. AND
THEY GET EXPOSED DOZENS OF DAYS
EACH YEAR.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME OF
THE HIGHEST.
HIGHEST RATES OF LUNG DISEASE
AMONG CHILDREN PARTICULARLY
ASTHMA. WE KNOW FROM
LONGITUDINAL STUDIES THAT
CHILDREN WHO GROW UP IN HIGHLY
POLLUTED AREAS IN CALIFORNIA
REACH ADULTHOOD WITH
UNDERDEVELOPED LUNGS. WE KNOW
THAT PREMATURE BIRTHS ARE MORE
FREQUENT AND HIGHLY POLLUTED
AREAS. WE KNOW THAT HEART
DISEASE IS HIGHER IN HIGHLY
POLLUTED AREAS WE KNOW FROM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AND THIS NUMBER MAY HAVE
INCREASED SLIGHTLY R DECREASE
SLIGHTLY I'M I'M NOT SURE BUT AT
ONE POINT. A SEVERAL YEARS AGO A
STUDY WAS DONE OF THE.
COSTS OF AIR POLLUTION IN THE
LOS ANGELES BASIN IT WAS ABOUT
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. IN HEALTH CARE COSTS LOST
TIME AT WORK LAST DAYS AT SCHOOL
AND LOST DAYS AT SCHOOL HAVE A
LONG TERM IMPACT.
YOU MANY WORRY SECONDS WE WILL
NEVER HAVE A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
WILL NEVER ACHIEVE CLEAN AIR AND
THE STATE IF WE CONTINUE TO
EXTRACT AND BURN.
SIMPLE AS THAT AND FINALLY THE
PLANET'S FUTURE.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS WE NEED TO
KEEP IT IN THE GROUND JUST AS
NOAH SAID IF WE DON'T KEEP IT IN
THE GROUND WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
A FUTURE WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
THE IMPACTS HERE. SO.
YOU ASKED AT THE BEGINNING WHAT
ARE THE SOLUTIONS I THINK ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS IS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR.
ALL OF US WHO ARE CONSUMERS WE
NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT.
CHANGING OUR HABITS BUT ALSO
NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
SENDING A SIGNAL TO THE OIL
INDUSTRY THAT THEY NEED TO
CHANGE THEIR BUSINESS THEY NEED
TO GET OUT OF OIL. THEY NEED TO
GET INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
CLEANER AND WE HAVE TO STOP
BECAUSE BEING THAT ONE OF THE
TOP OIL PRODUCING STATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO I
MISS HAWKINS NOW STIRRING
COMMITTEE MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
OUTDOOR RECREATION PARTNERS OR
AN OPEN UP FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE COMMITTEE. WE
WELCOME YOU AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES OF THE THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT GREAT THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU ALSO IT SOUNDS
LIKE LAST NIGHT WAS PRETTY FUN
I'M SORRY I MISSED I KNOW NEXT
YEAR WATCH OUT. THERE TO GO YOU
CAN'T GO WRONG WITH THAT BEER
AND CRAP.
OKAY A GREAT AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I'M KATIE HOPKINS I'M A MEMBER
OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE FOR
THE OUT CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERS COURT.
WE ARE GROWING COALITION OF
BUSINESSES USER GROUPS AND
AGENCIES THAT REPRESENT THE
NINETY TWO BILLION DOLLAR IMPACT
ABOUT HER RECREATION RELATED
CONSUMER SPENDING HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
UNITED STATES AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE OUTDOOR INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALLY A. RELEASE AN
UPDATED REPORT OF THE STATE
ABOUT OUTDOOR COMPANY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REPORT FOUND THAT THE CALIFORNIA
OUTDOOR ECONOMY REPRESENTS
GREATER THAN NINETY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. ECONOMIC STIMULUS TO THE
STATE SUPPORTS NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS AND
GENERATES OVER THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALARIES AND WAGES.
THIS WAS NEARLY TEN PERCENT.
INCREASE FROM THE PREVIOUS FIVE
YEARS.
OUR STATE ECONOMY IS THE SIXTH
LARGEST IN THE WORLD AND IT'S
TIED TO CLEAN COASTAL WATERS AND
BEACHES AS WELL AS A STABLE
CLIMATE. OUR STATE BOASTS ONE OF
THE MOST SPECTACULAR CLOSED
AREAS IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD APPROXIMATELY
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
TOURISTS ANNUALLY. CONTOUR CAUSE
TO FISH HIKE KAYAK SURF WINE AND
DINE ENJOY OUR BEACHES ARE COOL
SILICON A METER SKIS NEAR
COASTAL CONNIE CONTRIBUTES MORE
THAN A HALF A MILLION JOBS. AND
FORTY BILLION ANNUALLY TO THE
STATE OCEAN BASED RECREATION AND
TOURISM ALONE CONTRIBUTES TWENTY
BILLION. ANNUALLY AND PROVIDES
MORE THAT JOBS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
SO CALIFORNIANS CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT OUR ELEVEN HUNDRED MILE
COASTLINE AND PUBLIC BEACHES
WHICH SURPRISED MILLIONS OF
VISITORS A YEAR OUR POST IS HOME
TO A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR STATE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS. FORMER
NATIONAL MARINE SANCTUARIES AND
FOR NATIONAL PARKS WITH OCEAN
WATERS. THESE AREAS PROTECTED
SPECIES AND ECOSYSTEMS AND HELP
FUEL A VIBRANT COASTAL ECONOMY.
NOW I KNOW THAT KATHERINE SPOKE
ABOUT SANTA BARBARA INSERTED NO
LESS I DON'T REALLY WHAT I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THEIR COMMENTS AS
WELL AS THE IMPACT OF THE
OFFSHORE DRILLING HAS
ESPECIALLY.
THAT LONG LASTING EFFECTS WHEN
SPILLS DO HAPPEN SO I JUST WANT
TO ECHO YOUR COMMENTS WE FEEL
THE SAME.
SO GOING ON I JUST WANNA SAY WE
THEREFORE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EFFORTS UNDER WAY AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL TO
OPPOSE NEW OR EXPANDED OFFSHORE
OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT. THE
PACIFIC OCEAN IN KHOST SUSTAINS
OUR ECONOMIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
AND OFFSHORE DRILLING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY AT ODDS WITH OUR
COASTAL ECONOMY IN A WAY OF
LIFE.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S THRIVING
RECREATION INTERESTS INDUSTRY IS
RELYING ON A HEALTHY ACCESSIBLE
COAST AND OCEAN CORP OPPOSES ANY
NEW OFF SHORE OIL OR GAS
DEVELOPMENT OFF CALIFORNIA. AND
THINKS THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP.
AND STOP IN ANY NEW
DEVELOPMENTS THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
TURN OVER THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
FIFTY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THIS PARTICULAR PANEL.
SO JUST A QUICK COMMENT THINKS
MUCH.
OBVIOUS IS BIPARTISAN ISSUE WE
HAVE FIVE I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
SIX REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HAVE
COME OUT AGAINST THIS PLAN.
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF OTHERS OF
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO TALK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
THINK OBVIOUS INSTRUMENT I'M
GLAD BIPARTISAN INDUSTRY THAT
YOU REPRESENT AND A UNIFIED IN
THE APPROACHES. IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING LIVELIHOODS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE ECONOMIC ARGUMENT IS
STARKLY%
CLEAR.
.
AND. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
CHERUB CHOIR THERE'S NO THEIR NO
BONES ABOUT IT WHETHER YOU ARE A
CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL. OUTSIDE
THE FACT THE MATTER IS THAT THIS
INDUSTRY HAS NO PLACE IN THESE
PARTICULAR WATERS ABSOLUTELY NOT
AND. II'M GLAD THAT POLITICAL
REALITIES.
ARE ENABLING EVERYONE TO COME
TOGETHER. AND THEN SHARE THIS
OPINION AND JOIN IN PROTECTING
OUR COCINA CENTURIES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
PLEASE MISSILES.
I JUST WANT TO NOTE.
YOU KNOW BEING AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST DOESN'T HAVE A
PARTY AFFILIATION EITHER AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE POLLING IN
CALIFORNIA SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND I THINK ONE
REASON CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABLE
TO LEAD ON ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
IS BECAUSE IT IS CONSIDERED A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE IN THE STATE.
IT ISN'T ALWAYS REFLECTED BY
SOME OF THE VOTES WE SEE. BUT
THEN IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT I
THINK IF YOU TALK TO MOST
CALIFORNIANS YOU'RE GOING TO
FIND THAT MOST CALIFORNIANS DO
NOT WANT.
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING WHETHER
THEY'RE REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT
NOTHING SO MUCH.
MY LAST QUESTION IS HAWKINS CAN
YOU BREAK OUT THAT NINETY TWO
BILLION HOW MUCH OF IT IS CEAN
DEPENDENT IN COASTAL DEPENDENT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY BREAK DOWN ON
THAT YEAH SO HE'S.
FILL UP THAT. THE BUT WHAT WE
FOUND WAS THAT OCEAN BASED
RECREATION AND TOURISM WAS ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION ABOUT TWENTY
BILLION YES.
THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL A
COMPLETE SYSTEM. IS NOT THE
LABOR THIS BUT JUST TO WEIGH IN
A LITTLE BIT AND I THINK THESE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT HAVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE PRACTICAL
MATTER.
OF HAVING OFFSHORE OIL LEASES
WITH WITHOUT ONSHORE FACILITIES
THE MORE WE PUSH BACK ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE LESS LIKELY IT IS
THAT ANYONE COULD BE INTERESTED
IN THIS. STAKE IN THESE. LEASE
SALES. IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REALLY MOVES FORWARD ON THIS AND
WHERE WE ARE VULNERABLE IS WHERE
THERE ARE EXISTING FACILITIES.
ON SHORE FACILITIES TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE MORE OIL IN BUT A LOT OF
THOSE FIELDS ARE. DEPLETED IT'S
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
DO MUCH OTHER THAN TRY TO EXPAND
DRILLING. FOR THE LOUDER WE ARE
THE MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE THE RESPONSE TO
THE FEDERAL PLAN THAN THE LESS
LIKELY ANYONE WILL WANT TO.
REALLY ACQUIRE THOSE PLACES
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE A FIGHT. SO THAT'S
WHAT EERY OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT IT LOT OF RALLIES
HAVE BEEN DONE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO DRAW ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
WE ALL WENT OUR VOICE TO THE
EFFORT TEACHER OR TO TO CUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
INTERESTED IN THIS CHANGE.
WITHOUT A VERY CONSISTENT POLICY
TOWARDS OFFSHORE DRILLING FOR
DECADES NOW CALIFORNIA THAT
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGREED WITH
THAT UNTIL NOW SO IT'S REALLY
FRUSTRATING TO SEE. THIS CHANGE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND WE JUST
NEED TO STAND TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE PAST
YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARAGRAPH THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING SO MUCH
TIME AND YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
PLEASE YEAH WE'RE NOT IN THE
MOVIE FOR TWO OUR THIRD PANEL
THAT DAY IN THAT IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SALMON FISHERIES. WE
E. ARE GONNA HAVE EACH OF OUR
THREE PANELISTS APPEAR TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD WE'RE GONNA START
OUR PANEL TODAY WITH THE DOCTOR
I ROBERT LAZAR USE THE RESEARCH
ECOLOGISTS. IN CALIFORNIA TRY
YOU SEE DAVIS WILD IN COLD WATER
FISH SCIENTISTS HIS BUSINESS
CARD IS REALLY LARGE WITH THAT
TITLE.
HE'S WITH THE CENTER FOR WATER
SHOULD SCIENTISTS WITH.
THE AGGIES THEY'RE. THE GOOD
DOCTOR IS GOING TO BE GIVEN THIS
IS.
A REPORT ON THE STATE OF SALMON
AWAITS THE STATUS OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
DIPLOMATIC FISHES THAT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HIGHLIGHTING
THE URGENT NEED TO PROTECT AND
RESTORE CALIFORNIA STATUS FISH
AND I GOTTA SAY. AS WE TALKED
ABOUT LAST YEAR WE ARE IN FOR
SOME REAL CHALLENGES YOU TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IN THOSE HT
WATER TEMPS WE'RE ALSO GONNA
PLEASE HAVE COME FOR DATE DATES.
PRESENT THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION FISHERMAN'S
ASSOCIATION. MISTER BATES IS
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE STATUS
OF CHINOOK SALMON RUNS. IN THE
COMMERCIAL A SALMON FISHERY HE'S
ALSO GOING TO BE LOOKING INTO
HIS CRYSTAL BALL TODAY.
IT ABOUT THREATS TO BOTH.
EYES SPECIES AND WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO IMPROVE THE SITUATION.
FINALLY WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISTER
MCMANUS PLEASE COME FORWARD HE'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION. JOHNS
GONNA BE PRESENTING CHALLENGES
FACING RECREATIONAL SALMON
FISHING DUE TO IN RIVER IMPACTS.
TO CENTRALVALLEY SALMON AND THE
NEED TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE FLOWS
IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESTORATION.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO BOTH OF
THOSE GENERAL WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
DR THE SARTI WHO'S HERE TODAY
FROM UC DAVIS HE IS GOING TO BE
PRESENT IN.
HIGH LEVEL VIEW OF HIS STUDY
YOU'VE MADE SCENE IS IN MANY.
NEWS OUTLETS ACROSS THE STATE.
THIRTY YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN MINUTES WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE YOU ABOUT A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT AND THEN WE'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MISTER BATES INTO MISTER
MCMANUS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU HOUSE UNDER IT
UNDERSTAND NINETY MINUTES HAZY
THERE IN THE HIGH DID AS I WAS
SAYING.
WE SURE THROWN AT YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN KAREN SAY PRITCHETT
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT
OUR REPORT AND SAYS SOME ON AND
SAYS TO US TOO. AND I WAS A CO
AUTHOR ON THEIR PART WITH DOCTOR
PETERS MORAL PATTER SEMEL SAMUEL
AND JACOB CATS AS WELL. FROM
CALIFORNIA TROUT.
WE UNDERTOOK THIS RESEARCH OVER
APPEARED ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AND WE REVIEW THE STATUS OF ALL
SOMEONE IS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ASKED THREE SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF CALIFORNIA
SOMEONE IT'S WHAT FACTORS TO DO
BECAUSE THEY'RE DECLINE AND HOW
THEY CAN THEY BE CONSERVED INTO
THE FUTURE?
AND WE'LL SKIP RIGHT TO THE
FINDINGS. IN GENERAL THE STATUS
OF SOME ON ADS IN CALIFORNIA OR
IN CONTINUE TO BE IN THE GENERAL
STATE OF DECLINE WE PREDICT THAT
FORTY FIVE PERCENT IN SEVENTY
FOUR PERCENT OF ALL SALMON AND
TROUT IN CALIFORNIA. ARE LIKELY
TO GO EXTINCT WITHIN FIFTY OR
ONE HUNDRED YEARS RESPECTIVELY
IF PRESENT TRENDS CONTINUE.
I NATTER MISTER SPEAKER ID
MIGRATING FISH SITUATION IT CAN
STILL HAD ARE IN GENERAL A
GREATER RISK OF EXTINCTION IN
RESIDENT. IN ONE SPECIES.
WHAT FACTORS OF BECAUSE THEY'RE
DECLINED THE MAJOR SINGLER
THREATS INCLUDE DANCE
COMPETITION FOR WATER ESTUARY
ALTERATION IN NON NATIVE SPECIES
SPECIES INTERACTIONS? OF ALL THE
THREATS WE CONSIDERED HOWEVER
CLIMATE CHANGES FOUND AFFECT
NEARLY EVERY SOMEONE IT
NEGATIVELY MOVING FORWARD.
HOW CAN THEY BE CONSERVED?
I THINK THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
LOOK MUCH FURTHER. THAN THEIR
EVOLUTIONARY HISTORY SALMON HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR AT LEAST FIFTY
MILLION YEARS THEY'VE WEATHERED
MEGA DROUGHTS MASSIVE FLOODS
EARTHQUAKES HABITAT
DISCONNECTIONS PURGE OF
GLACIATION. VOLCANIC ERUPTIONS.
DESPITE ALL THIS THEY CONTINUE
TO PERSIST THEY'RE ABLE TO
PROCESS BECAUSE AT THEIR CORE
SPILL SPECIES WERE BUILT OF
NUMEROUS DIVERSE POPULATIONS.
AND AS SUCH WERE INCREDIBLY
RESILIENT TO CHANGE.
SO WILL SOMEONE DIE OFF DURING
EVENTS SUCH AS A MEGA DROUGHT
OTHER SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS WOULD RECOLONIZE
ADAPT IN SPECIES AS A WHOLE WILL
CONTINUE TO PERSISTAND
PERSEVERE. THOSE DIVERSE
POPULATION FOR PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA'S LANDSCAPE. TODAY
SALMON DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
DIVERSITY TO HABITAT AND YOU
MAKE MANY CASES ARE GENETICALLY
HOMOGENIZED.
TWO GOOD EXAMPLES OF THIS.
PHOENIX SALMON SPECIFICALLY
HAVE.
THE SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED PERCENT
OF THEIR CIRCLE SPAWNING HABITAT
IT'S BEEN COMPLETELY ELIMINATED
IT NOW LIES ABOVE HIGH HEAD DAMN
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
NINETY TO NINETY PERCENT OF ALL
FOUR PLANES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED FROM
PLAINS OF COURSE ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT HABITAT FOR JUVENILE
FICTION JUNE ARE REARING.
THE KEY TO RESTORING SALMON
TROUT THROUGH A CALIFORNIA IS
RESTORING ACCESS TO THESE
DIVERSE HABITATS IN PRODUCTIVE
HABITATS AND PROMOTING WHILE THE
NATURAL ORIGIN SPAWNING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE
BELIEVE THE BEST WAY TO DO THIS
IS AS FOLLOWS. PROTECT THE
HIGHLY FUNCTIONING SYSTEM TO
CONTINUE EXCESS THE SYSTEMS
INCLUDE PLACES LIKE THE SMITHS
THE EAGLE BLUE CREEK AND VIEW
CRAIG FOR SPRING RUN.
ATTACKED IN HER STORE SOURCE
WATER SO THEY CAN PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY WATER FOR SALMON AND
TROUT DURING PERIODS OF DROUGHT.
ENTERING AND AS CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES.
RESTORE A PRODUCTIVE IN DIVERSE
HABITATS IN HISTORICAL PLAYED A
MAJOR ROLE IN ST LIFE HISTORY
MOST SOUTHERLY THESE WOULD
INCLUDE FLOOD PLAINS THROUGHOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SUCH AS THE
YELLOW BY PASSING CENTER BY
PASSES AS WELL.
IMPROVE HABITAT CONNECTIVITY IN
PASSAGE TO HISTORICAL SPAWNING
AND REARING HABITAT TO DAM
REMOVAL OR PASSAGE.
GENETIC MANAGEMENT TO COURAGE
NATURAL ORIGIN WALLFISCH GENOME
TO PERSIST INTO THE FUTURE.
AND FINALLY INCORPORATE
CONSERVATION INTO HUMAN
DOMINATED LANDSCAPES THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS TO CONSIDER WHILE
FISH AND PEOPLE A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF THIS IS THE WORK THAT. YOU
SEE DAVIS IN CALIFORNIA TROUT
HAD DONE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WORKING WITH FARMERS TO REAR
CHINOOK SALMON.
AN EXPERIMENTAL FLOOD PLAINS IN
RICE FIELDS.
WITH THAT. I COULD TALK ABOUT
THE METHODS AND WHAT NOT BUT I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU GUYS A LIST
ESSENTIALLY THE MOST THREATENED
SPECIES IN RANK ORDER THAT WE
REVIEWED. CENTRAL VALLEY WINTER
RUN CHINOOK CENTRAL VALLEY
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA COAST COHO
SALMON OPERA PLANET TRINI SPRING
RUN CHINOOK SOUTHERN OREGON
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST SALMON
CENTRAL VALLEY SPRING RUN
CHINOOK. KLAMATH MOUNTAINS
PRIVATE SUMMER STEEL HEAD SOUTH
CENTRAL COAST DEAL HAD SOUTHERN
STEEL HEAD KERN RIVER RAINBOW
TROUT MACLEOD RAINBOW TROUT IN
OUR STATE FISH THE CALIFORNIA
GOLDEN TROUT ALL THOSE RANKED IS
CRITICAL. AND IF THINGS DON'T
CHANGE VERY SOON IT WILL BE GONE
WITHIN FIFTY YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TERRIBLE NEWS.
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
ANY COMMENTS.
CAN YOU.
WE SAW SADISTIC LAST YEAR THAT
AT THE SACRAMENT A WATERSHED IN
PARTICULAR IS MORE IMPAIRED. IN
WE COULD ACTUALLY START SCENE
PERMANENT. DIE OFF OF INTO
EXTINCTION EVENTS HERE IN THE
NEXT DECADE OR TWO.
SO WHEN YOU SAY FORTY FIVE
PERCENT.
OVER THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS IT'S
GONNA BE EXPEDITED IN SPECIFIC.
WATERSHED CAN YOU GO INTO THAT A
BIT SURE THAT'S EXACTLY THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT SO.
OF ALL THE SPECIES I I PROBABLY
JUST DISCUSSING AND TALKED ABOUT
WHAT DIRECTION AFTER OF COURSE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THEIR REMNANT OF WHAT THEY ONCE
WERE THESE ARE VOLCANIC FISH.
FOR THE LONG RUN FISH THEY MOVED
UP TO PLACES LIKE THE MCCLOUD
RIVER UP BY NOT SHASTA THEY CAN
NO LONGER ACCESS AT HABITAT
THEY'VE BEEN ELIMINATED FROM A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THEIR
STRUGGLE HABITAT.
LAST YEAR THEY HAD.
LESS THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS RETURN OF COURSE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN ENTIRE CORPS COHORTS
WERE NEARLY ELIMINATED THE
NINETY FIVE PERCENT LEVEL DUE TO
WARM WATER. SO.
FRANKLY IF WE HAD ANOTHER YEAR
OF DROUGHT THAT FISH COULD BE
GONE ABSOLUTELY SO IT IS A
CONTINUING THROUGH THAT FIFTY
YEAR PERIOD THE TWO THINGS THAT
WE LOOK AT PRIMARILY AS
GENERATION TIME. IN POPULATION
SIZES TO GET AT THOSE NUMBERS.
IN THE IN.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK ACROSS THE
STATE HOW MANY NINE HATCHERY
FISH OF THE SPECIES THAT YOU
JUST. NAMED ARE ACTUALLY OUT
THERE VERSUS.
COMING FROM HATCHERY WOULD YOU
SAY.
SO SAY THAT AGAIN SO HOW MANY
THE FISH OUT OF THE SPECIES THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED YET. HOW MANY
ARE COMING FROM HATCHERY VERSION
IS STILL WILD WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
GUIDE SAY ON ALL THE SPECIES
WELL WE KNOW THAT?
WINTER INCHING UP AGAIN IS IS
HEAVILY INFLUENCED BY LIVING
TOMBSTONE THEY HAVE A
CONSERVATION HATCHERY SO THAT'S
A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM SAY A
PRODUCTION HATCHERY RIGHT.
CONSERVATION HAVE TREES REALLY
VALUE THE GENETICS.
BUT CERTAINLY.
SEVERAL THE POPULATIONS ARE
INFLUENCED BY MOST OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY RUNS OF SHOULD
NOT CAR INFLUENCE TO SOME EXTENT
BY HATCHERY. HATCHERIES YEAH.
HATCHERY FISH THROUGH
INTERACTIONS IN THE WILD. THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
HAD.
AT LEAST ON THE NORTH COAST AND
ON THE EAGLE RIVER WATERSHED. IN
I THINK IT WAS AT TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE ACTUALLY SAW THE ILL
GO DRY. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY LEGAL OF WATER POOLS FROM
ROSE CANADA'S GROSS YEAH MAN IN
THAT IT HAS EXASPERATED THE
PROBLEM.
ON THE.
RIVER WATERSHED HAS BECOME
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPAIRED ANY
COMMENT ON THAT.
YEAH I WOULD COMPLETELY GREE
WITH THAT HOW IS IT DEFAULT TO
MY FRIEND AMARO WHO WORKS VERY
CLOSELY ON THIS STUFF UP IN THE
NORTH COAST IS ACTUALLY IN THE
ROOM WILL BE SPEAKING LATER.
BUT REGULATING THE CANDIDATES
IN HISTORY IN WATER WITHDRAWALS
AND DIVERSIONS IS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT MOVING FOR THESE THESE
FISH ARE ALREADY ON THE BRINK
SO.
ADDITIONAL KIND OF.
EXTRACTION FROM STREAMS AND
RIVERS IS IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DETRIMENTAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ANY OTHER FULL OF ITEMS
BREAK GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK
TODAY YES HOW MUCH. WE'RE NOT
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO DAVID'S
PRESIDENT OF PACIFIC
CONSIDERATION FISHERMAN'S
ASSOCIATION. AND AGAIN WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE DISTURBANCE FORTY
YEARS. OF HIS ADVOCACY IN
LEADERSHIP. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SUITE. IN THERE HAS
NOT BEEN AN ISSUE AS WE SAID
LAST NIGHT THERE'S UP AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN. A TOP OF MIND FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERMEN THEY DID
IT'S IT'S NOT BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR HIS FRANTIC MOMENTS SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN THE
LEGISLATURE HONORED HIM LAST
NIGHT.
IN INDIA WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE DRIVE SIR
FROM BEAUTIFUL HUMBLE COUNTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THOSE
KIND WORDS AND ALSO FOR THE
AWARD LAST NIGHT I WAS.
COMPLETELY FLORIDA HAD NO IDEA
THAT WAS COMING AND I WONDERED
WHAT I WAS FEELING STANDING UP
THERE. IT'LL ALL THOSE MUCH MORE
ACCOMPLISHED PEOPLE.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT OF
SPEAKING A MORE ACCOMPLISHED
PEOPLE OR WAS. GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE RUNS AND
THREATS TO THEM THAT THE SUBJECT
HAS BEEN COVERED MUCH BETTER
THAN I EVER COULD. BY THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT I'LL SAY A
FEW WORDS ABOUT IT THINK.
.
WE'VE DONE FOR A LONG TIME THE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE STOCK
OF THE SACRAMENTO FALL RUN
CHINOOK THAT WE DEPEND ON. FOR
MOST OF THE OCEAN FISHERIES. ARE
PRIMARILY HATCHERY STOCK. IN
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A A VERY
ASTUTE BIOLOGIST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FRANK FISHER WHO
SAID. MOST OF THE FISH SPAWNING
GRAVEL AND CAME FROM HATCHERIES
THAT'S BEEN TRUE FOR A LONG TIME
LAST YEAR WAS THE FIRST YEAR
THAT I'M AWARE OF. THAT THE
NUMBER OF FISH SPAWNING IN
GRAVEL WAS LESS THAN THE NUMBER
THAT CAME BACK TO THE
HATCHERIES.
IS NOT A GOOD SIGN.
.
OKAY.
OF THE BIG ISSUE. OTHER THAN
CLIMATE CHANGE.
OF THE BIG ISSUE IS HAVING
ENOUGH WATER OF SUITABLE QUALITY
AT THE RIGHT TIME. WE WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING THAT WAR FOR FORTY
YEARS WE ARE NOT YET OF WINNING
THAT WAR WE'VE. ALL COME BACK TO
THIS UP THAT SUBJECT LATER. OF
THERE IS A LITTLE SPOT OF GOOD
NEWS. OF JACK RETURNS AGE TO
FISH THAT CAME BACK IN BOTH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE KLAMATH
LAST YEAR. WERE ALIGNED
SUBSTANTIALLY GREATER NUMBERS
THAN THE YEAR BEFORE. ALL.
FISHERMEN AND THE GULF OF THE
FERAL LAWS LAST SUMMER FOUND
THE.
WHAT I WOULD SAY WAS A HYPER
ABUNDANCE OF AGE TO FISH? THAT
SHOULD PORTEND A GOOD YEAR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR WHICH IS THIS
YEAR HOWEVER. OF THE JACK
RETURNS DIDN'T QUITE REFLECT THE
OUT. OF HIM.
THE. SCIENTISTS WHO.
PREDICT THE SIZE OF THE RUN.
HAVE. FOR SOUND REASONS TAKEN A
VERY CONSERVATIVE APPROACH TO
PREDICTING THIS YEAR'S
ABUNDANCE.
AND.
.
ALL WE MAY NOT SEE THE BENEFITS
IN FISHERIES IN THE OCEAN OF OF
WHAT LOOKS LIKE A FAIRLY ROBUST
RUN. AND THIS IS SOMEWHAT
PERPLEXING WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
IT. TONIGHT ROHNERT PARK AND
THROUGH THE PACIFIC COUNCIL
MEETING THAT'S COMING UP. NEXT
WEEK OUR WAR BEGINS ACTUALLY OF
FRIDAY. SO WE'LL SEE WHAT. WE
CAN WORK OUT. ABOUT THAT THE
OCEAN COMMERCIAL FISHERY IS ON
ITS KNEES.
WE. WE HAD GOOD YEARS IN. TWELVE
AND THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN WE
HAVE NOT HAD. A DECENT YEAR
SINCE AND IT NOW LOOKS AS THOUGH
THIS YEAR'S SEASON. MAY BE EVEN
MORE RESTRICTED THAN LAST YEAR'S
BY. THE POOR PRODUCTION OF
SACRAMENTAL FALL CHINOOK.
.
THE LAST TWO YEARS SHOULD
QUALIFY OF THE OCEAN SALMON
FISHERY SHOULD QUALIFY FOR
DISASTER. DECLARATIONS I HOPE
THAT WON'T BE THE CASE THIS
YEAR.
OF WE'LL SEE HOW THAT TURNS OUT.
.
I GUESS I'M HOPING THAT.
FOLLOWING THE LITTLE BIT OF
OPPORTUNITY WILL HAVE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE PRODUCTIVE
THAN IT'S BEEN. THE LAST FEW
YEARS. OF WE ARE A LONG LONG
WAYS FROM THE GLORY DAYS OF THE
LATE NINETIES AND EARLY AUGHTS
WIN OF. THE QUESTION WAS HOW
FAST CAN YOU HANDLE FISH ON THE
BOAT AND TAKE CARE OF THEM TO
GET THEM CHILLED. WE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT FOR QUITE AWHILE. OF.
THREATS TO THE FUTURE OF THE
FISHERY IN ADDITION TO THE WATER
SITUATION AND OF COURSE IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE IN THE
STATE THAT WATER FLOWS UP HILL
TO MONEY. OF.
WE BELIEVE THE TWIN TUNNELS
WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC FOR SALMON
AND FOUR OTHER FISH AND WILDLIFE
ALL OF THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
THAT USE THE DELTA. AND THE BAY
YOU CANNOT RESTORE AN ESTUARY BY
DIVERTING FRESH WATER FLOWS
AROUND IT THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ITS FUNCTIONS. AND SO WE WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE THAT NOT HAPPEN
OFFSHORE DRILLING OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE SPOKEN MORE ELOQUENTLY
ABOUT IT THEN I WILL. BUT IT
WOULD BE DISASTROUS NOT JUST FOR
SALMON FISHERIES BUT FOR MOST
MARINE LIFE. AND ALL THE PEOPLE.
WHO EITHER MAKE A LIVING ON THE
OCEAN ENJOYED RECREATIONALLY OR
SIMPLY TRAVEL TO THE COAST TO
ADMIRE THE BEAUTY OF THE OCEAN
THAT?
THESE DISASTERS HAVEN'T HAPPENED
YET AND CAN BE PREVENTED.
CLIMATE CHANGE. IS A HUGE THREAT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SALMON IT'S
THE SOUTHERN END OF THE RANGE.
AND WE SEE A GENERAL TREND IN
SPECIES TO MIGRATE TO THE NORTH.
OF AS CLIMATE CHANGE OCCURS. OF
AN.
IT'S GOING TO BE A MORE INTENSE
STRUGGLE IN THE FUTURE TO
MAINTAIN. ROBUST RUNS OF SALMON
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO WHAT WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT IT.
FIRST OF ALL.
WE HAVE TO STOP TREATING WATER
AS THOUGH IT IS AN INFINITE AND
FREE. RESOURCE IS IT CLEARLY IS
NOT. WE'VE BEEN TAKING MORE
WATER FROM THE DELTA THE THAN IT
HAS TO GIVE FOR A LONG TIME IF
WE VALUE THE DELTA. AS A LIVING
AND BOUNTIFUL YES YOU ARE.
AND WE HAVE TO ONCE WE FACE THAT
REALITY YOU HAVE TO ADAPT TO IT
BY CHANGING THE WAY WE THINK
ABOUT WATER IN THE WAY WE USE
IT.
ONE THING WE COULD DO THERE IS A
TEMPLATE.
AND THAT WOULD BE THAT IS THE
MEASURES PROPOSED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER CARCASS. AND
THEIR DOCUMENT A SUSTAINABLE
WATER PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT THAT DOCUMENT
DESERVES A GOOD HARD LOOK BY
PEOPLE IN A POSITION TO MAKE.
AND CHANGE POLICY. THIRTY SIXTY
MINUTES OKAY. MENTION IF THE
MILLION MAN HOURS SPENT
ATTEMPTING TO JUSTIFY THE TWIN
TUNNELS HAD INSTEAD BEEN
DEVOTED.
TO FINDING MANY SMALL FIXES TO
THE WATER PROBLEMS THAT THREATEN
EVERYONE IN THE STATE RATHER
THAN BEING. SPENT ON ONE GREAT
DEALS PIPE DREAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PRETTYGREAT
FOR MUCH OF ITS AND WERE AT IT'S
APPRECIATE YOU ALWAYS BEING HERE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE UPDATE AS
WELL. THANK YOU SIR WE'RE NOT
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
MCMANUS PRESENT THE GOLD SEES
HIM AN ASSOCIATION. WHO HAS
BROUGHT ALONG A POWER POINT IS
WELL WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CERTAINLY
WELCOME? THANKS FOR HAVING ME
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
SENATOR REQUIRE SOME WOMEN STONE
DOLLY. GLAD YOU GUYS ARE HERE
TRONIC MAN IS PRESENT IN THE
GOLDEN GATE SALMON ASSOCIATION
THRILLED AT MY SLIDES BEEN UP
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE.
ACTUALLY WE JUST LIKE TO COMMENT
ABOUT THE DINNER LAST NIGHT FOR
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM SENATOR GORE
WAS ACTUALLY SERVING PEOPLE WITH
PLATTERS OF FOOD HE DIDN'T HAVE
TO DO THAT AND IT WAS EXTREMELY
IMPRESSIVE AND SHOWS WHAT KIND
OF GUY SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE IS
MEANT.
HAVING SAID THAT I WANT TO
THANK.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE PASSAGE OF A
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION SEVEN.
THAT WAS INCREDIBLE I WANT TO
THANK SECRETARY LAYERED FOR HIS
ROLE IN GETTING THE CODE WORD
TAG ISSUE. IRONED OUT WITH THE
FEATHER RIVER HAD TREE THIS
YEAR.
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES WILL
PAY FOR THOSE TAGS WHICH IS A
GOOD THING BIG STEP FORWARD. AND
I WANT TO ALSO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES URGING THEM TO
GET ON BOARD WITH.
THE RESTORATION OF THAT AREA IN
THE WORLD BILL WILDLIFE AREA
UNITY WITH THE SUTTER BUTTES
FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY. AFTER THAT
LETTER GREAT PROGRESS IS MADE D.
W. R. CAME AROUND AND BACKS THE
PROPOSAL NOW AND FOR THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION IS
SAYING NICE THINGS SO THEY
HAVEN'T GIVEN A FORMAL GREEN
LIGHT. BUT WE'RE MOVING IN A
GOOD DIRECTION SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
.
OFFSHORE OIL YOU KNOW WE GOT T
PULL THE FISH UP THROUGH THE
WATER INTO THE BOAT AND IF THIS
IS WHAT WE GOT TO DEAL WITH IT
pJUST ISN'T GOING TO WORK. I'M
ON
THE FLIP SIDE THIS CAME OUT OF
THE GULF OF MEXICO MEXICO FROM
THE DEEP WATER HORIZON.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WE PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE COMMERCIALLY
RECOVERABLE QUANTITIES OFF THE
NORTH COAST WHICH MAKES ME
WONDER WHY THE STRAP PLAN EVEN
CAME OUT MAYBE JUST A STICK IN
THE EYE TO CALIFORNIA. DON'T
KNOW.
STATUS OF OUR SALMON RUNS.
A BUNCH PEOPLE SPOKEN TO IT LOOK
AT THE FAR RIGHT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THIS IS THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY WE HAD UNDER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND ADULTS THAT
A THREE YEAR OLDS ADULTS ARE
RETURNED. THAT SECOND LOWEST.
BEATEN ONLY BY THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN WE WERE SHUT
DOWN ENTIRELY OUT ON THE OCEAN.
SO.
NOT A GOOD SITUATION THE RED
BAND IN THE MIDDLE POINTS TO THE
TARGET THAT THEY'RE MANAGING
FOR.
THEY WANT TO SEE BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND ADULT
SALMON COME BACK WE MISSED IT.
THE LAST THREE YEARS.
AND HERE'S A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
OTHER RUNS LATE FALL RUN AGAIN
WENT AROUND SPRING RUN. YOU'LL
NOTICE ON THE WINNER RUN WE HAD
LESS THAN A THOUSAND THAT
RETURNED THIS PAST YEAR SPRING
RUN WE HAD LESS THAN TWO
THOUSAND. SO NOT A GOOD
SITUATION AND WE'VE MISSED THE
TARGET SLASH THREE YEARS IN A
ROW. IN UNDER THE MAGNUSON
STEVENS FEDERAL FISHERIES ACT.
THAT THERE'S LANGUAGE THAT SAYS
THOU MUST DECLARE THEM OVER FISH
WE DIDN'T CONTEMPLATE THE
SITUATION WE'VE GOTTEN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY GOT
HAMMERED BECAUSE A DROUGHT AND
WATER OPERATIONS. SO THEY CALL
IT OVER FISH DEPLETED WE WOULD
ARGUE IS MORE ACCURATE IN THIS
INSTANCE. AND I UNDERSTAND THERE
IS A PROPOSAL OF THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TO AMEND THAT FEDERAL LAW
TO GET DEPLETED INCLUDED IN THE
LANGUAGE I I ONLY BRING THIS UP
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN REPORTED IN
THE PRESS. AND CREATED SOME
CONFUSION IN THE PUBLIC THIS
BUSINESS ABOUT OVER FISHED. I
WANT TO SHIFT GEARS AND MOVE TO
THE OLD BY PASS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
STATE AND THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION ABOUT ON THE HOOK.
TO GET THE FREMONT WE'RE NOTCHED
LOWERED MODIFIED IN SOME WAY
SHAPE OR FORM SO IT FLOODS WATER
INTO IT MORE OFTEN YOU REMEMBER
LAST YEAR EVERY TIME HE CAME
OVER THE CAUSEWAY. IT LOOK LIKE
LAKE MICHIGAN OUT THERE WHEN WE
SEE THAT THAT'S GOOD NEEDS FULL
OF DINKY LITTLE THREE YEAR OLD
SALEM THAT ARE GETTING FAT AND
HAPPY SO. WE REALIZE THAT
THERE'S AN ARTIFICIAL DAM AT THE
NORTH END OF IT THE FREMONT
WE'RE WHAT IF WE SHAVE THE THING
WHAT IF WE NOT*.
FINALLY IN DECEMBER.
THE.
THE RESOURCES AGENCY CAME OUT
WITH A DRAFT PLAN. GIANT STEP
FORWARD TOOK A LONG TIME TO DO
IT BUT NOW THE DRAFT IS ON THE.
IS OUT THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE DRAFT PLAN
WE FEEL LIKE THEY CHOSE THE
WRONG ALTERNATIVE.
WE COMMENTED ON IT NOW IS FOR
WHAT'S CALLED ALTERNATIVE SIX
BASICALLY IT TAKES THE BIGGEST
WHACK OUT OF THE FREMONT WE'RE
WOULD PUT THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
FISH IN THERE. AND IT'S NOT TOO
LATE FOR.
RESOURCES TO COME AROUND AND
COME OUT WITH A FINAL THE I. R.
YEAH YES.
THAT ADVOCATES FOR THIS.
SO WE MADE SOME PROGRESS IN
UNITY IN THE ORVILLE WILDLIFE
AREA BUT I'M COMING BACK TO
ORACLE JUST OR A MINUTE. THIS
THING HERE YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS
OUR BIGGEST HEADACHE UP THERE
THAT'S HOT WATER POURING. OUT OF
THE THERMAL LIDO AFTER BAY DOWN
INTO THE FEATHER RIVER BASICALLY
NEGATING SOME FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
MILES AN OTHERWISE GREAT SALMON
HABITAT. MAKING IT TOO HOT.
D. W. R. SWEARS ON A STCK OF
BIBLES THAT THEY'LL FIX THIS
PROBLEM ONCE THEY GET THEIR
LICENSE RENEWED.
AND WE WILL TAKE THEM AT THEIR
WORD BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD
THIS. IDEA AND IT'S ALL IN THE
LICENSE RENEWAL FOR GOOD OR FOR
ILL I'M NOT COMMENTING
UNDERSTAND THE LICENSES HUNG UP
SO IT'S BEEN TWELVE YEARS. SINCE
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR FIX IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO TO HELP US AT LEAST GET
DO W. OR TO MOVE ON THE THERMAL
LIDO ISSUE. THAT WOULD BE HUGE.
SO HERE'S A HAPPY PICTURE.
THIS IS UP ON THE ROGUE RIVER.
THIS IS AN ORGAN SHE MAY NOT
HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THIS BUT
WHILE THE CALIFORNIA RIVERS HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING THE ROGUES GOING
OFF THE HOOK. IT'S GOT THE
SECOND BIGGEST PRODUCTION FOR
CONTRIBUTION TO THE OCEAN AFTER
THE COLOMBIAN SNAKE RIVER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THE ENTIRE
WEST COAST. IT BEATS THE KLAMATH
IT BEATS THE SACRAMENTO BY A
FACTOR OF TWO.
YOU ASK YOURSELF WHY ON THIS
RIVER THEY TOOK OUT THREE DAMS
ON THE MAIN STEM THEY TOOK OUT A
SEVERAL ON SMALL TRIBUTARIES.
THEY'VE GOT A LITTLE POOL WATER
UP IN THE HEADWATERS OF THE
RESERVE JUST FOR SALMON. FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND THREE
YEAR OLDS SPEND A LOT OF THEM
FOURS MIXED IN THERE TOO AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE SHOT. SO WHY
CAN'T WE DO THAT IN CALIFORNIA
IN FACT WERE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THIS WHEN THE KLAMATH DAMS
COME OUT. AND MAYBE WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT A FUTURE LIKE THIS.
I WANT TO SWITCH IT AND TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE. FOR BRIEF
MOMENTS AND THAT IS WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME PRETTY STIFF
FEDERAL THREATS TO OUR WATER
SUPPLY AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THIS YEAR.
WITHOUT GOING INTO GREAT DETAIL
UNDER THE OF SO CALLED WIN ACT
THE FEDS HAVE TRIED TO PUMP IN
EXCESS OF WHAT'S ALLOWED. US
SEVERAL TIMES TO THE WINNER AND
UP THE STATE HAS NOT. GIVEN
THEIR PERMISSION. AND BASICALLY
NOT PLAYED BALL THE OTHER THING
IS THAT THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION CAME OUT WITH THE
WATER ALLOCATION PLAN IN
FEBRUARY. THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE WROTE A LETTER
SAYING WE CAN'T GO WITH IT IS
GOING TO WIPE OUT WHEN A RUN. TO
THE POINT I'M GETTING T IS WE
NEED SP FORTY NINE TO BE PASSED
WE NEED SOME STATE BASED
PROTECTIONS. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
UP FEDERAL ACTIONS ARE A MAJOR
THREAT TO US.
ABOUT A MINUTE OKAY.
ONE LAST THING ALL VISIT ON AND
THAT IS THE SO THE WATER
COMMISSION AND THE PROP ONE
FUNDING.
FROM WHAT WE CAN TELL THEM WE'VE
LOOKED INTO IT. THE WATER
COMMISSION STAFF DOING A GOOD
JOB. OF LOOKING AT APPLICATIONS
THAT COME BEFORE IT FOR NEW DAMS
AND STORAGE PROJECTS THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO HAVE PUBLIC
BENEFITS.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEY CAN'T BE
FUNDED UNDER PROP ONE THERE ARE
SOME WHO NEVER READ THE LANGUAGE
AND WHO WOULD LIKE TO RE WRITE%
IT NOW. BUT THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE
LANGUAGE IT WAS PASSED BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
WATER COMMISSION IN THE GOOD JOB
THAT THEY'RE DOING SO FAR. IN
REVIEWING THESE PROP ONE
APPLICATIONS AND I'LL STOP
THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS INVESTED IN
A NICE JOB AS USUAL VERY
GRATEFUL LET'S SEE. TO THE
COMMITTEE MISTER LEADER.
JOHN THE AS YOU KNOW THAT. I
WENT OVER THE WATER COMMISSION
WITH FOUR THOUSAND TITIAN'S. AND
I'M AM I MEAN I'M JUST SIMPLE
HERE.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M A FARMER AND I
MORE WATER IS BETTER. WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT MORE WATER.
SO I SUPPORT THE WATER BORNE MY
WHOLE DISTRICT VOTED AGAINST THE
WATER BODIES I BELIEVE IS GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW SITES RESOURCED
OFF. SOLID DAM ON THE ON THE
RIVER IT'S WATERED AS CAN BE
STORED OFF SITE TO AL ACTUALLY
HELPS THE THERMAL LEGAL PROCESS
WHERE YOU'RE PUTTING WARM WATER
IN THERE SO. YOU KNOW FOR THE
LIFE OF ME I CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY.
THE RANKINGS WERE VERY GOOD TO
COME TO THE WATER SO I WENT OVER
THERE AND YOU KNOW SAID LOOK WE
WE NEED TO HAVE A PROCESS HERE
THAT.
WAS TRANSPARENT WHAT WE REALLY
SOLD THE VOTERS WAS WE WERE
GOING TO CREATE MORE WATER.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT OUT SOLEMN
AND AND YES THERE IS. LANGUAGE
IN THERE THAT.
IT SAYS HAS TO BE PUBLIC
BENEFITS SO. I'M HOPING THAT AT
SOME POINT. WHEN THE THE ALL
JUST GET DONE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN CREATE
MORE WATER BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
DID IT IN SCENARIOS WHERE WE
HAVE. CLIMATE CHANGE WHERE WE'RE
GETTING. LESS SNOW WHICH IS THE
BIGGEST RESERVOIR WE HAD. IN THE
WHOLE SIERRA'S.
.
AND MORE RAIN DOWN THERE THAT WE
CAN CAPTURE SOME OF THAT AND
HELP TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THE
DELTA PROBLEMS AND IN THE
FISHERIES. GONNA COMMENT ON THAT
YEAH. I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD
AGREE IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE HAD
LAST YEAR RAINFALL THERE WAS ONE
OF THE COULD HAVE BEEN.
CAPTURED.
BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT YOU TO
THE COMMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN FISH AND WILDLIFE ROAD ON
SITES WHICH WERE AN EYE OPENER.
BASICALLY IN A NUTSHELL THEY SAY
YOU CAN OPERATE IT BUT IF YOU
ALLOW THE FLOWS NEED FOR SAM AND
YOU WILL BE DIVERTING FAR FEWER
THE DAYS AND MONTHS AND EVEN
WATERTIGHT PEERS. THAN YOU THINK
SO WITHOUT GOING INTO THAT I
WOULD JUST POINT TO THAT.
COMMENT LETTER BACK IT WAS A
REAL EYE OPENER FOR US.
PLEASE THIS ONE LAST COMMENT AS.
MAYBE TOO MUCH COMMON SENSE%
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW OR SOME IT IS
VERY SIMPLE AND AND NOT EDUCATED
ENOUGH AND MAYBE.
.
YEAH WE HAVE WE SOLD THE PUBLIC
ON A LOT OF BONDS AND IN
PROJECTS THAT. NEVER COME TO
FRUITION THAT THAT. THAT DON'T.
SOLVE WHAT WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO
SOLVE.
AND I THINK AT SOME POINT WE ARE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. BUT WE'RE LOSING PUBLIC
TRUST REALLY FAST AS LEGISLATIVE
BODY BEEN IN WHO GET CAUGHT UP
IN COURTS AND ALL KINDS OF
THINGS WE DON'T PRODUCE WHAT WE
SAY WE'RE GOING TO PRODUCE. AND
I THINK AT SOME POINT WE'VE
WE'VE RUN A RISK THAT THE PEOPLE
ON THE FACE OF THIS ANYMORE WE
DON'T WE'RE NOT ABLE TO ASK THEM
FOR THE RESOURCES TO GET THE JOB
DONE WHEN YOU GET DOWN.
NO THANK YOU MR LEADER AND NEVER
SIMPLE IT WHATSOEVER AND JUST
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE AND
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE REST HERE
WELL AND AND THAT'S WHY WE ALSO
OUGHT TO FOCUS ON WATERSHEDS
BECAUSE AS WATER AS SNOW. THE
BLUE SNOW PACKED WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE THAT WATER COMING
DOWN TO THE SIERRAS AND. THAT
THE ISSUE ABOUT SOME THE TUNNELS
AND IN THE HYDROLOGY THROUGH TE
DELTA. AS WE MOVE WATER MORE
QUICKLY THROUGH THE DELTA WHICH
IS PART OF THE PLAN WE ALSO
PULLED OUT OF THE SEARS FASTER
WHICH RAISES THE TEMPERATURE THE
WATER WHICH IS DETRIMENTAL TO
THE FISH SO THAT. THE AND A LOT
OF THE THE FOLKS WERE LOOKING AT
THE HYDROLOGY THE DELTA REALLY
ARE NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
UPPER WATERSHEDS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WEEK WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IT. IS THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S A REMARKABLE PICTURE AND
SEE WHAT CAN RECOVER IF WE ARE
WILLING. TO RETHINK HOW WE
MANAGE WATERSHEDS AND HOW WE
MANAGE THE SYSTEMS THAT THAT
ALLOW THE FISH TO COME BACK INTO
AND AS WE DEAL WITH THE. EFFECTS
OF CHANGING.
WATER PATTERNS TO THE STATE
WHERE IT'S WARMER COMING AT
DIFFERENT TIMES IN MANAGING
THOSE FLOWS IT'S A VERY LARGE
COMPREHENSIVE. ISSUE THAT NOT.
EVERYBODY'S WORKING TOWARDS THE
SAME ULTIMATE GOAL AND THAT'S
WHERE WE GET. THE.
YEAH THE TUNNELS IN THE DELTA
WITHOUT LOOKING AT OTHER ASPECTS
OF IT AND THAT'S REALLY
DETRIMENTAL TO WHAT WE'RE
ULTIMATELY TRYING TO LOOK AT
BECAUSE THESE ARE ENTIRE
SYSTEMS.
THAT WE TEND TO KIND OF
PIECEMEAL OUT AS WE DO PLANNING
AND AND LOOK FOR THEMSELVES.
JUST THE SUCCESS OF THE ROGUE
HOPEFULLY THE KLAMATH. OTHER
SYSTEMS.
AS WE MANAGE ALL OF THAT WATER I
THINK WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER SHOT
OF MEETING. MULTIPLE NEEDS THAT
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE
FISHERIES AS WELL AS WE DO. IS
WE REALLY DO RESTORATION TO TRY
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE THAT WE
HAVE CONFERENCES SOLUTIONS.
I. THINK IN THE COMMENTS BACK TO
THE VICE CHAIR THAT ONE.
IT'S GOOD TO LEADER DOLLY JUST
ONE LAST COMMENT. AS YOU MANY
KNOW THE NOTE DEMI LEGISLATORS
THAT I WORKED ON FORESTRY ISSUES
FROM DAY ONE THAT I CAME HERE
AND YOU KNOW THE REAL. THE REAL.
HEADWATERS ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
WHERE WE HAVE A FORCE THAT IS.
OVERGROWN OVERSTOCKED.
DUE TO OUR SUPPRESSION OF FIRE
FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS.
AT THE PACE IS GOING TO DO PUT
OUR MEADOWS IN OUR IN OUR FORCED
BACK INTO SHAPE SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY STORE HAVE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION NUMBER ONE. NUMBER
TWO STOP APPLE TRANSPIRATION
PROMOTIONAL.
BLOWN AWAY IN THE WIND AND
ACTUALLY GET INTO THE GROUND AND
IT OFFERS WERE COMES ON THE
SPRINGS AND IT'S COLD AT THE
RIGHT TIME YEAR. WE NEED TO MOVE
AT A PACE HILL THERE TO.
AND THE RESOURCES TO DO THAT OR
ARE NOT THE AVAILABLE TODAY AND
WE'RE SEEIN MAGNIFIERS NOW.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S LIKE THIRTY
SOME BILLS RENTED THIS
LEGISLATOR TO DEAL WITH FIRE.
THAT BUT WE DID IT TAKE A GOOD
CLOSE LOOK AT OUR WATERSHEDS IN
AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MANAGE
THEM IN A WAY THAT WE DON'T FARM
UP. SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
STORE CARBON AND AND WATER TO
SAVE TIME.
ABSOLUTELY. CANDIDLY IT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE LOOK AT AT
STORAGE. AND WE HAVE SIXTY
PERCENT OF OUR WATER SUPPLY IN
THIS STATE.
THAT COME FROM SO BACK IN AS WE
SEE. FEWER AND FEWER SNOW DAYS
AND.
LYNCH CONDITIONS IN THIS YEAR
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE TO COME
UP WITH A NEW WAY TO BE A STORE
THIS WATER. THAT WILL NO LONGER
COME FROM SNOW MELT. IN IT'S
GONNA HAVE TO BRING IT TO WORK
WITH SENSIBLE CUTS SOLUTIONS HAS
GOT TO WORK BOTH FOR. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FRONT. OBVIOUSLY
AT PROTECTING FISH WITHIN ALSO
ARE A CON ME AS WELL SO DO
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND WANT TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER
MASSA GEORGE OPEN YOU SEEM TO BE
PRIMED UP YOU KNOW I WAS JUST
THINKING WHEN ASSEMBLYMAN STONE
WAS SPEAKING HE WAS COMMENTING
ON THE PHOTO.
THOSE FISH ACTUALLY OFFICIAL
FEEL WHOLE LOT OF MEMBERS OF
YOUR FAMILY YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
AND.
THEY'RE JUST A TREMENDOUS WAY
TO CREATE COMMUNITY SO.
TO US THE REALLY IMPORTANT WE
WANT TO KEEP THEM IN THE
PICTURE.
HAVE ABSOLUTELY YEAH. FANTASTIC.
WHAT DOES HE THINK YOU TO MR
BUSINESS MASS FOR YOUR CONTINUED
HAVING SEEN YOUR HARD WORK? HERE
ACROSS THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO
HELP. SALMON FISHERY AND ON ALL
WATERSHED RESTORATION PROJECTS.
SAID THANK YOU TO THE DOCTOR FOR
THE FANTASTIC STUDY WE'D LIKE
YOU TO KEEP US UPDATED IF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU. IN HIS YOU ARE
SEEN NEW DEVELOPMENTS WE LOVE IT
TO BE THAT LEAD TO BEING
COMMUNICATION AS WELL. SO
GENTLEMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA TURN THIS PANEL AND
SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO BE
PROVIDED STATE I'VE SEEN
FISHERIES HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA.
TAKE A TEN MINUTE PLAN BREAK.
GO GRAB A CUP OF JOE HIT THE
RESTROOM ON AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK TALK ABOUT CRAP IN
DISASTER RELIEF WE'RE GONNA GET
A UPDATE ON OUR CULTURE AND
STARTING INDUSTRY WE'RE GONNA
HEAR ALL ABOUT SEE YOUR CHIN
HELD BUT INCREDIBLY RETRIEVAL.
AND THEN WE HAVE OUR FISHERY
COMMITTEE REPORTS WE'LL SEE HERE
IN JUST ABOUT TEN MINUTES AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING OUT
TODAY
OKAY ALRIGHT LET'S SEE JENNIFER
GONNA BE GETTING GOING IN ABOUT
A MINUTE SO FAVORITE CONCERT
TAKING YOUR SEATS. WE WELCOME
YOU BACK THANK YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US. AS SOON AS FOLKS ARE
ABLE TO GATHER RUNNING GET RIGHT
BACK INTO OUR HEARINGS. IN THE
MEANTIME WE'RE GONNA HAVE NO
OPPENHEIM IN LORI FRENCH IF THEY
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AND BE
SEATED AT THE TABLE WILL GET
GOING HERE IN ABOUT A MINUTE BUT
IF WE COULD PLEASE HAVE MS
FRENCH IN MR OPPENHEIM. PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND TO PREPARE FOR
THE TESTIMONY AND WHAT A REMIND
YOU WEAVE A LOT OF CHOCOLATE
HERE TODAY. HAZY THERE AGO WE
HEARD YOU TO HIT IT OUT SO I
COULD SEE YEAH. I LIKE TO SEIZE
THE DAY SEE THERE YOU GO.
I LIKE IT WILL GET GOING HERE
MOMENTARILY.
I MEAN THE.
YEAH. YEAH.
I MEAN THE CHRISTMAS YOU WANT TO
START WITH. THE POSSIBLE.
SO YOUR HOUSE AS A.
AND THEN YOU ARE
.
WE'RE GONNA BE COMING BACK
TOGETHER AND THANK YOU ALL FOR.
TAKING THE TIME TO COME ON BACK
UP WE'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
RIGHT INTO IT HONOR CRABBING
DISASTER RELIEF UPDATES WERE
GONNA FIRST HERE FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE PACIFIC
COAST ADORATION FISHERMAN'S
ASSOCIATION. NO OPPENHEIM AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM A
FELLOW LOVER A SEES CANDY.
LORI FRENCH PRESIDENT A CENTER
BECAUSE WOMEN FOR FISHERIES.
LAURIE AND I WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT WHAT OUR FAVORITE NIGHT OR
CHEW WAS.
IN LORI WHAT WAS IT WHAT'S YOUR
FAVORITE.
FOR YOUR BRUTAL. MILK CHOCOLATE
COVERED. LIKE THE ONE THAT NO
ONE LIKES I LIKE THE ONE WITH
THE CHERRY IN IT IT'S THE NIGHT
AND SHE WITH THE CHAIR YOU KNOW
BUT NO ONE LIKES A LIE SO WOULD
TALK TO THAT THIS MORNING. HAZY
THERE WE GO IT'S ALSO THE
HEAVIEST SO I LIKE THAT.
THEY THEY IT'S ALMOST INSTANTLY
OKAY WE'RE GONNA KEEP ON MOVIN
AT BEFORE I SO SEEN MY GRANDMA
WAS EIGHTY AT NIGHT INTO FANATIC
SO IT IS.
PASSED ON THE TRAIT I TRADITION.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER TO WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
OPPENHEIMER'S EXACT ADDRESS OF
THE PACIFIC COAST AT IT
FEDERATION FISHERMAN'S
ASSOCIATION WE'VE HAD SOME ROUGH
GOING.
WITH THE COMPANY CRAB INDUSTRY.
AND OUT WHAT AGAIN WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO KNOW WHAT AND THE
ENTIRE BOARD.
THE FEDERATION FISHERMEN.
FOR ALL YOUR WORK IN WORKING IN
A DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCE THERE IN DC AS HAVE
TO BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO
BETTER SUPPORT OUR FISHERY NO
AND TURN OVER TO YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
RUSSIAN AND THANK YOU FOR
STICKING AROUND. I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
IT'S DELIGHTFUL TO BE HAPPIER
WITH LAURIE ONCE AGAIN.
PROVIDING A CRAB UPDATE ON LAST
YEAR IT WAS A SOMBER TONE WITH
NOT MUCH IN THE WAY OF GOOD NEWS
TO SHARE THIS YEAR.
I'M PLEASED AND DELIGHTED TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE THE GOOD NEWS THAT
MANY INDIANS YOU'RE ALREADY
AWARE OF. NAMELY THE THE
SUCCESSFUL.
EFFORT TO SECURE FISHERY
DISASTER APPROPRIATIONS IN THE
US CONGRESS. I'M GONNA TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER THE TIME
LINE OF HOW WE GOT HERE AND WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT IN THE FUTURE FOR
THREE REASONS ONE BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S HELPFUL. TO.
SHARE THAT INFORMATION AND
REGENERATED. AND I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS PLATFORM TO
SHARE THIS MESSAGE WITH THOSE
WHO ARE HERE AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING.
OR WHO WILL BE WATCHING. THE
OTHER REASON IS THAT. THERE'S A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONVEYED THAT THE WORK IS NOT
DONE.
AND WHILE ONE FISHERY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN TAKING CARE
OF THEIR MANY MORE THAT. HAVE
NOT BEEN AND THOSE WHO WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE. TO GIVE IT
ALL THAT WE'VE GOT. AND THE
THIRD REASON IS BECAUSE
DESCRIBING THIS LABORIOUS
PROCESS WHICH TOOK YEARS I HOPE
MAKES IT VERY CLEAR THAT THE
PROCESS IS BROKEN. AND THAT
SOMETHING ELSE NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND WE HAVE SOME IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE. SO
BACK IN THE FALL OF TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN
YOU CENTER OF OUR HELD A PUBLIC
HEARING.
REALLY MEETING.
WITH FISHERMEN AND APARTMENT OF
SUCH WHILE LIFE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TALKING ABOUT WHAT WAS
VERY CLEARLY AN IMPENDING.
DISASTER THE ELEVATED LEVELS OF
DEMO CAST IN THE CRIME.
IN THE CRAB FISHERY.
FAST FORWARD TO THE SPRING OF
THAT YOU
AND THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
SENDING A LETTER TO SECRETARY
OF COMMERCE THAN PENNY PRITZKER.
REQUESTING A FEDERAL FISHERIES
ESTHER DECLARATION. OF THE
SEASON WRAPPED UP.
WAS CLEARLY A DISASTER WITH THE
WITH IMPACT SPREADING THROUGHOUT
THE FLEET IN INTO OTHER SECTORS.
THEN OF COURSE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP AND LOSS.
KELLY FELT BY SMALL THOSE
FISHERMEN AND YOUNG THE NEW
ENTRANCE OF THE CENTURY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ENABLED
ACCESS TO SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION LOANS WHICH ARE
HELPFUL BUT THEY WERE THEY WERE
NOTHING BUT A A LIFELINE AND NOT
A PERMANENT SOLUTION. MANY TOOK
ADVANTAGE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THREE DAYS BEFORE THE END OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SECRETARY
PRITZKER DECLARED A FEDERAL
FISHERY DISASTER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DUNGEON ISN'T ROCK
CRAB SURGERIES. ON THIS ENABLES
CONGRESS 
OCEANIC AND ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION TO. DISTRIBUTE
FUNDS IF THEY'RE APPROPRIATE.
WE. WE TOOK UNTIL AUGUST OF
TWENTY S. SEVENTEEN BEFORE THE
HOUSE. COMMERCE APPROPRIATIONS
SUBCOMMITTEE APPROPRIATED ARE
INCLUDED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE REGULAR ORDER APPROACH
STILL.
THAT WAS SOMETHING BUT CLEARLY
NOT ENOUGH ON THOSE BEFORE ALL
WEST COAST FISHERIES. AND WE HAD
OUR HURRICANES STRIKES THE
CARIBBEAN AND GULF COASTS.
INTACT THE FISHERIES THERE.
FINALLY AFTER LONG DISCUSSIONS
WITH OUR FRIENDS IN THE SENATE.
AND AND IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT.
THAT THIS WAS A BIPARTISAN
MULTISTATE EFFORTS WITH
SENATORS.
THE ENTIRE DELEGATES SENT A
DELEGATION FROM ALASKA
WASHINGTON OREGON CALIFORNIA
COMING TOGETHER. TO KEEP THE THE
NOISE UP AND ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KNEW
THAT THIS WAS A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THEM. ON FEBRUARY EIGHTH
SECRETARY. OF COMMERCE ROSS.
DECLARED THREE FEDERAL FISHERY
DISASTERS IN THE CARIBBEAN IN
THE US VIRGIN ISLANDS PUERTO
RICO IN FLORIDA ON FEBRUARY
NINTH. THE SENATE PASSED THE
BIPARTISAN BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
WEST COAST FISHERY DISASTER'S
DECLARED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THE THREE HURRICANE DISASTERS.
THAT.
THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
AUTHORIZED THEY NEED TO BE
APPROPRIATED IN THE OMNIBUS
BUDGET DEAL WHICH IS DUE OUT
MARCH TWENTY THIRD. ONCE THAT
HAPPENS.
THERE WILL BE A FORTY FIVE DAY
CLOCKS THAT BEGINS THAT NOTION
NATIONAL OCEANIC AND ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION WHERE THEY WILL
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SLICE OF THE
PIE.
BY ALL INDICATIONS THE AGENCY
IS GOING TO DIVIDE IT UP.
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TOM. USING EXTRA SO LANDINGS
VALUE AS THE BENCHMARK ESTIMATE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE. TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS SLICE TWELVE
WAYS. IS GOINGTO PRODUCE FAR
LESS THAN WHAT WAS ACTUALLY LOST
BUT IN THIS CONGRESSIONAL
CLIMATE.
WITH WITH BUDGETS BEING THE WAY
THAT THEY ARE AN APPROPRIATIONS
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO SECURE. ON
THIS IS GOING TO GO A LONG WAY I
ESTIMATE THAT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
THIRTY AND FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS GOING TO END UP COMING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TENNIS CROWD
SURGERIES.
ONCE THAT HAPPENS THAT MONEY
WILL BE APPROPRIATED TO THE
PACIFIC STATES MARINE FISHERIES
COMMISSION. WHICH WILL HANDLE OF
CREATING WHAT'S CALLED THE
DISTRIBUTION ALGORITHM WHICH
WILL DETERMINE THE IN THE WAY
THAT. ECONOMIC LOSS WILL BE
DETERMINED AND HOW INDIVIDUAL
SESSION WITH AND OTHER. INDUSTRY
OPERATORS.
INCLUDING.
SEVERAL DIFFERENT SECTORS OF
OUR ECONOMY WILL BE PAID OUT BY
THESE DISASTER FUNDS.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE SEVERAL REQUESTED BUT
UNDECLARED FISHER DISASTERS FROM
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE STILL
PENDING. PARTICULARLY NOTEWORTHY
ARE THE SEARCH FOR DISASTERS
FROM OREGON WASHINGTON AND THE
SALMON FISHERIES. THE.
YOUR CHIN FISHERY IN CALIFORNIA
THE STARTING PITCHER IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I BELIEVE.
THAT MY CALLING TO HIM DAVID
GOLDBERG WAS SPEAKING ABOUT THAT
A LITTLE LATER ON SO I WON'T
STEAL ITS THUNDER. BUT SUFFICE
IT TO SAY THAT THE JOB IS NOT
DONE.
THERE ARE THERE STILL PAIN AND
HARDSHIP AN ECONOMIC LOSS THAN
THE SPEEDING CARAVAN WE ARE. SO
GRATEFUL FOR OUR FRIENDS IN DC.
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS THANK YOU.
FOR FOR TAKING CARE OF THIS
FLEET TIME WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE.
HOUSES WANT TO POINT OUT THAT IT
TOOK ME SO. YOU KNOW WHAT ALL OF
FIVE MINUTES JUST TO DESCRIBE
HOW IT. HOW LONG IT HOW WE GOT
HERE IT SHOULD TAKE THIRTY
SECONDS BECAUSE THIS SHOULD BE
AN AUTOMATIC PROCESS AN
AUTOMATIC FUNCTION OF OUR
FEDERAL AGENCIES AN
APPROPRIATION SHOULD BE
AUTOMATIC? SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CREATING ACTUARIAL SOLUTIONS
FISHERY INSURANCE BASED
SOLUTIONS. PERHAPS SOME SORT OF
PILOT PROGRAM WITH THE PUB
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS.
SOMETHING LIKE CROP INSURANCE
WHICH IS A WELL ESTABLISHED.
PROGRAM SO WE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT BECAUSE THE
JOB IS NOT DONE BUT THANK YOU
FOR GETTING US THIS FAR.
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIX ACRE TRACT OF GREAT FOR
HERE THIS TURNED OVER TO MISS
FRENCH PRESIDENT THE CENTRAL
COAST WOMEN FOR FISHERIES MISS
FRENCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MAKING THE TREK NORTH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO SEE YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES TO FOUR SOURCE I BROKE A
SPEED RECORD GETTING HER TO HUNT
CAN PROSPER.
I DID NOT SAY THAT OUT LOUD.
OKAY TODAY I'M HERE.
AS A VOICE OF CRABBERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE SO I'M GONNA BE
REFERRING TO MY NOTES BECAUSE
I'M USING THEIR WORDS. TODAY THE
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN ARE WORKING
HARD ON WILL AND TANGLES RIGHT
NOW DOWN OUR EFFORTS ARE SEEING
GOOD RESULTS. BUT THE CENTER OF
BIODIVERSITY IS USING RECORDS
FROM THE SEASONS OF FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN. AS
STANDARDS.
OF FOR WELL ENTERTAINMENT WHEN
WE ALL KNOW THAT THOSE SEASONS
WERE NOT THE NORM.
AND THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO HEAR
THIS THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT
THOSE SEASONS WERE NOT THE NORM.
WE WERE CLOSED.
WE WENT FISHING ON APRIL FIRST
THAT'S JUST WRONG.
GRABBERS ANOTHER COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN ARE NOT OUT TO
UNTANGLE WELLS CONTRARY TO WHAT
IS BEING REPORTED IN THE MEDIA.
WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR A. BAD EVERY
POTENTIAL AVENUE USING THE
BRACKET BEST PACK. I CAN TALK
TODAY. USING THE BEST PRACTICES
GUIDE WITH SHORTER TRAILER BOOZE
POT RECOVERING.
CUP RECOVERY AND REMOVING AS
MANY OF THEIR GOAL LINES AS
POSSIBLE FROM THE OCEAN WE'VE
BEEN USING THESE METHODS PRO
ACTIVELY FISHING WHERE THE WELLS
AREN'T. SO FAR THEIR SEASON
THERE ARE SO FAR THIS SEASON
THERE HAS BEEN NO REPORTED WELL
ENTANGLEMENTS ARM. THAT SHOWING
THAT ARE PRO ACTIVITIES IS
PAYING OFF. WE URGE PEOPLE TO
REMEMBER THAT CONFIRMED
ENTANGLEMENTS ARE NOT THE SAME
AS REPORTED IN TANK ONCE. EACH
PORT IS GOING OUT OF THEIR WAY
WITH NO REIMBURSEMENT TO PICK UP
ANY LOSS GEAR IT'S A GENTLEMAN'S
AGREEMENT THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS.
TO CALL YOUR NEIGHBOR BOW AND
SAY HEY I FOUND YOUR GEAR SUCH
AND SUCH I LEFT IT AT SUCH AND
SUCH TALK.
WE DIDN'T NEED PEOPLE TO TELL
US AS WE DID THIS OURSELVES BUT
AGAIN IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO ITS PRO ACTIVE.
WE DO NEED A NEW WILSON SAYS
THERE'S ABOUT EIGHT PERCENT
POPULATION INCREASE PER YEAR.
CURRENTLY MY OLDEST SON IS
USING HIS WELL WATCHING VIDEOS.
FOR. GATHERING DATES.
GIRLS LIKE IT OKAY.
WE CAN'T GO BACK AND. CHANGE
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN THE
PAST BUT WE CAN GO AHEAD AND FOR
TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN AND WE COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN ARE COMMITTED TO THAT.
TRYING TO REDUCE THE WELL
ENTANGLEMENTS.
NEXT WE MOVE ON TO DO MORE GAS
AT THE UGLY LITTLE BEAST.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE WE NEED
REALISTIC NUMBERS. GOING OFF A
REALLY OLD OLD DATA FROM THE
EIGHTIES IS JUST WRONG.
SPORT FISHERMEN THAT WERE
ALLOWED TO FINISH WHEN WE WERE
CLOSED. DUE TO HIGH TO MORE GAS
IN NUMBERS THERE WERE NO
REPORTED ILLNESSES.
.
SAFETY IS OUR FIRST CONCERN AND
WE FISHERMEN WERE GROUND ZERO.
ARE THE HEALTH.
AND CONCERN FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
OF FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN AS YOU
KNOW WAS CLOSED THAT SEASON IS
STILL HAUNTING US. MEDIA MANAGES
TO TROT OUT THE DEMOC ACID
ISSUE.
IN PRETTY MUCH EVERY ARTICLE.
ON THE OPENING A CRAB SEASON
BUT IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN OUR AND
TEASING TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEASON WAS CLOSED DUE TO
MORE GAS IT AND THEN THEY GO ON
AND ON. WITHOUT IT'S LIKE.
NO STOPPED OUT. VALID TWO'S
BEEN.
EFFECTING OUR CRAB PRICE.
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. AND
WE DO WANT TO ASK THAT SOME OF
THE DISASTER FUNDING GO FOR
RESEARCH AND TESTING AND NOT NEW
BUILDINGS.
DOWN THE CRAB DISASTER FOUND.
A BIG BIG BIG HEART FELT THANK
YOU FROM THE CROWD FLEET. UP
AGAIN MANY FAMILIES WERE.
IMPACTED HEAVILY BY THIS OF. I
HAVE A THIRTY YEAR OLD SON OUR
DECK CANDU STILL LIVING AT HOME.
THAT HE MOVED HOME DURING THE
CLUB CRACKLE JOURNEYS STILL
THERE.
.
WE NEED TO GET OUR YOUNG GUYS.
SOME FINANCIAL STABILITY SOME
THESE YOUNG GUYS WENT OUT GOT
SBA LOANS.
OR THEY MADE THAT YEAR WAS THERE
GO TO YEAR TO GET INTO THE
INDUSTRY AND THEY'RE HURTING WE
NEED TO PROTECT THEM THEY ARE
OUR FUTURE.
I OWNED.
GENERAL OFTEN COMMENTS ON THE.
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
OBEY LOST ITS LAST OF PROCESSING
FACILITY. ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO.
THERE'S NO PLACE TO CUT FISH.
THAT I KNOW OF COMMERCIALLY FROM
MORAL BAY I DON'T KNOW IF SANTA
BARBARA HAS ANY BUT THERE'S
NOTHING NORTH THERE'S NOTHING
SOUTH WE HAVE ONE ICE PLANT.
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT WORK WE HAVE
ONE FUEL DOCK THAT. BLESSES
HART.
.
BECAUSE THE COAST GUARD IN
FISHING GAME IS HIS MAJOR
CLIENTS.
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD THAT WE
WOULD HAVE ONE SMALL MARINE
STORE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP
OPEN.
BECAUSE WE WANT YOU WHEN YOU
NEED A LITTLE PART BUT OUR LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE IS GONE.
JOHN.
THE TOURISTS COME TO TOWN TO SEE
THE COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN WILL
PRETTY SUGARS THERE.
SOON THERE'S NOT GONNA BE ANY
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN WERE NOT
JUST PRETTY BOATS WHERE OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
IN TOWNS AND IN THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE LOOKING OUT FOR OUR
YOUNGER GENERATION.
AND WE.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO US.
THE COMMERCIAL GUYS THAT ARE OUT
FISHING.
AS I SAID I'M THEIR VOICE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINK MISS
FRENCH WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
VICE CHAIR IF HE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HAVE DESPICABLE ITEMS. MAKING
SURE THAT.
ALL THE FISHERMEN THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH OUR PURSUIT PRODUCE
PAINLESS FISH AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS PARTICULAR
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROUGH THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSION.
HAS A STRANGE ANY OF YOUR.
FISHERMEN BEEN PARTICIPATING IN
THAT BEING A PROVIDE FEEDBACK
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT YOU JUST
MENTION IS THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS IMPACTING THE
FLEET.
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT.
THE ONE IN ATASCADERO CAME UP
AND WHEN I WAS TAKING CARE OF MY
MOTHER LONG.
SO I DIDN'T GET TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT ONE.
I WAS PLANNING ON CONTACTING
THEM THAT'S GREAT BEYOND GIVING
HIM JUST. A LITTLE BIT MORE
INSIDE.
I DON'T HAVE HIS I WAS HEARTENED
TO HEAR THAT. THEY'RE HEARING US
AND YOU'RE SEEING IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THE OTHER ITEM THAT I
NEED TO ENSURE IS THAT THAT
WHILE IT IS FANTASTIC NEWS THAT
A FISH WILDLIFE HAS THE FUNDING.
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE RECEIVING
AND THEY RECEIVED FUNDING LAST
YEAR FOR THEIR SIGHTED TOMORROW
CASSIE TESTING WITH US AND YOU
CONTINUE TO FUND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. RIGHT AND IN
THAT.
THAT WAS A CHALLENGE THAT WE HAD
LAST YEAR.
THAT FISH WILDLIFE WAS FUNDED
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WAS
NOT.
KNOW THAT THINGS MAY BE
CHANGING THIS YEAR HERE BUT I
THINK THAT'S THE OTHER. BIG
ENEMY FOCUSES THOSE TWO ARE
ATTACHED AT THE HIP. AND
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR TEAMS WORKERS
ARE DOING ON A SHOESTRING AND BY
THE WAY THANK YOU TO THE. TWO
CRABBERS WHO GO OUT AND ACTUALLY
COLLECT THE TEST TRAPS AND BRING
HIM BACK IN. THINK THAT'S THE
OTHER PIECES THAT MAKE SURE THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
FULLY FUNDED. FOR FUN GOING
TEST.
IS THIS WHEN I TELL YOU NOW THAT
THE CROWD THAT YOU HAD LAST
NIGHT WAS FOUR HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION TO MORE GAS IT HEY I
DID.
NO SAID I COULD SEE THAT.
IT WAS.
WE USE A WHISTLE.
DOES THAT WORK OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES.
AS WHEN IT WAS GOING OFF THE
STOMACH.
BUT YOU FORGET YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY THE CRAFT WAS
IT WASN'T HARD WAS NOW IT'S YEAH
IT'S GREAT.
EVERYBODY'S GOOD EVERYBODY'S
GOOD HERE.
BUT I THINK THAT ON THAT DAY DPH
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE FUNDED AS WELL AND IT
HAS BEEN THAT. THE CONCERNS. OF
SO THEY HAVE.
SO TO SAY THANK YOU CAN BOTH YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR CLOSING COMES EFFECT.
VANCE.
DOES NOT OVER.
OTHER FISHERIES ARE CONTINUING
TO HURT.
EVERYBODY. THINKS SO MUCH IN MY
CLOSING COMMENTS AS LIFE AGAIN.
WE NEED TO LOOK OUT FOR OUR
YOUNG GUYS AND THE GUYS WHO JUST
GONE INTO THE FISHERY.
ABSOLUTELY.
FRENCH THINK YOUSO MUCH IT'S
ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU YOU
DO A FABULOUS JOB SHOP AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH INTO IT THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK QUICKLY YOU'RE
HERE.
WHATEVER WE MOVING ON TO OUR
AQUA CULTURE INSERTING INDUSTRY
PANELS ARE TO BE HERE TO GIVE US
A STATE OF THE INDUSTRY. SO ROB
ROSS WHO WOULD TYPICALLY BE
GIVING OUR OPTICAL TO REPORT. IS
UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY SO WE
HAVE AI DAVID GOLDBERG FROM THE
CAMERA CONFERENCE AND COUNCIL
AND SEE YOUR CHIN MISSION IS
GONNA BE.
PROVIDING UPDATE WITH TONY SURE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
ASSOCIATION IS ALSO HERE WITH
US.
AND THE MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND
FROM HUMBLE COUNTY WE HAVE GREAT
DEALS FROM COAST SEAFOOD WE'RE
GONNA BE GETTING AN UPDATE ON
ALL ISSUES RELATED TO.
.
AQUA CULTURE IN SARDINIA WE'VE
HEARD.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES REGARDS
IS STARTING INDUSTRY WITH A
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT DECLINE
MEXICO.
UP THROUGH CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WITH PERMITTING IS
WELL COMPLIANCE. IN OBVIOUSLY
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
UPDATING DEVELOPMENT PERMITS OUT
WITHIN SPECIFIC BASE IS WELL SO
WHY DON'T WE TURN IT OVER TO MR
GOLDBERG TO BE ABLE TO KICK US
OFF. THANK YOU MADAM. THAT MIX
THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN MIKE WEIR AND
PLACED ON CHAIRMAN OF THE
SYSTEM.
.
CRAP CRAP. I AM A SECOND
STRINGER.
I KNOW THAT ROB WAS A SICK IT
WAS THE FIRST TRAINER AND I'M
SECOND STRINGER ON ON THE THE
SARDINE SO. BUT IF YOU DON'T
MIND I'D LIKE TO JUST MOMENT.
BRING TOGETHER BECAUSE THAT WE
ARE SIMILAR IN ALL RESPECTS FOR.
AND MY PUBLIC COMMENT WITH
SARDINES IT THAT THEY ARE UNDER
A DISASTER REQUEST AND ALONG
WITH SALMON AND ALL WITH SEA
URCHIN AS WELL AND SO I DO CHECK
THE UNOVA WEBSITE. ON A WEEKLY
BASIS AND SO SAYS PENDING. AND
SO WHAT I WOULD REQUEST FROM
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO SEND A
LETTER TO THE SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE WILL ROSS AND ALSO TO
CHRIS ALL OVER AT NOVA.
NATURI FISHERY SERVICE TO SEE IF
WE CAN.
DISLODGE THE THE PENDING AND
MAKE IT TO A ECHO THAT THEY ARE.
ARE DECLARED AS A STATE DISASTER
CONSIDER DOING. MOVING ON THAT
MEANS.
.
IAN DIANE PUSHERS WHO RUNS THE
COMPANY WITH FISH OR WHAT BUT
FISH PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION
ASKED.
ME TO. MAKE THESE POINTS OVER A
RELATIVELY QUICK SINCE I'M NOT A
SARDINE THEM ENTRY ADVOCATE OR
PERSON THAT WOULD KNOWS A LOT SO
I'LL JUST READ THAT THE NOTES
AND THAT IS. THAT THEY RECOGNIZE
THE URGENT NEED TO DEVELOP A
SYSTEMATIC SURVEY OF NEAR SHORE
WATERS. THIS INCLUDES.
AND EXCLUDED AREA UNDER THE
CURRENT STOCK ASSESSMENTS. AND
THIS IS NOW RECOGNIZED AS A
SERIES OF MISSION SO.
THAT WITH IF THEY DO GET
DISASTER RELIEF. THE WILL USE
THE SOME OF THE FUNDS FOR A.
A BENEFICIAL FOR COOPER
RESEARCH PROGRAM TO ASSESS THE
BIOMASS WHERE AS.
.
SEVENTY EIGHTY PERCENT IN THE
CATCHES FOR THAT WAS THAT WAS
THAT A CAR SO THAT'S NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT ENSURE
BIOMASS.
STOCK ASSESSMENTS.
AND THE SOLICITATION HAS
RECEIVED A SMALL CONTRACT FOR
THE SOUTH WAS FISHERIES SCIENCE
CENTER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. TO
HELP FUND THE PILOT SURVEY
INVOLVING FISHMAN AND SPOT A
PILOT TO VALIDATE THE CALL.
COOPERATIVE AREA AERIAL SURVEY.
THAT'S NOW BEING CONDUCTED IN
ARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FISH AND WILDLIFE SO THIS
CONTINUING WORK WILL HELP THE
FISHERY IMPROVED THEIR STOCK
ASSESSMENTS. THOSE OF THE MAIN
POINTS THAT THE STOCK
ASSESSMENTS ON THE THE BIOMASS
WAS WAS MISSED. AND THAT THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM OF
THE FISHERY A DISASTER FUNDS
BEING USED TO HELP COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION. NOTHING SO MUCH AS
A COMPARABLE FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
ON THAT AND ALSO POPE WITHIN THE
LETTER AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
THAT TONY SURE IS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
ASSOCIATION. AND. GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA BE ALSO UPDATING US
ON ISSUES OF THE SERBIAN
FISHERIES WELL. KNOW. HOW YOU
ARE OKAY THROWS ALL ROB NO
WORRIES NO WORRIES?
THE GENERAL THE GENTLEMAN DID IT
WILL THOUGH I THINK.
.
BASICALLY I. WANT TO BE THANKFUL
TO A GREAT MANY THAT OUR THAT
OUR INDUSTRY IS
ACTUALLY CONTRACTING BECAUSE OF
OF THE CONTRACTION OF WATER
RESOURCES AND LAND RESOURCES IN.
THE SAME THINGS THAT ALL THE
OTHER FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE SO THE ONLY THING WE
CAN. HOPE FOR IN THE FUTURE IS
TO MOVE INTO THE PACIFIC OCEAN
WHICH IS A SMALL BODY OF WATER
WE MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH.
WHERE WE COULD GROW AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT IN FISH WE ESTIMATED IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BY EACH?
THURS PROBABLY SOMETHING EASILY.
WITH A VERY RELATIVELY SMALL
MODERATE DENSITY OF FISH FARMS
OFF SHORE THE POSSIBILITY OF
CREATING A ONE TO TWO BILLION
DOLLAR.
SHOULD FOR BILL YOU'VE.
FISHERY THAT PROBABLY HAD A
CERTAIN ECONOMIC VELOCITY OF
ABOUT FOUR WHICH WOULD PUT IT TO
APPROACHING TEN BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TIME EMPLOYING.
GOODNESS SEVERAL TEN THE BOOK
FOR ABOUT TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IS
A IS AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE SURE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
BRIGHT FUTURE. THING THAT HAS
THE JOB OF OURFUTURE THE TO OUR
PROHIBITS OR STOPS OR CONSTRAINS
OUR FUTURE. IS THE LACK OF THE
THE.
PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO EVEN GETTING A
PERMIT ANYWHERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO DO OFFSHORE
AQUACULTURE ESPECIALLY MARINE OR
A MARINE FINFISH AQUACULTURE. ON
AND WE HAVE TO DATE WE HAVE. TO
THANK.
A DIRECTOR BONHAM AND OR A.
COCKLE CULTURE COORDINATOR RANDY
OVER THERE. FOR FINALLY GETTING
THIS PROGRAM IN A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN REVISE THE FOURTH VERSION.
OF THIS DOCUMENT THAT IS TAKEN
AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED. NOW
BUS SOMEWHERE IT DEPENDS ON HOW
YOU COUNT IT FROM WHERE IT
STARTED FOURTEEN OF.
AND DO FOURTEEN YEARS ELEVEN TO
AT LEAST ELEVEN AS MANY AS
FOURTEEN YEARS. SO WE'RE GETTING
UNDER WAY AND AND THE PROMISE TO
GET THAT DONE BY THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR ACCORDING TO CHUCK
IS JUST. AMAZINGLY GOOD NEWS FOR
US SHOULD WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS.
AND ON. TOP OF. THAT'S JUST
THAT'S THE MAJOR THING I WOULD
LIKE TO REPORT AND I THINK IT'S
A POSITIVE AND BRIGHT OUTLOOK
FOR US.
QUICK QUESTION IN YOU KNOW WE WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS STUFF DEVELOPING A
PRE PERMITTING PROGRAM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT AS
WE'VE LOST BUSINESS.
CLEAN UP NORTH.
ANY OTHER YOU WANNA GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON ANY ISSUES ON MOVEMENT
OF PRE PERMITTING BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S BEEN. ONE OF THE
BEST LOW HANGING FRUIT THAT WE
COULD POTENTIALLY MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE INSURED THAT OPTICAL TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO LIKE THAT SHOW.
THIS PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE FROM
WELL OFFSHORE AQUACULTURE IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE WELL
SUITED TO THAT. BECAUSE THE
WHOLE IDEA WOULD DISPERSE THEM
AWAY FROM MANAGEMENT GROUPS LIKE
HUMBLED. AND VENTURA AND SAN
DIEGO THAT MARVELOUS SHELLFISH
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS TO GET ME
WRONG THOSE GUYS ARE DOING A
SWELL JOB. BUT BUT.
BUT OFFSHORE AQUACULTURE IS
GOING TO BE A LARGE SCALE
INTERPRET NOURIEL ENTERPRISE IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME BIG BOYS TO
GET IN THERE. AND INVEST TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WHICH IS A
PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH THE P.
R. BUT WE'RE HAND WE ARE WORKING
WITH IT.
MEXICO'S PROGRAM IS WORTH WHAT.
HASN'T BEEN DEVELOPMENT ALSO IN
ORDER TO OBSERVE MY I'VE BEEN A
CONSULTANT TO TWO OTHER PROJECTS
ONE OF THEM IS A.
INTENSE. PACIFIC ARE A PACIFICO.
LOCAL CULTURE PACIFICO AND AND
SO NOT IN THE OTHER ONE IS A.
WHO ARE CRITICAL OF THE SEA
THAT'S AS IN ENGLISH? NAME INTO
A POSITIVE BUT CONSULTANT TO
BOTH OF THOSE PEOPLE HELPING TO
BUILD THEIR HATCHERIES. AND
DOING SOME ANALYSIS OF OF OF HOW
OF OF WHAT THE THE PROCESS
PROFILE LOOKS LIKE TO GO FISHIN
HOW MUCH MONEY PER SQUARE. METER
CAN YOU GET ECCENTRIC CENTER TO
CENTER. OF.
THE PRODUCTION MATRICES AND
OTHER DOING ALL THEY'RE DOING
VERY WELL THERE ARE PROBABLY SIX
DOWN IS SIX OTHER FIRMS NOW JOAN
IN THE SOUTHERN.
IN IN SOUTHERN IRAQ IN THE GULF
OF CALIFORNIA THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE SEA OF CORTEZ AND THEN
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHERS ON ON
SHORE IN THE WEST COAST OF.
MEXICO THAT MEANS MEXICO
MAINLAND AND THERE ARE OTHERS ON
THE EAST COAST.
CHICAGO HAS BEEN A VERY
PROACTIVE TALK WILL OFFSHORE
AQUACULTURE PROGRAM LOOKING AT
LOTS AND LOTS OF SPECIES SNOW IS
STILL REALLY IN ITS INFANCY IS
NOT REALLY EVEN TEN YEARS OLD.
IT'S HARD TO SAY HOW MUCH MONEY
IS KING BUT KNOWING THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING. TO END IT.
THEY'RE PRETTY SURE THEY'RE
GONNA MIX OF WHAT IS SPEND DON'T
DO THAT UNLESS THEY ARE
UNDERSTANDING IT IS STILL A
FLEDGLING INDUSTRY. MOSTLY
DOMESTIC OR INTERNATIONAL ARE
THEY SHIPPING IT OUT OF COUNTRY
FOR CONSUMPTION WHAT DO YOU WHAT
DO THEY SEE DOWN THERE OR WHAT.
MARKET ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
MEXICO'S GOT A A GROWING MIDDLE
CLASS AND ONE OF THE GREATEST
VICIOUSLY HAPPENS TO TWELVE A
IT'S A VERY LARGE SEA BASS IN
THE NORTHERN PART. OF THE GOAL
OF THE GULF OF MEXICO THAT I HAD
THE PLEASURE WORKING ON IT WAS
GREAT FUN IT'S OFFICIALLY GROWS
TO. WE WE GOT FISH THAT WE
PROJECTED TO GROW TO ELEVEN
POUNDS IN FOURTEEN MONTHS WHICH
MAKES THEM AMONG THE FASTEST
GROWING CHRISTIAN THE WORLD AND
IT GAVE ME MUCH GEORGE A PROJECT
THAT. ANYWAY.
THE THE. COMPUTER MONITOR IS
DOING THEM IN LARGE NUMBERS
THERE STALKING LIKE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND OF THEM IN AN
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM IN THE
NORTHERN GULF. BECAUSE THE TWO
TWELVE HE IS ALSO IN DANGER BUT
IT WILL BE THERE AND SO IN THAT
STATUS. PRESENT IT WOULD ONLY BE
SOLD. TO A MEXICAN MARKET BUT
MEXICO HAS A VERY DECENT FISH
MARKET AT REASONABLE PRICES. AND
SO THEY'LL DO FINE. UNTIL UNTIL
THE EXPANDED SUCH AS THE EXTENT
THAT THE THEY CAN THEY CAN
EXPORT OF THESE ARE GREAT FISH
THESE ARE JUST LIKE GIANT SEA
BASS. IS GOOD AS YOU THEIR FISH
QUALITY AS GOOD AS YOU CAN GET.
THERE AND.
.
LOTS OF LOTS AND LOTS OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THERE. THANK YOU
THAT IS FANTASTIC AND I YEAH I I
MEAN WE MENTION IT HERE AT OUR
PREVIOUS HERE AND WANT TO GET AN
UPDATE ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
SO THAT SO. THAT'S ENCOURAGING
WELL WE'RE WE'RE ALL WOULD I I'M
I'M NOT JUMPING FOR JOY YET WELL
BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE IT BUT
WHEN WE GET THIS DAMN THING.
FINISHED WITHIN THE CALENDAR
YEAR WE WILL HAVE AT LAST THE
BEGINNING WE DON'T LIKE THE PP I
ARE AT ALL OR THE THINGS IN IT
FOR THE BILL THE PROPAGATED IT.
BUT WE CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO
ENGAGE IT UNTIL THIS P. E. R. IS
OVER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SURE
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE.
TURN OVER TO I NOW MISTER GREAT
DEAL FROM COAST SEAFOOD HE'S
GOING TO GIVE US AN UPDATE ON
ALL ISSUES OF SHELLFISH AND
COMING TO US FROM THE CLEANERS
BAY WATER IN THE STATE.
REQUIRE.
BUY SHARES. STONE ARMED I I I
GOTTA SAY THIS. ALL AT LEAST TWO
FISHERMEN ELEVEN POUNDS. THAT
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT I
DESCRIBE A FISH IS THIS IS THIS
IS MY FISH AND A LOT OF GROUND.
OFFICIAL.
BUT FOR FIREPLACE.
AWESOME.
I'M SURE I'VE I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
TIRES SITTING IN FOR JOHN FINGER
TODAY I DON'T HAVE THE EARRING
AND I AND I DON'T HAVE THE.
YOU IN THE NOSE RING THOUGH
WHICH IS GOOD.
MY WIFE DOES A YEAH.
SO I I I I HAVE SOME NOTES FROM
JOHN AND AND I'M REALLY HERE TO
TALK ABOUT. BOMB SOME OF THE
ISSUES WERE SITTING IN THE
SHELLFISH INDUSTRY. BOMB AND AND
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE
SEE MOVING FORWARD BOB AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A HUGE SEAFOOD
DEFICIT THIS COUNTRY AND IN THIS
STATE. AND JOHN ON JOHN'S
RESTAURANT HE'S GOT MULTIPLE
RESTAURANTS IN THE NAPA VALLEY
SAN FRANCISCO THEY SELL ABOUT
SIX MILLION OYSTERS A YEAR. ON
THEIR HOPING TO DOUBLE THAT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS SO. TWELVE
MILLION OYSTERS THEY CAN GROW
ABOUT THREE MILLION SO HE IS
IMPORTANT. OYSTERS FROM ALL
LITERALLY ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
ON TO TO MEET THAT DEMAND. I
HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF HIS ONE OF
HIS CUSTOMERS AND AND.
WHEN THIS IS ONE OF ITS
SUPPLIERS.
WE'D WE'D LIKE TO FIX THAT WE
THINK WE CAN GROW MORE SHELLFISH
IN THIS STATE. ARM IF YOU WERE
TO LOOK AT THE EAST COAST.
WHO WHO HAS EMBRACED THE GROWTH
OF THEIR INDUSTRY THEY'RE ISSUES
GROWN BY TWENTY TO FIFTY PERCENT
EVERY YEAR IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS? ARM AND THEIR THEIR
ORCHARDS OR ARE INCREDIBLE.
THEIR SHELLFISH IS DOING QUITE
WELL THERE AUG AND CONSEQUENTLY
THE WATER QUALITY IS IS
BENEFITING FROM IT.
BOMBS.
SO THE SHELLFISH INDUSTRY OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS
WORKED TOWARDS.
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE GROWTH
CONCERNS AND WE WOULD LIKE TO.
WE'VE APPROACH AGENCIES ON ASKS
FOR HELP. IN THE PERMITTING SIDE
OF IT THAT'S REALLY THE THE MAIN
BARRIER ON AND DOING THIS IN A
PROGRAMMATIC OR A MORE
COORDINATED EFFORT INSTEAD OF
DOING IT INDIVIDUALLY TO DO. TO
DO IT.
INTO PROGRAMMATIC FASHION OFF.
I THINK.
THE I THINK MOSTLY AGENCIES
WOULD AGREE IT'S MORE EFFICIENT
TO DO IT THAT WAY AND IT'S MORE
EFFICIENT FOR BOTH THE APPLICANT
AND THE AGENCIES. ON THE THE
CURRENTLY THE THEIR COASTAL
COMMISSION FELL FOR IT BECAUSE
COMMISSION IS WORKING THROUGH.
ADDRESSING OUTDATED OR OR
NONCOMPLIANCE ISSUES WITH THE
CDP'S AROUND THE STATE FOR
SHELLFISH. BOMB AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE THINK AND
I BELIEVE THEY BELIEVE. COULD BE
DONE PROGRAMMATIC GLEE. AND SO
WE ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE
PRESERVATION PRESIDENT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO.
TO ADD TWO ADDITIONAL.
EMPLOYEES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND GAME OFFICIAL WHILE
LIFE FALTERS.
FOR THE AWFUL TO PROGRAM.
AND WE ASK THAT YOU YOU BOTH
SUPPORT THAT ON. THAT BUDGET
REQUEST
IF POSSIBLE.
WE SEE.
WE SEE THE DEPARTMENT DOING
GOOD THINGS AS AS IT GOES
FORWARD. WE JUST WANNA HELP.
WE ALSO FEEL THAT AS A STATE WE
SHOULD BE LEADING THE WAY IN
WHICH WE CAN.
CANNOT PUSHING. CULTURE
OFFSHORE INTO FEDERAL WATERS.
I THINK THAT'S A MISTAKE.
IN THE EFFORT TO EDUCATE AND
EXPLORE OPTIONS WE ARE ARE
GRATEFUL TO. BOTH CHAIRS OR VICE
DO GERM REQUIRED VICE CHAIR
STONED FOR.
ASSISTING IN SPONSORING A A
BRIEFING AND RECEPTION ON APRIL
SEVENTEENTH SACRAMENTAL. BOMB.
AND THAT'S ABOUT ALL I GOT I HAD
A FORTY FIVE MINUTE PRESENTATION
BUT TOM TOLD ME A FEW FREE CRAP
CRAP TOLD ME I COULDN'T. USE
FORTY FIVE MINUTES. AGO.
NO SOUND LIKE IT TOO IS OUT
TENNIS RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISS YOU
VERY GRATEFUL. THAT LOOKS THE
BEST HERE IF I HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
TODAY I I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT
AND I THINK THAT THE IN THE
OTHER PIECE THAT WE DID DISCUSS
PARTICULAR AND SHELLFISH. ON THE
DEMAND IS HUGE.
IN THIS STATE ALONE.
AND WE CAN'T GROW WHAT WHAT WE
CONSUME AN ANNUAL BASIS I THINK
WHERE YOU HAVE BEEN. TRYING YOUR
DARNDEST IS.
HOW WE CAN EXPAND CREATE LOCAL
JOBS DO AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE WAY? IN LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THAT PRE
PERMITTING OUT WITHIN SPECIFIC
BAY WATERS STRATEGICALLY. AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN YOUR BEER
TOPICAL AS. A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
TO MAKE THIS WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
YES IT IS AND AND I THINK WE'RE.
WE'VE WE'VE HIT SET BACKS BUT I
THINK WE'RE CONTINUING TO.
TO GROW IN OUR. IN OUR.
ABILITY TO DO THAT SOMETIMES I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE EASIER TO
FIX THE OCEAN. IS EXCELLENT
GOVERNMENT BUT ON. MY STAND I
STAND READY TO TRY. A THE
SUBMISSIONS TO DO WE'RE GRATEFUL
THANK YOU FOR PITCH IN A GAME
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU
WERE HERE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. MAKE A
GREAT JOB.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
TOWARDS HERE CHIN HALIBUT AND
CRAB GEAR RETRIEVAL UPDATE. AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT TOM
TRAPPERS HERE AT THE VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA SEA
URCHIN COMMISSION INDIA WHERE IS
LISA FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THAT HAPPENED A SEAFOOD
MARKETING ASSOCIATION. IS SO
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN INCISIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
TOM ARE GRATEFUL IT WAS GREAT TO
SEE LAST NIGHT.
TOM IS GOING TO BE A GIVEN AS AN
OPT IN IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGING
TIME FOR THOSE WHO ARE. HARVEY
SINCERE CHANGE IN THIS STATE.
HE'S GONNA BE A PRISON IS
BACKGROUND THE POOR CONDITION
OF-THEIR CHIN FISHERIES. AS WELL
AS
A LOT THE SIGNIFICANT REGULATORY
CHANGES THAT THEY'VE HAD A NEED
FOR DISASTER ASSISTANCE. LEASES
HERE HE'S GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE ALLOWANCE FOR HOW THAT
PERMIT TRANSFERS UNDER I SP
THIRTEEN OH NINE WILL UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE INDUSTRY LED
LAST FISHING GEAR RECOVERY
PROJECT IN HALF MOON BAY AND
THEY HAVE BEEN ALL OVER IT. JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU KNOW TRULY
FOR YOUR EFFORTS. TO LEAD THE
WAY ON THIS MEN ALSO TALKING
ABOUT THE EXEMPTED FISHING
PERMIT PROGRAM AS WELL. FIRST TO
TURN IT OVER TO TOM GET FIVE
MINUTES SIR WE WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE AS ALWAYS. AND I'LL
GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND PROF.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
BUDGETS RECENTLY. CORRECT
DRIVING TRIP FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DOWN TO SAN DIEGO
STOPPING IN THE HARBOR SOME
STUFF ON THE WAY TO TALK TO THE
FISHERMEN.
ARE.
STATED THERE CAN FISHERY IS IN
DIRE TROUBLE RIGHT NOW. WERE
DOWN EIGHTEEN NINETY PERCENT
SOME OF OUR AREAS. OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HAVEN'T HAD ANY
KILLED FOR THREE YEARS NOW. WE
GOT A LITTLE BIT THIS YEAR BUT.
NOT ENOUGH THIS FALL THE DIVERS
ARE OUT INTO A HUNDRED FEET OF
WATER WERE PICKING URCHINS THAT
ARE EATING BARNACLES. WHICH IS
NOTHING ELSE FOR THEM TO EAT.
WE'VE LOST A COUPLE DRIVERS TO
THE BENDS ARE READY OF AIDS YOU
KNOW IT'S. IN GOOD SHAPE.
CENTRAL COAST OF THERE'S NO
URGENCY HERBS AUTRES OF JUST
WIPE THEM OUT.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SANTA
BARBARA THERE. IS A FEW GUYS
WORKING. NOT VERY MANY THERE
THERE'S SURGEONS BUT THEY'RE
JUST NOT FINDING ANYTHING AT ALL
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE JUST.
THEY'RE JUST NOT IN VERY GOOD TO
DO NOT. TIME OF GUILT. SAN
DIEGO.
DIVERS DOWN THERE THROUGHOUT IN
DEEP WATER JUST LIKE THEY ARE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PUSHING IN IN T DOING THOSE
DEEP TIES AND WHICH ARE
DANGEROUS OR DANGEROUS DIES. ON.
THE WHOLE STATE IS THE SOURCE
YOUR CHIN GOES IN PRETTY BAD
CONDITION. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAD A PURPOSE EXPLOSION ALSO
CAME ALONG WITH THE.
EL NINO. AND.
THERE ARE EATING ALL THE BABY
KELP THAT WE'RE STARTING TO GET
THE PURPLE URCHINS ARE JUST.
DEVASTATING MAP SOMEWHERE KINDA
GOT TWO FRONTS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW. FROM THE EL NINO IS WINDING
DOWN I I BELIEVE WE'RE COMING
OUT OF IT ON. THE OCEAN
CONDITIONS ARE. I JUST WENT
THROUGH THIS EITHER THROUGH YOUR
THIRD OR FOURTH EL NINO I'VE
BEEN THROUGH I'VE NEVER SEEN ONE
LAST THIS LONG BEFORE IS LISTED
IN THE EFFECTS OF LAST THIS
LONG.
WE'RE HOPING WE'RE HOPING. THAT
IT'S KIND OF STREET KNOWLEDGE
BUILT.
ON.
BUT WE WOULD LIKE FROM YOU GUYS
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE IS
REALLY HELP US PUSH THIS
DISASTER THING THROUGH.
WE ARE A LOT SLOWER PROCESSORS
THE END FROM OUR PROCESSORS IN
LOS ANGELES AREA HAVE SHUT DOWN
HOPEFULLY THEY'RE GONNA OPEN
BACK UP AGAIN. WHEN THE YOU WERE
TO SAY. WHEN YOU ARE
HAVING A ROBUST SEASON YOU BRING
IN A HUNDRED PERCENT OF HARVEST
IF YOU WILL MOVING. ARE YOU A
TEN PERCENT OF NORMAL WHERE YOU
AT.
IT I MEAN THERE ARE SOME
REGIONS THE STATE WE ARE NOT
EVEN FOLKS AREN'T EVEN ABLE TO
GO OUT JUST DESCRIBE IT PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR US.
WILL.
IN FORT BRAGG USUALLY WE HAVE
OF.
.
MANY BOATS WORKING. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE FOUR.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS JUST HOLDING
THEIR BREATH LOT OF GUYS ARE
GREAT WOULD THEY BRING ENOUGH
FOR THOSE FOUR BOATS BRINGING.
WE USUALLY BRING UP THE ANYWHERE
SOME A THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND
POUNDS A DAY THE RING UP TWO TO
THREE HUNDRED POUNDS A DAY IS
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
HARVESTING.
AND THEN THE PERCENTAGES ARE
DOWN ON AN AS IT SAID THEY WERE
DRIVING DEEPER AND THE PURCHASE
OR EATING BARNACLES. AND WE'VE
NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE YOU
THERE'S KIND OF LATE THEY WENT.
ALL THE CONFINED.
THAT'S THE STATE OF IT.
AND.
IT'S NOTHING YOU ARE IS SO WITH
THAT HELP. YOU OR NOT SEEN.
REPLENISH WHAT SO YOU'RE NOT
SEEN THEM GROW IT'S IT'S IT IS
BEEN.
.
NOT BEEN A MARKED IMPROVEMENT
SINCE THE LAST TIME WE TALKED
WELL THERE IS ACTUALLY. THIS
YEAR LONG SAW SMALL LITTLE AREAS
WHERE THERE WAS SOME SPORTS CAME
OUT.
THAT'S THAT'S A SIGN THAT ALL
NEED A WINDING DOWN. OF WHAT WE
NEED THIS FOR THE KILL WE NEED
THIS SPRING IS HAVE A COLD
WATER.
ON HIM THING WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE GET THE NORTHWEST WINDS
BLOWING A BLOW THAT WARM WATER
OFF THE SURFACE IT BRINGS OUT. A
NUTRIENT RICH COLD WATER IN THE
DEEP IF WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE A
CHANCE OF GETTING MORE KILLED.
AND THAT'S WERE ALL HOPING AND
PRAYING FOR. IN MY IGNORANCE AND
I APOLOGIZE SO FROM THE TIME YOU
GET TO SAY BYE. KNOCK ON WOOD.
WE SEE THAT TOO. REPLENISHMENT
OF WHAT DOES NOT FORCE IF YOU
WILL USE TO LOOK LIKE WHAT'S
TIMELINE ON THAT.
.
A COUPLE YEARS PROBABLY TO GET
READY REALLY BACK TO IT IF WE DO
GET KILLED. FOR TWO CONSECUTIVE
GOOD CALC FOR TWO CONSECUTIVE
YEARS. THE SECOND YEAR GETS
BETTER THE FIRST YEAR WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE URCHINS TIME TO
GO THROUGH THE FIRST
YEAR. JUST. STRUGGLING WITH IT
BUT IT IS GETTING BETTER BY THE
SECOND YEAR THEY'RE USUALLY
BETTER THEIR FIRMED UP. SO IT
TWO YEARS AT MINIMUM.
IN JUST LOOKING AT THE.
THE LANDINGS REAL QUICK FORT
BRAGG HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IT WAS A LITTLE OVER ONE
POINT THREE MILLION POUNDS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THREE
TO TWENTY ONE THOUSAND. IF WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SANTA BARBARA
AREA ALMOST FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION POUNDS OTHER DOWN TO ONE
POINT SIX MILLION. LAST YEAR
IT'S THIS MASSIVE DECREASES PAUL
MASSIVE MASSIVE.
AND IT'S THIS IS REALLY
DEVASTATING FOR THE WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE BUSINESS
IS WHAT IT IS AND IT'S. YOU KNOW
OUR. MYSELF I PROCESSOR TUNES I
USED TO WORK. IN BACK IN THE
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN. I HAD
SEVENTY EMPLOYEES I HAVE CAN
NOW.
SO THAT. AND I'M HAVING TROUBLE
KEEPING THE TEN WORKING. SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
ONE OTHER THING PLACE. WE.
WITH THE HELP OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE DISCUSS REGULATIONS
PASSED IS GOING TO HELP US GET
THROUGH SOME THIS THING AND I
WOULD LIKE TO. THANK FISH AND
WILDLIFE FOR HELPING US THANK
YOU SO MUCH. PRESSURE.
THAT. JUST A COMMENT ON THE ON
THE CAL AT THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL WELL IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE ON COST OF
PROTECTION WHICH IS A COMMITTEE
THAT I HAVE HERE WE. HAD.
PC AND TALK ABOUT YOUR GRASS
AND CAL AND IT'S IT'S REALLY
STARTLING TO SEE. SOME OF THE
GRAPHICS ABOUT THE THE LOSS OF
THE KELP FOREST WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY IMPACTING WRITERS THE
URCHIN POPULATION BUT. IT'S ALSO
SHOWING SOME SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS FROM THE OCEAN
CHEMISTRY STANDPOINT IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROTECT. SHELLFISH AND
HOW SHELLFISH GROW THEY THE
CHEMISTRY NEEDS TO BE CORRECT.
TO THEIR LOTS OF DIFFERENT
LAYERS TO THE. THE LOSS OF THE
KELP FORESTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
NOT ONLY IMPACTING THE FISHERIES
THERE. BUT CHANGING THE THE
CHEMISTRY PREVENTING THE LACK OF
THE FORCE PREVENT SOME OF THE
BUFFERS THAT WE NEED. AND AS THE
WE GET MORE CARBON IN THE OCEAN.
CHANGING THAT THAT CHEMISTRY AND
STARTING TO PROVIDE SOME A
LITTLE BIT MORE ACID IN WHATEVER
SMALL AMOUNTS BUT IT CAN BE
DEVASTATING. TO OYSTERS TO
SHELLFISH PRODUCTION OF ANY
KIND.
THESE ARE THESE ARE VERY
COMPLICATED BUT IN A RELATED
ISSUES AND FINDING WAYS TO PUT.
THE THE ALLERGIES BACK IN THE
OCEAN AND GET THEM TO GROW IS IS
GOING TO HELP US ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT LEVELS SO IT'S A IT'S
A BIG ISSUE THAT WE NEED A LOT
MORE SCIENCE ON. AND TO BE
LOOKING A LOT MORE CLOSELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY. WERE NOW.
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE LISTED
THE EXACT ADDRESS COULD HAPPEN
BASICALLY MARKETING ASSOCIATION
HERE THAT YOU HAVE TO FOR FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
CAN GET FUZZY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK PARTICULARLY
RETRIEVAL.
THANK YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING TIME OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS AS WELL I WANT TO
THANK YOU.
JIM ACQUIRE VICE CHAIR STONE
AND I THINKS MR WAS LOW FOR
ASKING ME TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'VE BEEN KNOWN TO WEAR MANY
HATS IN THE COMMERCIAL FISHING
COMMUNITY OF HALF MOON BAY. AND
TODAY OVER TO.
TO SPEAK TO TO SPECIFIC
SECTIONS OF THE FISHERIES
OMNIBUS BILL. ON MY DAUGHTER
SISTER HAD TO.
B. TO SECTION FIVE AND MY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE HALF
ME SEAFOOD ARKETING ASSOCIATION
HAD. TO SPEAK TO SECTION EIGHT.
SO FIRST ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY
AND OTHERS I ASKED THE SUPPORT
UPDATING THE LANGUAGE.
THAT A DAY IN THE CALIFORNIA HOW
THE TRANSFER ABILITY AS
SUGGESTED IN SECTION FIVE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT LANGUAGE.
I COME FROM A COMMERCIAL
FISHING FAMILY THAT HAS BEEN
FISHING OUT OF HALF MOON BAY FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS. AND
TIMES HAVE CHANGED. AND WE'VE
WORKED HARD TO CHANGE WITH THEM.
TO SUCCESSFULLY ADAPT TO NEW
REGULATORY SYSTEMS SUCH AS
QUALIFYING FOR MAINTAINING A
CALIFORNIA HAVE IT PERMIT. SINCE
THAT FISHING BECAME LIMITED
ENTRY IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. I
REALLY APPRECIATE VICE PRESIDENT
WILLIAMS COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE.
BE REALLY EASY TO GET INTO THE
WEEDS HERE WHICH BELIEVE ME I
DID WHEN DRAFTING THESE REMARKS.
BUT IT'S LATE IN THE DAY AND I
WANT TO DO THAT TO YOU AND.
I HAVE ANOTHER HAD TO PUT ON IN
A MINUTE SO I JUST WANT TO SHOW
THREE PRINCIPLES THAT I THINK
ARE REALLY. IMPORTANT TO ALL
AREAS OF FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
AND HOW THEY RELATE TO THIS
ISSUE AND PRINCIPLE ONE IS THAT
COMMERCIAL FISHING BUSINESSES
NEED LEXIBILITY TO SURVIVE.
OVER THE YEARS FISHING
BUSINESSES LIKE ALMOST EVERY
OTHER BUSINESS HAVE TO ADAPT.
IN OUR INDUSTRY THAT COULD
INCLUDE THE NEED TO CHANGE
VESSELS HAVE A SAFER FISHING
PLATFORM. AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THIS WITHOUT A VESSEL
BEING DESTROYED. AND THAT'S
FORCING PARTICIPANTS OUT OF THE
FISHERY.
TWO REGULATIONS NEED TO BE
UPDATED RATHER THAN USED AS A
REASON TO PERPETUATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. ARE THE
TRANSFERABILITY RESTRICTIONS IN
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR WERE PUT
INTO PLACE PRIOR TO. THE
COMMISSION ADOPTING A RESTRICTED
ACCESS PROGRAM. TWELVE YEARS
LATER WE STILL LIVE IN PRIOR TO
LAND.
IN THE RESTRICTIONS REMAIN
WHICH WE'VE BUSINESSES FAMILIES
AND THE INDUSTRY STOCK. AND
THREE FISHERIES REGULATIONS
SHOULD BE ABOUT MANAGING
FISHERIES AND NOT PEOPLE. THE
CURRENT SITUATION IS RESULTING
IN THE ELIMINATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HELMET FISHERY FOR NO
BIOLOGICAL OR CONSERVATION
REASON. SIXTY ONE PERMITS
ORIGINALLY ISSUED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. THIRTY SIX AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. TO TWENTY
FIVE HISTORICAL.
HOW ABOUT FISHING BUSINESSES
HAVE DISAPPEARED IN THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS? AND I'M DOING MY
BEST TO MAKE SURE MY FAMILY'S
NOT NEXT. SO AGAIN.
WHEN IT.
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT LANGUAGE
IN THE OMNIBUS BILL TO.
ALLOW THE COMMISSION STILL ACRID
RESTRICTED ACCESS PROGRAM BUT
ALSO PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
KEEP FAMILIES AND BUSINESS.
I'M GONNA CHANGE HATS FOR YOU
NOW AND TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE HAPPEN A SEAFOOD MARKETING
ASSOCIATION. ARE THIS IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION A
FISHERMAN IN HALF MOON BAY WHO
SHARE A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
BEING A PRODUCTIVE UNIFIED VOICE
FOR THEIR LOCAL INDUSTRY. I'M
SPEAKING ONLY TO SECTION EIGHT
OF THE OMNIBUS BILL ON LOST AND
ABANDONED CRAB GEAR. WANNA BE
CLEAR THAT THE HALF ME SEAFOOD
MARKETING ASSOCIATION HAS NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ON ANY OTHER
ISSUES.
IN THE ON THE BUS AT THIS TIME.
SO I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH THIS GROUP OF
PROGRESSIVE FISHERMEN IN MY HOME
PORT. US SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THIS ORGANIZATION AND WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND OTHERS WE'VE
CREATED AND MANAGED THE LOST
FISHING GEAR RECOVERY PROGRAM
AND A PORT FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS. BOMB IN AN EFFORT TO
REDUCE POTENTIAL MARINE MAMMAL
INTERACTIONS WITH GEAR AFTER THE
CLOSURE OF DUNGEONS CRAB SEASON.
ARE WE WERE DRIVEN TO DO THIS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR FISHERY
REPRESENTS THE VERY BEST IN
OCEAN STEWARDSHIP.
AND THAT'S BEEN SAID NO ONE
WANTS WILL ENTANGLEMENTS LEAST
OF ALL FISHERMEN. MISS FRENCH IS
CORRECT. COLLECTING MUST GEAR IS
NOTHING NEW FISHERMEN HAVE BEEN
CLEANING UP THE OCEAN ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS. FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME. SO STILL THE FLEET
HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EFFORTS TO FORMALIZE AND
STANDARDIZE EFFORTS FORGET
RECOVERY. AND HOW WE FELT IN
HALF A DAY AND STILL FEEL THAT
THE INDUSTRY BEING INVOLVED IN
THIS FROM THE GROUND UP IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HELP BUILD
LASTING SOLUTIONS. SO WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT OUR MODEL IS THAT
IT'S COMPLETELY MANAGED BY
INDUSTRY.
WE'VE BEEN TRACKING THE SUCCESS
AND LESSONS LEARNED TO HELP
INFORM THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN. CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
TASK FORCE. OTHER THAN JUST CRAP
TASK FORCE THAT IS. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE RECOVERED
MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY LOS ANGELES CRAB POTS IN
HALF MOON BAY. AND LAST YEAR
BEGAN WORKING WITH FOUR OTHER
CALIFORNIA PORTS TO HELP THEM
CREATE OR GROW SIMILAR PROGRAMS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IT HAS DEFINITELY BEEN
CHALLENGING TO GET TO A STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM I'M DEFINITELY
ENCOURAGED BY DIRECTOR BONHAM'S
REMARKS ON THIS TOPIC EARLIER
TODAY. ARM AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT INDUSTRY THE DEPARTMENT CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
FINALLY HAPPENED.
WE INHABIT MAY WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY AND
ADVOCATE FOR SUSTAINABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT CAN
BE. SUCCESSFUL IN ALL POOR
COMMUNITIES SO WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE LANGUAGE IN THE OMNIBUS
BILL THAT PROVIDES DATE. OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN FOR
THESE REGULATIONS TO BE
DEVELOPED. AND FOR THE EXTENSION
OF THE SUNSET DATE.
YOU MENTION THAT I WOULD SPEAK
TO THE F. PEAS AND THAT'S COOL I
DIDN'T PUT THAT BUT I CAN DO
THAT REALLY QUICKLY AND JUST LET
YOU KNOW.
I HAVE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN.
ANOTHER HAT SWITCH.
THE GROUND FISH GROUP AND HAVING
BAY HAS ON THE KHALFAN
GROUNDFISH COLLECTIVE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN. ESP FOR ELECTRONIC
MONITORING THE FEDERALLY MANAGED
FISHERY FOR GROUNDFISH AND THAT
PROCESS THAT IS ALLOWED THROUGH
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM. ALLOWS REAL
ON THE WATER TESTING OF.
IN THIS CASE TECHNOLOGY BUT IT
COULD BE OTHER THINGS.
PRIOR TO REGULATIONS BEING AN
ACTIVE AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY'S PLACES WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT GETTING STUCK IN
CALIFORNIA HAD WE DONE SOME YES
HE'S.
ARE EXEMPTED OR EXPERIMENTAL
FISHING PERMIT WORK ON THE WATER
PRIOR MIGHT HAVE SAVED US SOME
OF THESE REWORKS.
BECAUSE IT REALLY MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE WHEN. THE REGISTER
THE REGULATIONS ARE INFORMED BY
ON THE WATER EXPERIMENTATION. SO
I JUST.
GUESS THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
ON THAT BUT I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
STRANGE. SEVEN GIVING QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SO.
SO I THINK THE YOU YOU. HAVEN'T
BAY YOU'VE REALLY BEEN A LEADER
ON THE COUNTER EFFORT AND THEN
NOW MIGRATING RIGHT AT A TURNING
THIS. RETRIEVAL PROGRAM INTO A
STANDARDIZED SYSTEM OF A DOWN
THE COAST.
ALWAYS ASK THE QUESTION IS.
WHERE DO YOU FIND MOST STUFF
FOLKS HAVE LOST IT BASED OFF OF
WEATHER CONDITIONS?
OR INTERNED IN IMPORTANTLY
DISCUSS THEM OUT THERE TALK
ABOUT TRENDS THAT YOU SEE.
IN REGARDS TO YOUR FINDINGS.
WE'VE WE'VE REALLY FOUND THAT
AND YOU KNOW LOST GEAR IS A PART
OF COMMERCIAL FISHING FOR
DUNGENESS CRAB.
IT HAS BEEN FOR EVER SINCE
BEARS ROAM FREE.
YES IT'S BEEN FOR YOU KNOW I
ALWAYS A PART OF THE FISHERY SO
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IT'S IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THE FISHERMEN DO ON
PURPOSE. THERE'S SOME
OCCASIONAL.
LOTS OF IT OUT THERE BUT FOR THE
MOST PART IT'S THE STRAGGLERS
POTS TO GET SEPARATED FROM THE
REST OF THE STRING. POTS THAT
ARE MOVED BY WHETHER POTS THAT
ARE MOVED BY ANOTHER VESSEL A
SHIP.
AND THEY GET LEFT AND THERE'S A
PERCENTAGE.
IN PARTICULARLY STORMY YEARS
THIS YEAR WE SAW MORE THAT WE
RECOVERED THEN IN THE YEAR PRIOR
BECAUSE IT WAS A REALLY STORMY
YEAR. AND WEATHER CONDITIONS
MEANT THAT MORE GEAR WAS LOST.
WE ALSO IND THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF FISHERMAN THAT WE
CONTACT ARE REALLY HAPPY TO HEAR
FROM US. PLEASE THAT WE FOUND
THEIR GEAR HAPPY TO REIMBURSE
THE PROGRAM TO GET THEIR GEAR
BACK. ON THAT THAT WAS GOING TO
ASK QUESTIONS SO HAVE YOU HAD
ANY RESISTANCE. AT LEAST WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FLEET IN
PLEASE. PUSH BACK AGAINST ME IS
THAT. NO ONE EVER WANTS TO
UNTANGLE AWAY. THE LAST THING
THAT.
AND THE MORE PROACTIVE THE
FLEET CAN BE THE BETTER OFF
RIGHT. IT'S BETTER OFF FOR THE
INDUSTRY FOR THE CONSUMER THIS
KEEP GOING THROUGH IT. HAS THERE
BEEN ANY PUSH BACK.
IN REGARD TO HAVING TO. PAY TO
GET TO BE THE CURE BACK.
SURE I'M YOU KNOW. THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME PUSH BACK RIGHT
THERE'S ALWAYS A QUESTION OF
WELL HEY UP FOR YEARS I'VE JUST
PICK MYSELF UP ON THE DOCK.
BECAUSE MY FRIENDS HAVE FOUND IT
FOR ME AND NOW YOU WANT ME TO
PAY FOR IT.
WHAT WE'VE FOUND IS THAT THIS?
THESE PROGRAMS DON'T PRECLUDE A
FRIEND FROM PICKING UP HERE AND
TELLING ANOTHER FRIEND ABOUT IT.
IT JUST MAKES ANOTHER AVENUE FOR
A FORMALIZED RECOVERY EFFORT TO
GO OUT AND GET A LARGE AMOUNT OF
GEAR.
YOU KNOW DID YOU ADD A
MONETIZATION TO IT THE FISHERMEN
THAT RECOVER THIS GEAR.
ARE INCENTIVIZED TO DO SO AND
THE FLEET IS HAPPY TO GET THEIR
GEAR BACK SO. YOU GET YOUR BACK
AT A PRICE HOPEFULLY IN OUR
MODEL AND THAT'S OUR CONCERN
ABOUT. THE BROADER. LONG TERM
MODEL THROUGH THE APARTMENT BUT
IF IF A FISHERMAN CAN GET HIS
GEAR BACK AT LESS THAN IT WOULD
COST HIM TO REPLACE. KNEW. THE
GEARS OUT OF THE WATER. THERE'S
NO REST FOR AWHILE UNTANGLE MAN.
AND. IT'S A LOST ITEM FOUND
TYPICALLY THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
HAPPY BUT I'M NOT GONNA TELL YOU
THAT I NEVER GET ANYBODY THAT
MONEY IN THE POCKET HAPPY OTHER.
I'M SORRY HE INDEED.
IT'S MONEY IN THE POCKET IS
WELL IT'S EXACTLY YEAH NO
ABSOLUTELY IT'S. IT'S BEEN A
VERY.
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN OUR PORT
WE HAD A LESS SUPPORT FROM OUR
HARBOR DISTRICT WHICH IS GREAT.
YOU KNOW THE PRESS LOVES IT
IT'S IT'S A GREAT STORY OF
FISHERMEN BEING THE PROACTIVE
LEADERS IN WHALE ENTANGLEMENT
FIVE REDUCTION EFFORTS. AND
THAT'S THE THE P. SAID ALWAYS
SAY IS THAT WHEN IT CAME TO THE
CRAPPY RETRIEVAL BILL.
IT WAS NOT AT.
WHO'S NOT A LOBBYIST THAT CAME
TO US IT WAS THE CRAFT LEAGUE
THAT THE CRAFT LEADS THAT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE. TO MOVE ON THIS
ISSUE. IN A PROACTIVE MANNER
WHAT I WHAT I WOULD ADD THAT
THAT HAVING THAT LAW AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE THE ONE THING MISSING.
FROM OUR VOLUNTEER PROGRAM AS
SUCCESSFUL AS IT IS IS THE
TEETH.
WE NEED THE TEETH OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TELL THOSE
FEW FISHERMEN THAT WANT TO SAY
HEY I WANT MY GEAR AND I'M I'M
NOT GOING TO PAY FOR IT. BE
LIKE.
THIS IS THE WAY THE PROGRAM
WORKS AND YOU CAN TALK TO THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT IT THAT'S FINE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT NOW SO WE
WE FIND OURSELVES SOMETIMES
WORKING IN A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE AND A DISADVANTAGE
WITHOUT. THAT SUPPORT THINK THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE TIME.
WORKS.
EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE THEY NEED
TO BE A STICK.
AND.
IT. IN A IN A HAD TO SAY THIS
DEADLINE TO FINALLY GET THIS.
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE
STATE. HAS BEEN DESPERATELY
NEEDED WHEN I FEEL LIKE FROM
JUST ONE MORE THING IS I THINK
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN USE IN
WORKING THIS PROGRAM OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A STICK. I
REALLY THINK THAT THE AMOUNT OF
TIMES THAT STICK WILL NEED TO BE
TAKEN OUT OF THE VERY LIMITED
BACK IN THE CLOSET WILL BE SMALL
YES.
THANK YOU AGAIN. NOT EXACTLY YOU
HAVE DONE A FANTASTIC JOB IN
LEADING THE WAY IN SHOWING WHAT
CAN WORK WRITING. IN WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE NOW IS TURNED TO LAW.
AND IS NOW GOING TO BE SPREAD
ACROSS. EACH OF THE POOR TO
CALIFORNIA SOMETHING REALLY PART
OF THINKING WELL I'M PROUD OF
THE FISHERMEN THAT I WORK WITH
THAT MAKE THIS HAPPEN. AS JOHN
WAS RUSSIA.
ALL RIGHT. TO BOTH YOU THINK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LADIES IN GENERAL WE ARE
MOVING TO OUR FISHERY FISHERY
COMMITTEE REPORTS AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR EACH OF THESE FOUR
REPRESENTATIVES WHO HAVE BEEN
HOLDING TIGHT WITH US AND HANG
IN. FOR THE AFTERNOON THAT'S A
FIRST BRING UPPER SHELF FISHER
HE'S WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
TEAM IN THE DUNGEONS CRAP TASK
FORCE. SHOULD BE.
PROVIDING AN UPDATE ON THE TASK
FORCE'S ACTIVITIES IN. OUTPUT
ITEMS FROM THEIR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN REPORT WE ACTUALLY.
HAVE SOME SECURITY THAT TASK
FORCES AND KEEP MOVING FORWARD
AT WHICH IS ALSO A BIG SIGH OF
RELIEF. SO WONDERFUL NEWS FOR.
ALSO GOING TO.
WELCOME DARREN MERU UP HERE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA BUYS YOU
COMEDIAN SALMON STEELHEAD TROUT.
NEARLY ELECTED CHAIR BY THE WAY.
IN CAN BE PROVIDING OVERVIEW OF.
THE STATE OF SALMON AND
STEELHEAD RECOVERY EFFORTS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S WAS
WREAKING RECENT DECLINE TO
SPECIES THAT IT LED TO A SALMON
MARTIN C. DECLARATION. AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT MY CRICKETS IS
ALSO HERE CHAIR OFTHE SEA
CALIFORNIA'S SALMON STAMP
COMMITTEE. MYSTERY TO WANT TO
GET THIS SALMON STAMP RE
AUTHORIZE A IS A PEAK. IN ONE I
ALSO POINT OUT THAT MISTER
RICKETTS WAS AT LAST YEAR'S
RESOLUTION RECIPIENT AND HI
DAVID VERY GRATEFUL THAT.
THAT IS HERE HE IS A SENIOR
SCIENTIST WITH THE OCEAN SCIENCE
TRES. INTO SO I SAY THANK YOU TO
THE TRUSS WORK COULD BE TALKING
ABOUT.%
THEIR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP.
DELIVER USEFUL AND RELIABLE
SCIENCE IN SUPPORT OF CONFERENCE
COAST IN OCEAN AND PARTICULARLY
THESE DAYS RIGHT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE DATA EVEN THOUGH
SOME MAY NO LONGER LIKE TO. LOOK
AT SIGNS THAT WE WON'T GO THERE
FROM WATCHING DC. SO WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO WE'RE GOING TO BE AT
TURN IT RIGHT OVER WHATEVER
SHELL OF THE DATA PROVIDED TASK
FORCE UPDATE THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK IT'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL
TO SEE YOU HERE FIVE MINUTES
WILL GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO THE TASK
FORCE'S MOST RECENT MEETING WAS
HELD OCTOBER AND SIXTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN AND DURING THAT TIME.
THEY DISCUSSED OR THEY WORK
TOWARD DEVELOPING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
FENCING FISHING GAME CODE
SECTIONS AND DAMN THEY
RECOMMENDED TO.
EXTENDING SUNSET ON THOSE
FISHING GAME CODE SECTION SO
THAT AS. YOU SAID WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE WILD WILD WEST ANYMORE. THEY
ALSO RECOMMENDED SOME AMENDMENTS
TO PERMIT TRANSFERS THE LONG
TASK FORCE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRMAN CHOIR AND DAD CO CHAIR
STONE. FOR INCLUDING ALL OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS IN SENATE
BILLS. THIRTEEN OH NINE AND
THIRTEEN TEN AND ALSO A SPECIAL
SHOUT OUT TO TELL MY SLOW FOR
HIS EFFORTS IN DOING THAT AS
WELL.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE TASK
FORCE REQUESTED THAT FUNDING BE
SECURED THROUGH THE TENSIONS
CRAB COUNT TO SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE TASK FORCE
UNTIL THEY SENSE THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND AND AS OF JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR THE TASK
FORCE DID RECEIVE THAT REQUESTED
FUNDING AND SO THE TASK FORCE
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE FOR
ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS. TO
SUPPORT THAT AND TASK FORCES
OPERATIONS IN ONGOING EFFORTS TO
HELP INFORM CALIFORNIA FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT.
SO LOOKING AHEAD THIS YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING WITH THE
TASK FORCE TO DEVELOP A WORK
PLAN. TO OUTLINE WHAT THE TASK
FORCE IS GOING TO BE DOING THIS
YEAR. AND THE TASK FORCE LOOKS
FORWARD TO ADDRESSING A NUMBER
PRIORITY TOPICS.
INCLUDING SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT LAST PUSHING YOUR
RECOVERY PROGRAM. AND DATA
ADDRESSING COMPLEX FISHING
REGULATIONS. THE TASK FORCE WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TENSIONS PRACTITIONER
WORKING GROUP AND.
TO DRESS WHEN TANGLE MEANT. AND
DAN AND CONTENT AND.
WORK ON CONTINUED EVALUATION OF
THAT THE RAM PROGRAM THE RISK
ASSESSMENT MITIGATION PROGRAM.
THE TASK FORCE IS ALSO GRATEFUL
FOR THE STATE AND FEDERAL
EFFORTS AND PC IF A PHASE
EFFORTS TO OBTAIN THE FEDERAL
DISASTER RELIEF FUNDS AND DOWN
THERE'S. AS YOU KNOW LOTS OF
INTEREST IN THE INDUSTRY TO HELP
INFORM HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED AND AND THERE'S. AT
THIS POINT THERE'S NOT A ROLE
FOR THE TASK AN OFFICIAL ROLAND
FOR THE TASK FORCE IN THAT
PROCESS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW THINGS OF ALL.
AND THE TASK FORCE WILL SHARE
REPORT SUMMARIZING THEIR
DISCUSSIONS IN DETAILING ANY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON OR BEFORE JANUARY FIFTEENTH
ALTHOUGH WE KNOW THAT YOU PREFER
THE MISSING AS POSSIBLE SO WE'LL
DO OUR BEST TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
THE GOVERNMENT BY DECEMBER THIS
YEAR WE'RE VERY. VERY PROUD OF
THAT.
THE FUTURE THE TASK FORCE AS YOU
KNOW NOW LIES IN THE HANDS OF
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TEN. AND
SHOULD THE BILL BE PASSED TO THE
CHARGING FUNDING OF THE TASK
FORCE WILL BE EXTENDED TO TWENTY
TWENTY NINE AND AT THAT TIME.
OPC WILL TAKE THE REINS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND ADMINISTER THE
TASK FORCE.
ADMINISTER YEAH AN AGREEMENT TO
SUPPORT THE TASK FORCE AND
CONTINUE TO USE FUNDS FROM THE
TENSION IS CRAP COUNT TO SUPPORT
THAT EFFORT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WATCHING THIS BILL AS IT
PROGRESSES AND.
YEAH THE TASK FORCE HOPES TO
CONTINUE SERVING AS AN INDUSTRY
LED BODY. THAT.
INFORMS FISHERIES MANAGEMENT IS
RESPONSIVE TO POLICY ISSUES AND
AS A CONDUIT OF INFORMATION TO
THE FLEET. AND SOME HALF THE
TASK FORCE IN THE ADMIN TEAM I'D
LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN CHOIR AND
CULTURE STONE. AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND.
JUST TO SAY THE TASK FORCE IS
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
CONTINUED LINE OF OPEN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND.
SHOW CREATURE WAS ALWAYS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR JUST A
BIT.
COULD DARE ENTER THE COMPANY
BUYS A COMEDIAN SALMON STILL
TRAPPED WE WELCOME YOU SIR YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROBLEM. I THINK
IS HAVING AN IDEA. THROWING ME
HERE TODAY.
SERMON CHOIR AND.
MISTER STONE THANKS FOR HANGING
IN. ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO TO SERVE A CHOIR AND AND TOM
FOR.
RECEIVING OUR NOMINATIONS FOR
OUR COMMITTEE THOUGHTS WERE
TRYING TO GET OUR COMMITTEE HAS
FILLED OUT AND WE APPRECIATE
YOU.
HELPING. PROCESS THOSE FOR US.
THE CALIFORNIA ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON SEVEN IS STILL HEAD
HAS BEEN ATTENDING THESE FISH
FOR MEETINGS FOR. MANY MANY
YEARS SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE AND WE'VE HAD THE DUBIOUS
ROLE OF REPORTING TO YOU. THE
DECLINE OR SALMON AND STEELHEAD
POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND.
TODAY DON'T HAVE ANY BETTER
NEWS THAN THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO OBSERVE THOSE SIMILAR
DECLINES.
YOU HEARD FROM DOCTOR THIS
ALREADY ON CAL TRIALS.
STATE OR SALMON REPORT THAT WAS
COMPLETED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
HE WOULD IN THE CAR QUITE A
QUITE A GOOD DETAIL WE HAVE
REPORTS AVAILABLE I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN DELIVERED TO YOU
AND YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO.
YEAH GREAT.
ONE MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THOSE
SOME. OF THE SUMMARY THAT I HAD
YOU KNOW IN MY NOTES HERE IS
THAT FIFTEEN OF THE STATE'S
THIRTY TWO SEVEN STILL
POPULATIONS.
ARE EITHER THREATENED
ENDANGERED OR EXTINCT. THINGS
ARE LOOKING GOOD IN THAT REGARD.
THE KLAMATH RIVER.
SPRING RUN CHINOOK SALMON
POPULATION IS NOW UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE NATURAL
FISHERY SERVICE FOR LISTING OF
THE FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT THAT WAS ANNOUNCED IN
FEBRUARY. FOLLOWING THE PETITION
THAT WAS SUBMITTED.
BACK IN NOVEMBER.
AND FINALLY MY NOTES HERE.
TO OUR POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THE THE COASTAL
SHOULDN'T CALL SAM AND. THE
CENTRAL COAST CO SALMON
POPULATION IN THE WINTER AND
STILL AT SEVEN POPULATION ARE
BEING SUSTAINED BY. BROODSTOCK
PROGRAMS NOW IT'S REALLY THE
LAST STAGE BEFORE EXTINCTION AND
IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR BROOD
STOCK PROGRAM AND A HATCHERY.
RAISES ADULTS IN THE HATCHERY IN
ORDER TO PRODUCE TO WHAT ELSE TO
RELEASE BACK INTO THE WILD SO
IT'S. KIND OF A A DIRE SITUATION
FOR THOSE POPULATIONS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT.
BUT THESE CONDITIONS THAT LET
OUR COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
RECOMMENDING TO YOU.
THE SAME EMERGENCY AND I SAY
WERE CONSIDERING MAKING THAT
RECOMMENDATION OR NOT SILLY
MAKING THAT RECOMMENDATION TODAY
WE MET THIS MORNING WE DISCUSSED
THAT AND WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS
MIGHT BE.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
THAT.
BUT THIS KIND OF DECLARATION%
WOULD WOULD TO SPEND SOME
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS AND
ALLOW SOME OF THE RESTORATION
PROJECTS TO PROCEED IN A LITTLE
LITTLE MORE STREAMLINED FASHION.
AND IT ALSO MIGHT ALLOW THE
STATE WATER HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S. WATERS
RIVERS STREAMS WATERSHEDS. AND
THEIR ADDITIONALLY THREATENED
BY.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CHANGING
RAINFALL PATTERNS SO WEIRD.
YOU KNOW WE'RE THE RESILIENCY OF
OUR OUR RESOURCES IS REALLY
BEING IMPERILED RIGHT NOW. IS
BECOMING DIRE.
AS YOU KNOW.
FOR DECADES THE STATE HAS BEEN
INVESTING SIX SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
RESOURCES. RECOVERY EFFORTS FOR
SALMON AND STILL AHEAD ON WE HAD
PROPOSITION FIFTY PASS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO. PROPOSITION EIGHTY
FOUR AND TWO THOUSAND SIX WE HAD
THE PROPOSITION ONE WATER BOTTLE
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND WE ALSO
RECEIVE ON THE ORDER OF TEN TO
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR IN FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
THE PACIFIC COAST OF SOMEONE A
RECOVERY FUND. AND ALL OF THESE
IN TOTAL.
.
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR IS IT REALLY CONSIDERABLE
INVESTMENT PUBLIC FUNDS FOR
THESE RECOVERY EFFORTS AND YET.
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE RESULTS
THAT WE WE EXPECT WE SHOULD BE
SEEING.
SO I'M GONNA JUST PROVIDED.
THERE'S ONE MORE THING.
.
BUDGET COMMITTEE WANTED TO BRING
TO YOUR ATTENTION AND WE HAVE
DONE SO BEFORE THAT THE THE
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
SPECIFICALLY THE OVERSIGHT OF
THESE FUNDING PARTIES AND
DECISIONS IS REALLY BEING
DIMINISHED OVER TIME.
THE TRINITY RIVERS. FEDERAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS YOU KNOW
WAS WAS SEIZED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
FOLLOWING THE ELECTION. OF THIS
PAST YEAR THAT THE FISHERY GRANT
PROGRAM REVIEW COMMITTEE WAS.
PREVENTED FROM MEETING BECAUSE
OF UNSUBSTANTIATED CONFLICT OF
INTEREST ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP BY THE BY THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS.
.
THEN THE ENTIRE.
PROPOSITION ONE EXPENDITURES
THROUGH THE STATE'S WATER SHOULD
BRANCH AND THE.
QUALITY CONSERVATION BOARD
STRICKLAND HAS BEEN PROGRAMS.
HAVE REALLYNO PUBLIC OVERSIGHT
OR INPUT ON THE PRIORITIZATION
OF THOSE GRAHAM PROGRAMS.
DESPITE ITS FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S BEING
EXTENDED SO.
WE REALLY FEEL LIKE OUR.
RESTORATION COMMUNITY AND AND
PRACTITIONERS NEED TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE IN THE OVERSIGHT OF
PROGRAMS.
SO JUST A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE OUR COMMITTEES TO
LIVING YOU TODAY.
WE WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT'S
RECENT OUT REACH TO RESTORATION
LEADERS TO HOST A MEETING
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST THIS YEAR.
UP TO SEEK OUR INPUT ON HOW BEST
DEPARTMENTS SOMEONE A RECOVERY
PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE BETTER
RESULTS.
WE SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET CHANGE PETITION WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A RECENT VERSION OF
THAT BUT THAT WAS SHOWN TO US.
IN JANUARY ON THAT WOULD
ADDRESS STRUCTURAL SHORTFALLS IN
AN INCREASED STAFF POSITIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. SO THEY CAN
FOCUS ON THIS CRISIS AND AND
BRING MORE RESOURCES.
AND WITHIN THAT WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE STAFF POSITION BE
PRIORITIZED TOWARD MORE
STRATEGIC PLANNING. STREAMLINING
OF ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS AND
EXPANDING THE DEPARTMENT'S
CAUSED A MONITORING PROGRAM SO
WE CAN TRACK OUR POPULATIONS
WERE DOING A POOR JOB OF THAT.
WE URGE THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE
STEPS THE DEPARTMENT FISH WALLET
TO TAKE STEPS TO SECURE THE
FUTURE OF THE COASTAL MONITORING
PROGRAM. AND IDENTIFY A FUNDING
STRATEGY THAT WILL ENSURE THE
WORK OF THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM.
CAN CONTINUE ON OUR
UNINTERRUPTED THERE'S BEEN SOME
PROPOSED CHANGES WITH REGARD TO
HOW THE. OBSTACLES OF SOMEONE IN
RECOVERY FUND. COMES IN TO THE%
STATE AND GETS DISTRIBUTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS AND AND. WE'RE NOT
CLEAR ON ON WHAT THOSE CHANGES
ARE. SORT OF SEEKING MORE
INFORMATION THERE.
THEN WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT
OUR STATE'S PUBLIC TRUST
RESOURCES ARE FRESH WATER FISH
AND WILDLIFE SPECIES ARE
PROTECTED. FROM THE NEWLY
FORMING LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
WITH SOUND ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
IN STRONG ENFORCEMENT.
WE THINK THAT STATE AGENCIES
NEED TO CONTINUALLY ASSESS HOW
THEY'RE PERMITTING PROGRAMS. AND
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH IS WORKING
AND BE READY TO ADAPT AS THEY
SEE THAT THEY'RE NOT WORKING AS
WELL AS WE NEEDED TO.
THE RESTORATION FUNDING FROM TAX
REVENUE FROM CANNABIS. NEEDS
TARGET THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE
SUFFERED THE MOST I THINK THOSE
ARE MOSTLY. NORTH COAST IN
CENTRAL COAST WATERSHEDS AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
FUNDS AS THEY COME INAND BUILD
OVER TIME. ARE DIRECTED TO THE
PLACE THAT ARE IMPACTED THE MOST
BY THAT ACTIVITY.
AND AND WE NEED TO IDENTIFY
ACCUMULATIVE LIMIT TO HOW MANY
GROWING UP GO OPERATIONS CAN CAN
CAN WASH IT SUSTAINED WE DON'T
HAVE THAT. THAT CHEMO TO EFFECTS
ANALYSIS AND. WE NEED THAT
BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE.
AND LASTLY WE WE STRONGLY URGE
THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL ALL IF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
WITH OVERSIGHT FROM YOUR
COMMITTEE TO STRENGTHEN YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY
OF RESTORATION PRACTITIONERS. SO
THAT WE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO AND
HELP FIND SOLUTIONS IT'LL.
REVERSE THIS TREND.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INDEED EXTREMELY THOROUGH I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS WILL THAT MIKE.
IN AIR AND SPEAK IN THE END I
WILL COME BACK TO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THAT WORKS FOR FOLKS.
RICHARD OVER TO MIKE WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF THE CAPTAIN SIMMS HIM
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY WELCOME YOU
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU QUICK TO
TALK WITH YOU LAST NIGHT AS
WELL.
WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND MY NAME IS MIKE CRICKETS?
THE. CALIFORNIA SALMON STAMP
COMMITTEE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU. ALL FOR
THE HELP WITH THE REST A RE
AUTHORIZATION SO THEY WERE IN
BUSINESS FOR ANOTHER TEN YEARS
AGO SO. THAT'S GREAT SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP WORKING.
FOR OTHER COMMITTEE IS. LIMITED
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBERS WERE DOWN
THAT NOT VERY MANY PEOPLE
FISHING AND SO THE THE THE MONEY
MONEY WE HAVE TO SPEND IT IS A
LOT SMALLER THAN WHAT IT WAS BUT
WE WOULD. LIKE TO STAY AND
RESTORATION.
AND THAT TRAINING AND SOME OF
THE THINGS WITH THE NET TRAINING
WE'RE TRYING TO. PROBABLY HAVE
THREE AND A HALF MILLION FISH.
TWO OF THE ENHANCEMENT FISH THIS
YEAR. AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT
MANY FISH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PROBABLY.
A LARGE SUM OF THE NET TURNS A
LITTLE BIT AND HAVE MORE.
TRAILERS MAYBE TWO MORE
TRAILERS.
TO CONTINUE WITH WHAT'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL RECENTLY IS. NOT
RELEASING ANY MORE THAN TWO DAYS
IN ANY ONE SITE IN SUCCESSION.
THAT WAY WE KEEP THE PREDATION
DOWN THE FIRST DAY WE'RE GETTING
GREAT RETURNS THE SECOND DAY. IT
GOES DOWN TO A FAIR AMOUNT IN
THE THIRD DAY WE'RE NOT SEEING
ANY OF THOSE FISH BECAUSE WERE
MARKING THEM SO THAT BILL SMITH
IS THE NET WITH THEM A CALL
MYSELF.
WE WANT TO GET A COUPLE MORE
TRAILERS ISSUE IF WE CAN TO HELP
GET THE STRETCH. IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO WE GET THE BEST
SURVIVAL RATE.
OF THE. DAY YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WORD
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WITH IT
WE DID IN THE PAST AS THE NET.
AT THE.
SCREENS AND.
DIVERSIONS WE BUILT IN THE PAST
QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO TUNED TO
SCREEN SHOPS ONE IN RED BLUFF IN
ONE WAY RICA.
AND IN THE RECENT YEARS I
HAVEN'T SEEN MUCH ACTIVITY OR
HEARD MUCH ABOUT IT DID YOU KNOW
WE HAD BACK GOES IN. AND OF IT
ALL THE MORE WILLING AND GET
QUICK MEANT TO BUILD THE SCREENS
TO STOP THE FISH FROM. GETTING
INTO THE PONDS AND WHATEVER YOU
MAY NOT KNOW CRICKET DEER CREEK
IN BUTTE CREEK. WE DID A LOT
THERE THAT REALLY HELP TO INTO
GETTING SOME OF THE RESTORATION
BACK. AND THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
I THINK IN THE COMMITTEE
BELIEVES.
OR A LOT LESS EXPENSIVE AND CAN
BE MORE OR.
THE.
HELP THE RESOURCE MORE. THAN
SPEND A LOT OF MONEY STUDY AND
HOW TO NOT TO DO IT TENNIS SO.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT AND.
YOU KNOW JUST SOME OF THE THINGS
VERY COMMITTED THE.
SAN JOAQUIN WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONTINUE. AS MUCH. OF
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO HAVE SEEN FISH
LIKE WE SAW ON THE SCREEN AND
THE KINGS RIVER THAT WAS A IT
WAS ONE OF THE MAIN TRIBUTARY OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN. THAT YOU KNOW
INTO IT BEFORE FINAL PLAT DAM
WAS OF. THOSE FISH WHEN THEY'RE
LIKE THAT IN.
JUST THE DAM ON THE SAN JOAQUIN.
KILLED A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND RETURNING FISH. THEY
WERE ALL FIXED LIKE THAT WE USED
TO SAY THAT THEY TURNED LEFT AND
WENT SOUTH OF BIG FISH WITH. THE
THOSE ARE THE THINGS IF WE CAN
GET. THAT SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM
BACK ON TRACK WHERE WE WOULD
HAVE. A LOT MORE OPPORTUNITY
FOR.
BECAUSE THERE IS GOOD SPAWNING
AREAS LEFT IN THAT AREA WHERE WE
HAVE DAMS TOO CLOSE TO THE. TO
THE MAIN STEM.
WITHOUT HAVING STEP FISH LADDERS
TO GET THOSE FISH UP TO THIS THE
MITIGATION WITH APACHES IS NOT
AS SUCCESSFUL BY ANY MEANS IS
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE STAYED WITH
A LONG TIME AGO WITH THE FIRST
LETTERS.
SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE. TRYING TO DO
AND WE'RE PRETTY SURE IT'LL HELP
THAT YOU'VE HELPED US WITH IT.
MY AP OR THE ONES THAT ARE ON
THE GROUND DOING THE WORK SO
WE'RE THE ONES YOU NEED TO BE
THINKING YOU IN JUST SO GRATEFUL
YOU TAKE THE TIME TO BE HERE
TODAY.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP PUTTING
SEVEN THE. WATER SO. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR SEMESTER ENDS WAS
FAR.
ALRIGHT LET'S TURN IT OVER TO
AARON FROM IS A SENIOR SCIENTIST
AT OCEANSIDE STRESS WE WELCOME
YOU INTO GOOD AS HE CAN THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
CAN'T.
AND THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. OCEAN SCIENCE
TRUST IS AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT WE ARE NOT A STATE
AGENCY.
AND THAT OUR RELATIONSHIP TO
CALIFORNIA'S FORMALIZED THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA OCEAN RESOURCES
TO URGE A FACTOR COURSE THAT
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND.
OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST IS A
BOUNDARY ORGANIZATION BRINGING
TOGETHER GOVERNMENT ACADEMICS
AND COMMUNITIES USING SCIENCES
ARE GATHERING POINT.
OCEAN OF PERCENT OF COURSE.
WERE REQUIRED TO REPORT ON OUR
ACTIVITIES TO THE STATE IN
VARIOUS FORMS INCLUDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY. WHY AM
HERE?
UNDER UNDER COURSE SO WE HAVE
THE OBLIGATION AND IT'S OUR
MISSION TO MOBILIZE THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA MANAGEMENT AND
POLICY MEANS. WITH RESPECT TO
COSTA NOTIONS. AND WE DO THIS
WORK BY PARTNERING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
ESPECIALLY DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE WHILE SCIENTISTS AND
STAKE HOLDERS. AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF UPDATE
ON SOME OF OUR WORK THAT'S
PARTICULARLY RELEVANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
WOULD LIKE TO AT BUT YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
FOURTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT.
VIEWS AND HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS.
AT FIRST UP ON THE FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT. FASHION
SCIENCE TRUST HAS BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL STAFF AND THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM. TO DEVELOP A
REPORT PROVIDING A SCIENTIFIC
BASIS TO ADVANCE THE STATE'S
ADAPTATION PLANS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COAST NOTIONS. THIS
REPORT IS PART OF THE LARGER
CALIFORNIA FOURTH CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT.
SCIENTIFIC ASSESSMENTS ARE A
REALLY IMPORTANT WAY WE THINK
AND THAT STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CURRENTLY
AFFECTING US AND WHAT WE MIGHT
EXPECT IN THE FUTURE. AND WHAT
WE CAN DO ABOUT IT. OF THE
REPORT WILL INCLUDE TOPICS SUCH
AS FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS SEA LEVEL
RISE AND OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
HEARD ABOUT ALL THESE TODAY. A
PORTLY IT ALSO FOCUSES ON THE
IMPACTS OF THESE CHANGES AND
STRESSORS ON HUMAN HEALTH
COASTAL ECONOMIES AND COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. WITH FOR LOOKING AT
SOLUTIONS ORIENTED LANDS FOR
ADAPTING TO THE CHANGES WE SEE
COMING. THIS REPORT WILL BE
RELEASED IN THE FALL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING IT WITH YOU.
ON THE FMP PEER REVIEW FRIENDS
WEEK CONTINUED TO BE EXCITED TO
PROVIDE A SCIENTIFIC PEER REVIEW
OF FM TEASING CALIFORNIANS.
UNLESS HE LED AN OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL SCIENCE
ADVISORY TEAM REPORT PROVIDING
GUIDANCE ON CONDUCTING AN ATOM.
VIEWS THAT INFORM THE PEER
REVIEW CHAPTER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S ALANA ALAMAIN
MASTER PLAN UPDATE.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS REQUESTED AND
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
FUNDED US TO UTILIZE THIS
GUIDANCE ON TO UPCOMING IN.
VIEWS ON HEARING AND RAT ABALONE
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
BEGINNING WORK ON THESE PRETTY
MUCH IMMEDIATELY.
LASTLY ON HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS
ALTHOUGH THANKFULLY IT'S NOT
SOMETHING IN THAT AND WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN THIS EXACT
MOMENT.
IT CONTINUES I THINK TO BE ON
ON MIND FOR THE FISHING
COMMUNITY FOR ACADEMICS AND FOR
CONSUMERS.
EXCITED ABOUT AND ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HOSTING A WORKSHOP
AND A COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT WILL
PUT. SOME KEY MEMBERS OF STATE
AGENCIES ALL ALONG THE WEST
COAST AND MAIN IN THE ROOM WITH
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS NGOS AND
FISHERMEN.
AND TO PUT THEIR HEADS TOGETHER
AND START TO FIGURE OUT HOW OUR
CURRENT SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDING
OF HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS
ESPECIALLY DEMO ACID.
CAN INFORM THE STATE'S
MONITORING DESIGNED FOR SEAFOOD
SAFETY AS WE SEE THESE THESE
CHANGES COMING.
AND TO CLOSE I JUST LIKE TO
THANK EVERYBODY I AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING US TO SPEAK TODAY.
CALIFORNIA TION SCIENCE TRUST
IS REALLY APPRECIATE OF OUR ROLE
AND OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
STATE AS YOU TACKLE THESE THESE
ISSUES.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A VERY
GRATEFUL.
SEMESTER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR. DURING
TOOK TALK ABOUT I DO I'M. PRETTY
SURE I THINK THERE IS ONGOING
CONCERN.
BUT THE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
MADE FOR HABITAT RESTORATION.
AND IT'S JUST THAT HE HAD SAID
IT'S NOT WORKING.
I AM PARAPHRASING HERE.
WALK ME THROUGH HE SAID THAT IS
IT. NOT CONSULTING WITH THOSE
FOR YOU FOR EXAMPLE YOUR MEMBERS
ARE ON THE GROUND. IS IT NOT
GOING INTO THOSE WHO ARE.
WASHES THEIR MOST IMPAIRED THAT
ARE STILL COLD WATER.
TRIPS WALKS THROUGH THAT YEAH
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT IT IN MY.
BUT JUST TO PUT IN CONTEXT WE WE
HAVE PROBABLY THE MOST MONEY
WE'VE EVER HAD IN THE
RESTORATION OF THE NEED TO
COMMENT PROJECTS IN IT YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT CAME UP AT
THE. MEETING WE HAD WITH DOCTOR
BONHAM ANOTHER'S.
I THINK INDIVIDUALLY WORD WE'RE
DOING REALLY GOOD THINGS THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING SELECTED
AND FUNDED BY THESE FUNDS ARE
ARE REALLY NEEDED AND THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE. BEING IMPLEMENTED
SUCCESSFULLY AND I THINK
INDIVIDUALLY YOU KNOW THEY'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE A STRATEGIC
APPROACH TO IMPLEMENTING THEM I
THINK WE'RE DOING YOU KNOW IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE BREADTH OF.
RESTORATIONNEEDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FROM IN OREGON BORDER ALL
WAY TO TIJUANA INLAND THE
FISHERY GRANT PROGRAM NOW
INCLUDES CENTRAL VALLEY.
PROJECTS.
IT'S A BIG AREA THERE'S A LOT
OF NEED. AND SO WE'RE KIND OF
SEEING A SCATTERSHOT OF PROJECTS
AND. SO ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I THINK THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
SEPARATE LAYERED ECHO THE SAME
CONCERN OR OR OR SENTIMENT WHICH
IS THAT WE NEED BETTER STRATEGIC
PLANNING.
SO WE NEED YOU KNOW STAFF
PEOPLE WITHIN AGENCIES OUT FRONT
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHERE'D
WHERE'D AND WHERE'S THE BEST
PLACE TO MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS
WERE GETTING PROJECTS READY.
IDENTIFYING GEOGRAPHIES THAT
THAT WE CAN INVEST IN THAT OLD
THAT'LL HAVE A LONG TERM STABLE
BENEFIT.
WE TALK ABOUT STRONGHOLDS
THAT'S THAT'S ONE CONCEPT THAT
WE THINK IS IS IS REALLY A GOOD
THING.
.
AND I WOULD SAY. THAT IF WE LOOK
AT THE SACRAMENTO FOR EXAMPLE OR
THE SAN JOAQUIN. IN THE MAIN
STEM IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
BE ADMITS CAN'T TAKE BILLIONS
RIGHT. IN OUR LINE TO AN
INCREASE YOU KNOW AND THE OTHER
THING IS
WE JUST WHAT I THINK WE STARTED
TO SEE SOME SOME RECOVERY ARE
WATERSHEDS ARE. ARE PROBABLY
HEALTHIER NOW THAN THEY WERE A
FEW DECADES AGO BECAUSE OF SOME
THE REGULATIONS THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY AND SO FORTH AND AND SO
ACTUALLY NOW. THAT THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY IS IS IT A GOOD PARTNER
FOR RESTORATION BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LARGE OWNERSHIP OF LAND.
AND SO WE'RE SEEING BETTER
POPULATION RECOVERY THERE. BUT
THEN DROUGHT CANNABIS EX YOU
KNOW COME IN TO KIND OF
UNDERMINED UNDER CUT THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING.
SO WATER IT REALLY IS A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE RIGHT NOW. I
KNOW THE STATE WATER BOARD.
AND THE PARTITION WHILE IF
WATER BRANCH OR OR INITIATING
NEW PROGRAMS TO LOOK STATEWIDE
AT SETTING ENVIRONMENTAL FLOWS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT'S GONNA BE VERY CHALLENGING
WITH ALL THE WATER USERS WE
HAVE.
AND AND SLOW GOING BUT THAT
NEEDS TO BE SUPPORTED WE NEED
TO-IDENTIFY. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THE STREAM FLOWS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE PUBLIC TRUST
RESOURCES THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE
YOU KNOW IT'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AMAZING. YEAH IN AT YOU KNOW
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW I THINK ON
THE ISSUE OF A CANNABIS IS WELL
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
AND I CAN I SPEAK. TO THE NORTH
COAST SIDE ANALYSTS PICK FOR THE
VICE CHAIR BUT.
WHERE WE'VE HAD SOME REAL
CONCERN? IS ONLY A CALF WILL
HAPPEN.
SEE AT.
REPORTER FORESTRY ISSUE FOR
EXAMPLE THREE ACRE CONVERSION
PERMITS RIGHT HIGH THAT. FOLKS
ARE CONVERTING TEN ACRES FIFTY
ACRES AND THERE I NO FOLLOW UP
WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR THAT WOULD EXTEND. THE
SESSION LIMITATIONS FROM TWELVE
MONTHS TO THIRTY SIX MONTHS OUT
SO THAT.
COVERED PART IN FORESTRY CAN GO
AFTER THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE
LEGALLY CLEARED ALL THIS LAND
AND THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO
SIGNIFICANT SEDIMENT FLOWS IN
THE STREETS BECAUSE? TIMBER
INDUSTRY REALLY HAS BEEN.
MAKING INCREDIBLE STRIDES OVER
THE PAST THREE DECADES IN
PARTICULAR. BUT NOW IT'S BEEN
MADE UP WITH.
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF ROE GROWS.
IT UNDER THE MILES OF NEW ROADS
YET PAYING FOR DECADES TO CLEAN
UP THAT MESS UP YEAH. SO.
MORE TO COME ON THAT. ONE WHAT
HE'S.
WE DIDN'T QUITE A BIT OF WORK ON
THEIR NO CREEK WITH A CONSORTIUM
WITH OF RANCHERS AND FARMERS.
WENT TOGETHER WITH THEM THIS IS
SENDING A FREE FLOWING STREAMS
WITHIN HAVE A TEST PHONING IT
WITH THAT. AND ALL IT TOOK WAS
JUST TO GET THE RANCHERS TO TO.
.
IT'S OFF THERE THE HEADWATERS IN
THESE CREEKS SO THAT THE CATTLE
AND HORSES AND WHATEVER WOULD
GET IN AND CAUSE A LOT OF MUD
AND SILT. AND STUFF THAT.
THEY'RE VERY COST EFFECTIVE. AND
IT JUST TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME AND AND COORDINATION YOU
KNOW. THAT FOR I THINK INSTEAD
OF MAJOR PROJECTS IT. TAKES MORE
MONEY PLANNING AND THEY DIDN'T.
GET THE JOB DONE THE FOOD. GET
BACK TO SOME OF THAT TYPE WORK
UNTIL ACTIVE MEASURES RIGHT OFF
OF ME ACTUALLY RIGHT.
I THINK MY.
YOU DON'T THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU NICE WORK OF
ART THANK YOU.
THE LATEST IT WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO OUR. PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION AND WE WELCOME ANYONE IN
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
RIGHT HERE. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
ALL WE ASK IF YOU DON'T MIND THE
STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME
INTO PLEASE COME ON FOR THE MIKE
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR HANGING
WITH US.
HEY. HOW YOU DOING SIR? MY
GLASSES.
WE WELCOME YOU DIRECTOR GAINER.
.
THE SO MUCH TO SAY IN TWO
MINUTES OUR FIRST THING I'D LIKE
TO SAY IS.
THEM TOLD HER HAD A. A REALLY
HELP THE CHINOOK RUNS THIS YEAR.
BEFORE THANKSGIVING AND THEN
AGAIN IN JANUARY. I'M NOT SURE
HOW THE CO SITUATIONS ALONG
ABOUT HIM OR IS IT YOUR GOES ON
BUT THE SURVEY. CREW SOME MORE
CHINOOK IN A SHORTER TIME AND
SCHROEDER REACHES IN NEVER HAD
BEFORE AND THOSE SERVICE STARTED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY.
EXCITING.
.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT. I USE IS
BOUNDED INTO A LITTLE BIT A IT
SEEMS THAT THE FISHER LUSTRATION
GRANT. PROGRAM IS GOTTEN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT DETAILS THAT MAKE
IT REALLY DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER
PROJECTS. WITH SO MANY
LIMITATIONS AND NOT HAVING THE
FLEXIBILITY.
TO USE FUNDS FOR DIFFERENT
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT INSTEAD OF
JUST BEING ABLE TO USE THIS PART
FOR THAT IN THIS MUCH FOR THAT.
AND ALSO. IN NORTHERN MEN TO SEE
NO.
SOUTHERN HUMBLED TO OTHERS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH A LOST CAUSE
FOR US TO REFUSE ALL REDWOOD
FOREST. AND THERE IS PLANNING A
THERE'S A CO RECOVERY PLAN BOTH
EVIL RICHARD DELIVER TRIBUTARIES
AND. AND FOR YOU SAW NOT THE
LOST COAST FORESTED OR NEIGHBOR.
OF A LOT OF GOOD PROJECTS A LOT
OF GOOD WORK HAS BEEN DONE BY
THE OTHER HAND THERE'S BEEN.
SOME PROJECTS I KNOW THERE'S A
LOST CAUSE FOR US PUT IN THAT
WAS MULTI BENEFITS I INCLUDING
THE STREAMS ROADIE
COMMISSIONINGS AND ROAD UPGRADES
FOR MANAGEMENT OF THE LAND. WON
THE FACTORS NEED TO BE TAKEN THE
PLACE AND. IS TO ENCOURAGE THE
RESTORATION RELATED ECONOMY OF
THESE AREAS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED THE SKILLS AND AND AND
THESE ARE THE FUTURE AREAS TWO.
OF THE SOUTH FORK EEL COURSES
EVERY FUTURE AND.
COME OVER WHEN I FED STREAM IT
JUST A.
THAT MAN IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS ALSO I
THINK IS IMPORTANT HERE AND.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION RULE
COMPREHENSIVE. THING AND THEN
THEN AND THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
PRESS. NEEDS TO HAPPEN WHICH IS
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS AND POLICY
CHANGES YEAH.
VERY GOOD BUT.
.
BECAUSE.
AND THE SECOND CODE IS EASY AND
THERE ARE PROBLEMS THAT SEEMTO
REAL BIG PROBLEMS WITH CANVAS.
BUT A LOT OF THE THINGS ARE
GOING OUT AND ENCOURAGES A
BIGGER PEOPLE HAVING HEAVIER
IMPACT BECAUSE OF THE MONEY THAT
THEY NEED TO PUT IN TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE IN THE SOUL. AGRARIAN
CULTURE GOES BACK HUNDREDS OF
YEARS REALLY. BUT.
THE SMALL. FARMER IN MULTI.
WAYS OF EARNING A LIVING IN
RURAL AREA AND SAYS IT NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT TO GET THE
MAXIMUM CHANGE IF PEOPLE DO WANT
TO FISHERIES IN THE RUSSIANS.
OUT OF ITS.
EDUCATION OF THE WHOLE
POPULATION I JUST A SECOND
NICELY IN WHICH MAKES A GREAT
POINT WE JUST HAD A. A LARGE
HEARING OVER THREE HUNDRED
TURNED OUT. AND YOU CAN I.
A WEEK AGO TODAY. IN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN REGARDS TO
COMPLAINTS ABOUT ALL THE NEW
WATER RULES IN ALL THE LAND USE
RULES IS. THAT THE COST OF
PERMITTING IN THAT'S A AN ISSUE
THAT WE ARE DEFINITELY LOOKING
AT AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING THERE FOR HIS YOU ACTUALLY
WRITE PARTICULAR SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS WE WELCOME YOU SIR AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT TO ME.
HI I'M MINDING IT MIKE MITCHELL
A. CALIFORNIA DOLLAR FISHMAN US
CENSUS CO DRAGGER DOESN'T MAKE
US. TWO THINGS THANKS TO MIKE
FOR THAT DISASTER BILL. AND LONG
TIME SAYS THAT THAT AFTERNOON AT
THE SCHOOL WAS IN A RANGE THAT
YOU SPOKE. OF GOD WHAT HAS
WORKED BETTER FOR THAT FINGERING
WEIGHT WITH THE HOW THAT BILL I
THANK YOU FOR THAT THERE TOO
MEANS A LOT TO ME. BECAUSE I'M
WILL BE ABLE TO TRANSFER MY
PERMIT NOW IT OUGHT TO BE DEAD.
FOR.
.
THE.
GET OUT COMMERCIAL FISHING.
A FEW OTHER THINGS BUT THERE IS
ONE THING THAT I WANT TO POLICE
TO PUSH ON NASA. VESSEL.
FOR THE LENGTH OF THE SAME SIZE
OR FOR LESSER CAPABILITY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT LEAVE THAT LANGUAGE IN
THERE. BECAUSE. I ALSO WORKED A
LOT OF THEM BY MELLISA WE WANT
TO KEEP THIS A FRIDGE WE FISHERY
TO WAGES AND NOW. THE FLOORS.
.
HOW BIG THE BOATS ARE? AND THEY
WERE THE THERE'S A LOOPHOLE THAT
WE FOUND OUT WHAT WITH CRAP
TRANSFERS THERE WAS. WITH BUTCH
SPOTS IN THEIR BOATS MAKING
BIGGER. AND IT SEEMS LIKE. WE'VE
KNOWN EVEN TOUCHED ON AND NO ONE
KNEW ABOUT. BOTH WOULD.
MAKE UP A GUY COULD MAKE THE
BULLS BIGGER QUITE A BIT BIGGER
TWICE AND WHAT NOT TWICE BUT A
THIRD BIGGER OR MORE. THAN THEY
WOULD HAVE IT SURVEYED AND THEN
THEY SEND THE SURVEY TO. THE
COAST GUARD THE COAST GUARD.
DOCUMENTS THAT VESSEL AT. TEN
FEET LONGER FIFTEEN FEET LONGER
WHATEVER THEY SEND THAT
DOCUMENTATION FISHING GAME
FISHING AND LOOKS AT THAT
DOCUMENTATION OKAY THIS VESSEL
IS CUT OFF FIFTY FOOT PERMIT ON
IT OR WHATEVER WILL IN ESSENCE
ME THAT BUT WHEN WE HAD A FORTY
FOOT. PERMIT WHEN THEY STARTED
BUT THEY MADE IT BIGGER. THAN
OUT THAT AUTOMATICALLY JUMPED UP
TEN FEET OR FIFTEEN FEET OR EVEN
BIGGER THAN THAT AND NOW YOU GOT
A BIG BOAT THERE THAN FISHING
GAMES OR SO CASES. AND THEY JUST
LOOK AT THE PAPERWORK AND THAT'S
ALL THEY NEED TO DO. AND.
TO ME I WOULD LIKE TO SEE OF OF
THAT VESSEL BE A VESSEL OF THE
SAME. SIZE OR LESSER CAPABILITY
THAT THAT BEAUTIFUL PERSON ONCE
A BIT MAKE THAT BOTH BIGGER
THAT'S FINE BUT WHEN THEY
TRANSFER THAT PERMITS GONNA BE.
TO A BOAT OF WHEN THEY STARTED
WITH THAT PERMIT YOU KNOW IF IT
WAS A FORTY FOOT PER MEADOW ALL
OF THEM BECAUSE A LOT OF A
LOT OF BIG BOATS AND A CRAB
SEASON. GRAPHIC THREE NOW THAT
THAT WEREN'T THERE BEFORE
BECAUSE THEY MADE A BOLD MUCH
BIGGER AND THEY GET TO SELL
THEIR PERMITS AT THAT SIZE BUT
WHATEVER THEY MADE THEIR BOATS.
UP THAT LATE THEY MADE THE BALLS
INTO SOUL THEY COULD GAIN FOR
TEN FIFTEEN FEET ON THEIR
PERMITS AND THAT'S A PERMIT THAT
THEY SELL. PERMIT THAT THEY
STARTED WITH ACTUALLY I I HAVE.
A WHOLE LIST OF FOLLOW UPS AND
KEEPING AN EYE JUST I WROTE THAT
DOWN TO WILL DEFINITELY FOLLOW
UP ON THIS THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU
OKAY AFTER I WAS TOLD THAT
FISHMAN A VERY CREATIVE. AND.
.
A VERY CREATIVE MAYBE TOO MUCH
CREATE A.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE AND IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU. BACKED
ENOUGH THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN SIR HAVE YOU BEEN DOING.
WORKING ALL RIGHT BUT JUST A
QUICK ONE ON THAT ONE THEM
TYPICAL I'M A FISHERMAN FROM A
HALF MILLION BY.
WAY MORE IT MADE. YOUR DAY IN
SHIPS WE WANT TO KEEP UP WITH
THOSE WILD STUFF.
RIGHT DOWN. GENERALLY WILL HELP
THE NATION NOT BECAUSE YOU CAN
SAY.
BUT THIS GREEN YELLOW AND RATE.
FOLLOWING THE WILDS IN THE BODY
CAN WE GO TO MOVE IT FROM THAT
SIDE AND THEN THE WILES MOVIES
AND THEN WE MOVED FROM THE ON.
THAT TO CRACK AND CONFUSION.
ALSO TO STOP THE ARGO. A LOT OF
THE POINTS.
ONE THING I ALWAYS DO IT WILLOW
SITTING HERE THIS PROPOSITION
ONE.
WE PUT NOLA'S MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND TO RESTORING THE DELTA IT
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT
WITH BIG GOLD DAME CONNELL. IT'S
GOING TO PUMP THE WATER OR WHY.
AS IN THIS SORT OF QUITE A LOT
OF LIKES TO DO A DAMN MONEY.
YEAH. WE GO TO CHECK THE KNOWING
OF THE GOD DAMN PROPOSITION ONE.
TOWARD A DAY SELLING ALL OF THE
ACTION IN CLEANING PLANT.
IT'S TAKEN US NOT FOR OUR COME
ON HERE TO BE UP TO OR WHAT ON
BLABBER KNOWN ABOUT YOU DIDN'T
TO HIS. AND FOR THE FAMOUS EVEN
UNDER AND FIFTY MILLION BUT I
THINK IT'S A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO CYPRUS. RIGHT.
DOOMED WITH HIS LOGIC NAIL.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO STOP BRADEN
AND GROWN UP MEN'S. YOU KNOW
THAT'S ONE SEGMENT FOOTBALL I
BOMB AND SNAIL AND THINK IT
WORKED A AT IT. YOU WANT TO DO
THE MATH.
LIST FOR ALL NIGHT OUT BROUGHT
SOME OF THAT ONE.
THE MOTION PASSES. AND I JUST
GOT TERRIBLE AT HEARING YOU WILL
LIST THE FIREARMS AGE COMING ON.
THE MARKETS HAD STARTED IN
CANADA AND DESTROYED WATERS ON A
MUSCLE FILED. WITH THE COUNT OF
THE MOLLY CASTED COMES FROM.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO GET ANOTHER
INDUSTRY STARTED WE WERE UNDER
THE SUN SIGN BANNER.
SO I GOT BACK TO WHAT LORI FREE
SAID WE NEED TO LOOK AT LARGE
NUMBERS.
YOU KNOW I FOUND OUT WHAT A
GIVEN NEAR FULL HUNDRED PARTS
PER MILLION DISAPPROVE IT BUDDY.
THERE ARE.
I YEAH I WOULD HAVE REALLY OKAY
HEY WATCH OUT I'M NOT GONNA GO.
I DO NOT CUT MY LOVE GO EVEN AT
THIRTY SECONDS AKA THIRTY SECOND
SERMON. WE MORE BABIES JOAN AND
SOME WRONG DIRECTION AREA.
BEFORE SHAPES TODAY AND WENT TO
A WEEK I WORK STING CHIN. NATURE
OF THE FORCE YESTERDAY AND. FROM
BEING STYLE A JURY BY GRADE THE
WIND AROUND SALMON AND STUCK
THEM IN NEW ZEALAND.
NOW IF YOU CHECK VIA. THE
GENETICS BY CHALLENGING. ROAD
THAT WILL BRING IT BACK IT'S NOT
THE SAME GOD DAMN FISH. YEAH WE
GOT A WHOLE DIFFERENT ECOLOGY AN
AREA. AND WE STILL CHASING THAT
ORIGINAL STAIN FACTOR THESE
FIRST TO TRY DOING WELL WITHOUT
US IN A RANT RIGHT. BUT
CHANGING.
FOR A COOL ONE IT WELL.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY THE BOYS FROM
WASHINGTON.
COME UP WITH IT. RESULT TO WHAT
WE SHOULD START LOOKING AT THAT
NOW AND I APPRECIATE IN BY THE
WAY. WE ALWAYS LOVE IT WHEN
YOU'RE HERE PAT AS YOU WERE
COMING UP AND YOU WERE FIRED
AWAY IT'S THE BEST THAT SOME OF
THE BEST TESTIMONY SO
DISTRESSING THANK YOU. BUT JUST
REAL QUICK ON THE ISSUE OF. THE
OTHER ITEM. ALSO AND I KNOW THAT
THE DRUG HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THE COLOR CODED SYSTEM WHEN IT
COMES AWAY ALSO. WE'RE ALSO
GONNA BE PROVIDING THAT MOVING
FORWARD LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
WITHIN THE OMNIBUS BILL TO ALLOW
THE DIRECTOR TO HAVE TEMPORARY
CLOSURE.
CRABBING AREAS DURING CRAB
SEASON WHEN WHALES ARE PRESENT
TO CURRENTLY THE DIRECTOR
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
TEMPORARY CLOSURE. IN IT WOULD
BE BAD SO THAT THAT'S THE OTHER
PIECE THAT WE NEED TO BE ON THE
MOVE AND BECOME MORE NIMBLE ON
IN THE FLEA IS SUPPORTING THAT.
AND I'M WITH YOU ON THE ISSUE OF
TUNNELS SO.
WHEAT IT SO THAT'S A BIG ONE TO
WORK ON THE ASSIGNMENT. YA'LL
YEAH THERE IS LITTLE PAULA YEAH
SO WE'RE GOING TO GET TO KNOW A
BODY GETS A BOX. THE BOYS ALIAS
SECOND THE MONEY TO MATCH WHAT
WE PUT IN AND.
HOLD ON IT GO HEY GOOD TO SEE
YOU BEEN BUILT OR PUT IN. THE
THE
WATERS OFF CALIFORNIA IN RECENT
YEARS. AND THAT NEW OFFSHORE OIL
WELLS OR SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
PLANNED FOR THE FUTURE. ON UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION UNDER
OPENING NEW FEDERAL LEASES.
IN REALITY ACCORDING TO
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION DATA
ANALYZED BY THE FRACTURE CRACKER
ALLIANCE. ON STATE OIL AND GAS
REGULATORS APPROVED FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT NEW OFFSHORE OIL WELLS IN
STATE WATERS UNDER EXISTING
LEASES IN LOS ANGELES. INVENTOR
A COUNTIES. ALSO.
ERROL WATERS OFF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED AND THREE. SEPARATE
FRACKING OPERATIONS. THAT THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED UNDER EXISTING
FEDERAL LEASES. AND THAT'S
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY THREE IN
TWO. THOUSAND THIRTEEN. AND THIS
INFORMATION WAS REVEALED. BY A
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
REQUEST BY THE SO SHADED PRESS
BACK THAT DAY WAS EXPOSED BACK
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. SHOW ONE THING I'D
LIKE TO GET ACROSS TO EVERYBODY
HERE TODAY. IS THAT NEW OFFSHORE
OIL WELLS ARE ALREADY DONE FACT
IN CALIFORNIA THEY BEEN. RB DONE
FAQ FOR MANY YEARS. AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
PASS LEGISLATION. DRESS SCENE
STOPPING NEW. DRILLING
FACILITIES AND THAT'S SP EIGHT
THREE FOUR N. A. B. WHAT IS IT
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
BUT THOSE THOSE.
BAND NEW PIPELINES. AND PEERS
IN WARS THAT WOULD GO TO STATE
WATERS RACE WOULD I THINK APPLY
TO BOTH THE STATE BORDERS AND TO
THE FEDERAL WATERS. WHERE'S THE
INFRACTION ANDERSEN WASH OR OILS
WELLS BEING IMPLEMENTED. CAN'T
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I'M
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE YOU'RE HERE
EVERY YEAR AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE
LAST NIGHT AS WELL.
HEY GUYS WERE ALMOST SET WERE A
GOOD EVENING. SELL ADS IN THE
PAPER HANGING WITH THE ENTIRE
TIMES GOOD TO SEE YOU. HIGH.
ALEXIS JACKSON AT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. I WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE ENDS WILL TAKE
YOUR TIME JUST SITTING IN THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY BEEN
WONDERFUL PARTNER.
ON ALL ISSUES HERE RELATED TO
WELLS ENTANGLEMENTS JUST WANNA
PLEASE PASS OUR SINCERE THANKS
THANK YOU HAVE FOR THEM.
JUST WANNA TAKE KNOWLEDGE THAT
COMMENTS IN THE TESTIMONIES
TODAY I I THINK THERE'S A
GENERAL CONSENSUS THAT. CLIMATE
DRIVEN CHANGES ARE IMPACTING OUR
MARINE ECOSYSTEMS AND THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SUPPORT. AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE THESE CHANGING OKAY
OCEAN CONDITIONS IT'S GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT WE
START TO BUILD INNOVATIVE AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT ALLOW US
TO MORE FREQUENTLY. AT COLLECT
INFORMATION TO MARTY'S RESOURCES
ALLOWS TO COLLECT HIGHER QUALITY
DATA AND ALSO THAT WE'RE
EXPLORING MORE ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT FRAMEWORKS. AND LISA
DAMROSCH.
HIGHLIGHTED OF REALLY IMPORTANT
MECHANISM THAT EXISTS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHICH IS THE
EXEMPTED FISHING PERMIT PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE SORT OF ON
THE WATER EXPERIMENTATION THAT
REALLY NEEDED. TO EXPLORE THESE
NEW INNOVATIONS. EXCEPT WE STILL
DON'T HAVE THIS PROGRAM AT THE
STATE LEVEL FROM AND SO THE
CONSERVANCY DOES REMAIN
ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT IS ALL DAY
TODAY WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL AND THEN THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ALL DAY AS WELL HAVE.
MY NAME IS JEFF CHESTER I'M FROM
MONTEREY CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR FOR
AND SENIOR SCIENTIST FOR OCEANIC
WHICH IS AN INTERNATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. OUR
MOTTO IS SAVE THE OCEANS AND
FEED THE WORLD.
THANK YOU JIM ACQUIRE AND A PEN
AND VICE CHAIR STONE FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP TO PROTECT
OUR COASTLINE FROM OIL DRILLING
PROTECT WILDLIFE IN COASTAL
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES.
BUT IT'S GREAT ALSO TO JOIN
FORCES WITH CALIFORNIA FISHERMEN
TO OPPOSE OIL DRILLING AND AND
PARTICULARLY PC FFA WHICH OF
COURSE WOULD BE A DEVASTATING TO
OUR FISHERIES WILDLIFE AND AND.
AN ECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING THE OMNIBUS
FISHERIES BILL ARE THIS YEAR.
ON THE ISSUE WILL INTEGUMENT SO
SHE AND ANOTHER GROUPS BROUGHT
THIS ISSUE TO THE STATE'S
ATTENTION THREE YEARS AGO IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. I'VE
PERSONALLY BEEN A MEMBER OF THE
DUNGEONS CRAB FISHING YOU'RE
WORKING GROUP. FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS WHICH I BELIEVE.
DESPITE A FEW TOUGH MOMENTS HAS
ACTUALLY MADE GREAT STRIDES
TOWARDS.
AND DEVELOP NEW TOOLS AND A AND
A CONFERENCE A FRAMEWORK FOR
ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TESTING THE
THIS WHOLE RAMP UP PROGRAM WITH
THE REGULAR GREEN.
THEY WERE MAKING EXCITING
PROGRESS WERE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS WELL CAN
GROUP IN BEING AN ADVISORY
BODY TO THE DIRECTOR THERE.
AND WE DO WE DO ASK ALSO THAT
YOU DO INCLUDE.
THE THE SEA TURTLES OR IF IT'S
PHYSICALLY LEATHERBACK SEA
TURTLE WHICH IS THE THE MOST
IMPERILED ENDANGERED SPECIES
ENTANGLED IN CRAB GEAR.
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S ALSO THE
STATE RUNNER UP TELL OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
THAT SPECIES AS WELL. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH A CRAB
TRAP AND THEN THE WORKING GROUP
TO WORK TOWARD SOLUTIONS THERE.
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE GEAR
MARKING PROVISIONS JUST BRIEFLY
ON THE EDGE OF THE PROVISIONS.
WE SUPPORT A SMALL SCALE TO
STABLE FISHERY THERE.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS IN THE
COURT TO CONTINUE.
DISCUSSION TO ENSURE ONGOING
SUSTAINABILITY. AND AND A ON THE
ISSUE OF THE THE THE SWORD FISH
IN THE DRIFT GILL AT ISSUE WE DO
REMAIN DEEPLY TROUBLED. BY THE
BY CATCH CONTINUING ENOUGH.
FEDERAL FISHERIES.
THIS IT DOES CUT DEPARTMENT LED
EFFORTS TO IMPLEMENT MONITORING
HARD CAP SOME BI CATCH AND BUY
OUTS BUT ALL THOSE EFFORTS HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY STALLED. AND
SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO FIND
A SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM AND WE
LIKE TO ASK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT WITH
THAT.
.
AND THEN LASTLY.
THE SENTIMENT WHERE YOU'VE BEEN
YOU'VE BEEN ASKING A LOT ABOUT
THAT STARTING ISSUE WE'VE BEEN
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THAT A
HISTORY THAT I WANTED TO OFFER
JUST THE PERSPECTIVE THAT.
DURING A NINETY SEVEN PERCENT
DECLINE.
OF OVER FISHING ON TOP OF A
NATURAL DECLINE IS A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER WE WIN THEN CANNERY
ROW.
IT HAPPEN AGAIN WE STILL YET TO
SEE THE MANAGEMENT REFORMS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO PREVENT
SOMEWHERE THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
SO ANYWAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALL YOUR ALL YOUR GREAT WORK
AND.
AND AND AND AS FOR BEING A
LEADER ON OIL DRILLING AND IT
REALLY MEANS A LOT TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP WHICH WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND.
AND EVERYONE WHO CARES ABOUT
EATING GOOD SEAFOOD THAT'S FROM
FROM OUR LOCAL WATER SLIPPING
ALL OVER JEFF'S NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE TODAY. PERSPECTIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON COKE PROFESSIONAL
SEAFOOD HARVESTS FOR AN AREA OF
WHAT I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY WE TALKED ABOUT OPEN OCEAN
OFF THE PORCH. WHO TALKED ABOUT
AND IT'S INTERESTING THEY
TALKING MILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO MAKE? FULL
YOU HAVEN'T. GIVEN ONE FOUGHT
YET THEY TOLD US SPECIALLY. TO
THE SMALL BOWL. OF FISHERMEN
THAT FISH ALONG THE COAST FROM
WALL SAY FROM THE SHORE OUT TO
TWO BALLS OF SAY TEN MILES.
EFFICIENT RENEWABLE SUSTAINABLE
FISHERIES A SUPPLY OUR LOCAL
FISH MARKETS. THEY SERVE FOR THE
PUBLIC. AND WHAT THESE PEOPLE
ARE DOING AS A COMMENT ON WHAT
THESE PIE IN THE SKY IDEAS WERE
FACING ONE ON THE SANTA BARBARA
CHANNEL RIGHT NOW. OF TWO
THOUSAND ACRES AND THEY WANT TO
PUT A RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
BEST HOW ABOUT TROLL GIRLS.
WITHOUT ASKING US FIRST.
AND NOW WE'VE SAID NO WHAT. WE
CAN'T PUT A TERRIBLE WILL BE OUT
OF BUSINESS WILL PULL WE'D NOT
AGAINST THE. OPEN OCEAN ALL
CULTURE BUT HERE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES. AND THEY BOTH TOLD ME
THAT HERE'S THE PROBLEM WE SPOKE
YOU SUPPORT THIS OPEN OCEAN OFF
OF CULTURE BUT WHERE ARE WE
GOING TO PUT IT THAT IS NOT
GONNA. JUST PLACE ORIGINAL
FISHERMEN THAT ARE ALREADY
FISHING. AND THERE'S NOTHING IN
ANY OF THE PERMIT PROCESS THAT
SAYS. THAT BEFORE A PERMIT CAN
BE ISSUED THEY SHOULD TALK TO
THE LOCAL FISHERMEN IN THAT AREA
AND GET THEIR APPROVAL OF WHERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE BECAUSE THEY'D
ILLYANA WORSE. YOU CAN'T COME
JUST DISPLAY A CERTAIN. ERA SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S POSSIBLE TO
DO IT WOULD BE A GOOD STEP IN
THE FUTURE. TO HAVE IT IN THE
PERMIT PROCESS THEY GO THROUGH
FOUR OR FIVE DIFFERENT PERMITS.
AND THEIR THEIR PR PEOPLE ARE
EXPERTS IN CONNING THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHEN THEIR OWN
BIOLOGIST SAYS DON'T PUT IT OFF
ALONG THE BEACH IN THIS AREA.
KISSER ADD THAT GOT UP THERE.
AND SO I DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN IN OUR AREA AND I'M GOING
TO. DO EVERYTHING I CAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THAT'S WHY I
DO KNOW I'M GRATEFUL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE THAT AS
WELL.
GOOD EVENING.
HI DOING GOOD MY NAME IS SCOTT
DYLAN AND HIS I'M A COMMERCIAL
SALMON CRAB FISHERMEN OUT OF BUT
A GOOD DAY. I'VE BEEN SALMON
FISHING SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND I BEGAN OR WAS
SUPPOSED TO BEGIN CRAB FISHING
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN.
DURING THE LEAD UP FROM TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN I HAD
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT IN
BUILDING AND PERMITTING
OUTFITTING ABOUT.
AND.
I WAS READY TO GO NOVEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE CRAB DUE TO
DEMOTE GAS AND WE'RE NOT READY
TO GO FOR US. AND BEING NEW TO
THE BUSINESS AND HAVING SUCH AN
OUTLAY TO BE INVOLVED IN THAT
BUSINESS AND HOPING FOR A. WAY
OF LIFE FOR MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY.
ON. ENTIRE LIVELIHOOD WAS PUT ON
HOLD AND. I WAS FORCED TO TAKE
ON OTHER SIDE JOBS AND. RELY AND
GENEROSITY FROM FAMILY AND IT'S
BEEN AN UP HILL BATTLE EVER
SINCE THEN AND I'M JUST NOW
BEGINNING TO CALL MYSELF OUT OF
THE MOUNTAIN OF DEBT THAT I PILE
DURING THAT PERIOD. AND I WAS
JUST HOPING THAT YOU GUYS WOULD
CONSIDER GIVING SOME OF THE
NEWEST FISHERMAN. AND A SHOT AT
SOME OF THOSE RELIEF MONIES AS
WELL SELLERS SO I'D WANT TO TAKE
ANYMORE OF YOUR TIME EVERYBODY'S
READY TO GO HE DISSES SO HOW
MANY. IF YOU LOOK HOW MANY
MONTHS FOR YOU AT WORK COULD YOU
SAY. LET'S SAY FROM NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH UNTIL MARCH NINTH
CHEESE. YES.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE STRESSFUL
RACIST IT'S AWFUL. YEAH I DON'T
THINK THAT THE BANK GIVES ANY
OR THE COUNTY IN PROPERTY TAXES
AND WE STILL HAD TO EAT DURING
THAT TIME SO IS. THERE LIKE I
SAID A VERY STRESSFUL TIME HELL
ABSOLUTELY IN WERE SOME FOR YOU.
I LIVE IN PETALUMA. OKAY AND
FISH OUT OF THE DECK OF A HOME
REALLY YEAH.
THANKS FOR LISTENING. UNGRATEFUL
AND THANK YOU FOR COMING OVER
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR STORIES WELL. OKAY YEAH
GOOD IDEA THINKING.
HAVE YOU DONE MANY MANY FEDERAL
AID TO ANIMATE COMMERCIAL CRAVIN
SALMON FISHERMAN ON A SMALL
VESSEL HAD BEEN A GOOD DAY.
I LIVE IN THE MOTTO. I HAVE A
FAMILY THERE.
THREE KIDS AND NOT BY MY PERMIT.
OCTOBER OF TWENTY THIRTEEN.
EXPECTING THE FISH.
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN AND HAD
TO WAIT TILL I THINK IT WAS
APRIL EARN.
APRIL FIFTEENTH IS LIKE THAT
APRIL TWENTIETH. AND IT CREATED
A LOT OF HARDSHIP.
.
NO ONE SENT A SAM AND DISASTER
PREVIOUS YEARS THEY BASED.
APPLICATIONS ON.
PREVIOUS CATCH HISTORY.
I DON'T HAVE ANY PREVIOUS CATCH
HISTORY. I HAVE CATCH HISTORY
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR HIGH.
SO ANY HELP WOULD BE GRATEFUL.
WHAT?
WHAT CAN BE DONE FOR US YOUNGER
GUYS GETTING INTO IT? AND.
WITHOUT ANY HISTORY.
THEY'RE ALWAYS TO WRITE TO ME
IT'S JUST IT'S. NOT GONNA HELP
RIGHT.
SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR.
WHAT YOU'VE DONE? FOR THE VISIT
DISASTER RELIEF.
AND HOPEFULLY THAT.
THINGS WILL PAN OUT FOR
EVERYONE EQUALLY ANY
FRUSTRATIONS PLEASE CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG THAT. YOU GO TO A
RESTAURANT YOU'RE GO INTO A.
GROCERY STORE RIGHT IN YOU SEE
IT THERE YOU THINK EVERYTHING'S
FINE BUT THEY HAD NO IDEA. THE
CHALLENGES AND SUFFERING IS
BEHIND THAT PARTICULAR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IT'S JUST BEEN BRUTAL
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T
ACQUIRE ALL THE GEAR YOU KNOW
OUT THAT THE BOAT TO. FAIL TO DO
THE SAME SALMON CRAB FISHING.
AND THEN TO HAVE THE DELAY.
A GOOD BIT OF HARDSHIP ON THE
FAMILY SO.
BUT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF HELP ABSOLUTELY
HOW OLD YOUR KIDS.
TEN. EIGHT AND THREE AND A HALF
YOU ARE BUSY YES THERE YOU GO.
BEING A COMMERCIAL FISHERMAN I'M
UP IN FORT BRAGG RIGHT NOW AND
ONLY. IT'S.
IT'S TOUGH.
SO I'M GRATEFUL IN ANY TIME AT
THE DRIVE TO THE NEVADA NEAR AS
IT IS NINETY SIX MONTHS. THAT'S
NOT ANY FUN YEAH ABSOLUTELY ONE
JUST THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. AND IT IS SO
PERSONAL RIGHT. ANGRY FOR
FEATURING STORY GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THE END AND
WAS TAKING NOTES WITH BOTH
YOU'RE SPEAKING BY THE WAY. AS
WELL SO THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US.
VIVIEN HELLO WILL PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS THAT IS I WORK FOR
THAT GROUP AND SALMON HABITAT
POLICY WORK.
AND SOME OF THE THINGS I SAY
TODAY MIGHT BE INDIVIDUAL
OPINIONS AND NOT NECESSARILY OF
THE GROUP. WE WELCOME.
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ONE
OF THE CRITERIA FOR OUR NEW GUYS
YOU KNOW WHO HAD DISASTERS IN
CRAB.
IF THEY ARE PERMITTED THEY
BOUGHT HAD CATCH HISTORY THAT
MIGHT HELP.
DONNA.
WASHINGTON STATE IS PHASING OUT.
OCEAN PEN RAISING OF ATLANTIC
SALMON THEY HAD A BIG. DISASTER
UP THERE APPEND BROKE RELEASING.
A LARGE NUMBER OF ATLANTIC
SALMON WHICH COMPETE WITH THEIR
NATIVE SALMON RUNS. AND ALSO HAD
A VIRUS.
SO THEY'RE PHASING OUT WE'VE
OPPOSED OCEAN PEN RAISING OF
SALMON. IN CALIFORNIA ALL ALONG.
THE. FAR NORTH COAST RIVERS ARE
ALL SENTIMENT IMPAIRED. OUR RUNS
OR NOT RECOVERING ROBUSTLY
THEY'RE HANGING ON. AND
DECLINING. OVERALL FOR SALMON.
THE TIMBER WENT DOWN WITH THE
FISHERIES. NOW SEE WE HELPED
WRITE THE WORDING IN THE FOREST
PRACTICES ACT FOR MAINTAINING
QUALITY FOREST PRODUCTS.
WE DON'T HAVE A THIRTY TWO INCH
SAW LOGS NOW ALL THOSE MILLS ARE
CLOSED WE HAVE QUALITY FORCE
PRODUCTS MOUNTAINS OF WOODCHIPS
GOING TO JAPAN. THE IRONY IS
HALF THE YEAR THEY CAN'T GET OUT
THE HOME WILL BE ENTRANCE
BECAUSE OF THE MUD RIGHT. TO WE
HAVE DREDGING IT EVERY YEAR THE
MARINAS ARE MUDDIED IN. WHICH.
WE HAVE A MODEL.
THE COAST GUARD BOAT HAD TO MOVE
TO ANOTHER SLIPPED. ALONG WITH
THE FISHING BOATS IN THE MARINA
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET THE
PERMITS YET TO DREDGE THE
MARINA.
CAUSNG SAFETY HAZARD IN THE
CHANNEL.
SO CUMULATIVE IMPACTS ARE
COMPOUNDING IMPACTS. FOR SAM AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS TO
HAVE THE RESILIENCY TO RESPOND
TO THESE.
COMBINING INSULTS.
TO THEIR SURVIVAL.
AND SO. DATE ON.
YOU DON'T NEED THAT HELP.
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACTS FROM
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES OR CANVAS OR
WHATEVER BUT IT'S A COMBINATION
OF THINGS. OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
DIRECTORS JUST PILED UP. ON THEM
GIVEN THIRTY CAN'T RESPOND
EASILY.
SO THE STOCK NOW FALL RUN AND
WIN AROUND WE WORKED SO HARD TO
BRING THAT WENT AROUND BACK FROM
THE VERGE OF EXTINCTION. ONLY TO
HAVE NINETY PERCENT NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE RUN KILL TWO
YEARS IN A ROW AND EVERY TIME I
HEAR PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THEIR
SPEAKING IN PASSIVE VOICE. LIKE
THIS JUST HAPPENED IT JUST
HAPPENED TWO YEARS IN A ROW NO.
THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN JAIL FOR
KILLING THOSE TWO RUNS TWO YEARS
IN A ROW.
AND YET WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
LIKE BOTHER HIM AT ALL.
WHEN YOU STRING GAUGES MONEY
FOR STRING GAUGES WE NEED
MINIMUM FLOWS. FOR THE RIVERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FISHERIES ARE CONSERVATIVELY
MANAGED ON BEING TRYING TO TALK
FAST.
THE CONSERVATIVELY MANAGED. SO
THIS THIS USE OF THE WORD OVER
FINISHED TO REFER TO ANY STOCK
THAT'S DEPLETED. IS SERIOUS
BECAUSE IT GIVES THE PUBLIC THE
WRONG IMPRESSION IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NO A FISHERY REPORTS TO
CONGRESS EVERY YEAR THERE'S NO
OVER FISHING. OCCURRING ON OUR
STOCKS ON THE WEST COAST EXCEPT
FOR TWO STOCKS THERE IN
INTERNATIONAL WATERS.
LAST I LOOKED WHICH WAS A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO RIGHT GOODNESS SO
HAVE YOU.
IF YOU DON'T MIND OFFER SOME
CONCLUDING REMARKS YES MY
CONCLUDING REMARKS IS IT THAT
I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN.
TOM WAS GOING TO BE A STILL HAD
FISHERMEN NOT A CRAB FISHERMEN.
AND EVER SINCE YOU GOT INTO
GOVERNMENT I MISSED SEEING HIM
AT THE FACT THAT DHEA THE DINNER
AND HIS. HIS SMALL ONCORHYNCHUS
TEE SHIRT. I THINK NEXT YEAR THE
MAN IS GONNA HAVE TO WEAR. IT SO
WHAT IS IT IS KIDS MY KIDS MY.
OLD ONCORHYNCHUS CHRISTMAS WHERE
YOU DON'T WORRY THAT ANYMORE
AFTER AFTER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU GUYS NEXT YEAR
I EVEN HEARD IT ALL HERE WE GOT
TO SEIZE THE DAY.
AIMED AT HE'S BRINGING IT BACK
YEAH IT'S GONNA BE VERY ECITED
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US Y THE
WAY THANK YOU FOR THOSE PERSONAL
WORDS. AS WELL VERY VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU.
I. KNOW OF IN HOME PACIFICUS
FEDERATION FISHMAN'S
ASSOCIATIONS JUST WANT TO
REITERATE OUR COMPLETE
GRATITUDE.
THEN APPRECIATION FOR THE WORK
THAT ALL THREE OF YOU GERMAN DO
ON BEHALF OF THE FLEET.
WE ARE IN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MANY THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILLS
THAT YEAR EVEN PRODUCE SENATOR
AND. WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE WHERE
ESPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF. THE
UNIVERSAL GEAR MARKING PROVISION
IN THIRTEEN OH NINE AND
RECOGNIZING THAT. UNIVERSAL
MEANS UNIVERSAL BELIEVE THAT
CRAB TRAP. WILL HAVE TO WEAR A
TAG WHEREVER HE GOES.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO PUT
TOGETHER A CUSTOM. MARKER FOR
MISSILE SO I THINK THAT WE COULD
IT BE LIKE A DOG TAG BUT YEAH HE
WEARS AROUND HIS NECK I THINK SO
I THINK THAT BE GREAT OR ON THE
YEAR.
ABSOLUTELY SO LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO PERFECT THE
BILL.
CAN AND RECOGNIZING THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE SECTION
PERTAINING TO DIRECTORS
AUTHORITIES TO IMPLEMENT THE
RAMP MAY CHANGE.
WE APPRECIATE THE SENTIMENT
EXPRESSED IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THAT. THE WORKING GROUP
OR SOME.
.
COLLABORATIVE BODIES JUDICATA
RECTOR'S AUTHORITY WE. STRONGLY
REQUEST THAT LANGUAGE OF SIMILAR
INTENT BE INCLUDED IN ANY
LANGUAGE THAT MOVES FORWARD.
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU IN THAT REGARD. I THINK
SO I THINK IT'S. TAKEN SIX SIX
RICHTER LIKE YOU SEE PRIOR TO
CLOSING COMMENTS FOR VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK FOR THE GOOD OF THE ORDER.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO COME FOR
WE WELCOME YOU TO COME FOR THE
MICROPHONE.
ALRIGHT SPRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ENOUGH TO START OUT
WITH. TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR AND AGAIN. AT THE CENTER
STONE IS INCREDIBLY BUSY. GUY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP ON ALL ISSUES OF
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE AND
WE'RE SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE. AND. WE'RE GONNA BE TECH
TEAMING UP FOR THE REMAINING
HERE AND HELP FOR YEARS AHEAD TO
SERVE FOR SURE. THANK YOU ADAM
LEGITIMATELY. HERE SITTING WITH
YOU ON A DIET SO THAT'S. THAT'S
LOVELY I HAVE NOTHING MORE THAN
ABOUT THIRTY FORTY MINUTES OF
COMMENTS TO MAKE FOLLOWING UP
GREAT HEARING APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THE INFORMATION
THAT WE TAKE IN AS WE TRY AND
MANAGE THE JEWS THAT. THAT COME
BEFORE US IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THE FISHERMEN HERE AND THE
INDUSTRY REPRESENTED WITH THE
STRUGGLES THAT YOU GO THROUGH AS
WE. LOOK AT POLICY OR OUR
OVERSIGHT OBLIGATIONS AS A
LEGISLATURE SO THANK YOU FOR ALL
FOR EING HERE FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND FOR THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS IMPARTED TODAY VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR VICE CHAIR
AT ALL JUST STARTED AND HOW IT
IS I STARTED JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU. TO ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
IN MEMORY OF COURSE AT MR
GREATER. AND WE HAVE A WHOLE
LIST OF FOLLOW UPS THAT WE'VE
BEEN KEEPING TRACK OF.
ON MY SHEET AS WELL AS MISTER
WEST LOVES IS WELL ON MR WESSELS
AS WELL. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK IN FRONT OF US WHEN IT
COMES SSUE OF URCHINS IN
SARDINES.
ISSUE OF CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
ON THE CENTRAL FRONT IN AT TIMES
AND IN THE VERY CANDID AND AS
YOU'VE SEEN IT IS NOT THE
EASIEST.
I WORK WITH SOME OF OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS IN THIS CURRENT
CLIMATE.
THAT SAID WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO PUSH FORWARD. AND WE'VE SEEN
SUCCESS BECAUSE THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT STATES WE HAVE TO
CONFORM WITH THAT.
.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR YOUR HARD
WORK AN INTEL NEXT YEAR. WE ARE
GOING TO BE JOURNEYING IT WILL
BE HAVING ANOTHER HEARING IN THE
FALL OF THIS YEAR IS WELL. IT
WILL KEEP YOU UP TO DATE ON THAT
HERE IN THE IN THE COMING MONTHS
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE IN
IN MEMORY OF THE CREATOR WE'RE
GONNA BE JOINING. THE FORTY
FIFTH ANNUAL FISHERIES FOR THANK
YOU